[inaudible]
WELCOME [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN -- I AM BEFORE I
START I'D LIKE TO THANK -- THE
COMMITTEE -- FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY WITH US ON THIS BILL
AND A HAPPY TO ACCEPT -- THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS SIDE
MENTIONED IN THE ANALYSIS.
AND LAST NIGHT THE COMMITTEE IN
MY STAFF WORKED OUT A REVISION
TO THE MIRACLE TEACHER -- MA'AM
AND I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THIS ISSUE -- AFTER THE HEARING --
AS WELL -- SO -- THIS BILL THE
OCEAN HEALTH AND THE OCEAN
RESILIENCY ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN WHICH WAS -- DESCRIBES
IN THE ANALYSIS AS A PRODUCTION
BILL AND I APPRECIATED THAT
REFERENCE THAT IN THE CHAIR HAS
A NUMBER TO IT AS THE OPENS TO
THE OCEANS -- BUT WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT IT IS A BILL --
THAT WILL MAKE OUR OCEANS --
HEALTHIER -- AND THAT WILL HELP
RESTORE --THE ECO SYSTEMS IN
OUR OCEAN THAT ARE DYING RIGHT
NOW.
AS A RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
AND OWES OCEAN ACIDIFICATION --
AND WE NEED TO TAKE AGGRESSIVE
STOPS -- TO ENSURE THE HEALTH OF
OUR OCEANS AND ECOSYSTEMS --
THIS BILL HAS EXCEPTIONALLY
BROAD SUPPORT FROM THE BAR
MENTAL COMMUNITY -- AS WELL AS
FROM PEOPLE WHO MAKE THEIR
LIVING -- AT THE CITY -- THE
LEGISLATION WILL HELP RESTORE
WATER QUALITY AND ELIMINATE
LOCAL OCEAN CITY HOT SPOTS BY
SETTING STATEWIDE ACIDITY AND
HYPOXIA.
OBJECTIVES REQUIRING THE
NOTIFICATION OF WASTEWATER
DISCHARGES AND OVERLAYING MARINE
RESERVISTS AND THERE IS A
BIOLOGICAL SIGNIFICANCE OF STATE
WATER QUALITY PROTECTED AREA.
DESIGNATIONS.
SB SIX AND I WILL ALSO HELP
RESTORE HABITATS AND ENCOURAGE
PRACTICES THAT INCREASE OUR
SEQUESTRATION OF BLUE CARBON.
INCLUDING WETLANDS WRIST
RESTORATION BENEFICIAL RE USE OF
MARINE SEDIMENTS TO BUILD
OPERATOR WETLANDS.
AND SUSTAINABLE MARICULTURE.
WE ALSONEED TO PROTECT OUR
KEYSTONE SPECIES INCLUDING THOSE
THAT COASTAL ECONOMIES RELYING
ON THE BILL WILL PROTECT WHALES
BY CODIFYING -- AN EXISTING
VOLUNTARY PROGRAM AIMED AT
PREVENTING SHIFT STARTS.
SB SIXTY NINE TAKES A NUMBER OF
LONG OVERDUE STOPS.
ABOVE A BEGINNING -- THE
REBUILDING OF OUR SALMON
FISHERIES INCLUDING PROTECTION
OF THE FORESTS STREAMS.
WERE SALMON SPAWN.
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT THESE
CHALLENGES ARE CONSTANTLY
EVOLVING -- THE BILL REQUIRED
ENGAGEMENT OF RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS ACROSS THE PUBLIC
SECTOR AND THE PRIVATE SECTOR
WHEN OCEAN CITY VACATION BY
CONDUCTING A STATEWIDE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT AND
CREATING AN ADVISORY GROUP -- I
CAN ALWAYS THIS IS A BIG AN
AMBITIOUS BILL -- AND SEVERAL
GROUPS HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERNS
I'M SURE YOU'LL HEAR FROM THEM
TODAY -- WE ARE WORKING WITH ALL
OF THEM.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK --
BOTH OF THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL AND WITH THE CONSTRUCTIVE
CRITICS -- SO THAT WE CAN -- AND
UP WITH A BILL THAT WILL NOW WE
CAN ALL BE PROUD OF ALTOGETHER --
THESE MEASURES WILL ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A STRATEGY -- AND
THE ABILITY TO MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE
OCEAN.
THE CLUSTER GREATER AMOUNTS OF
CARBON ALLOW COASTAL COMMUNITIES
TO CONTINUE THEIR WAY OF LIFE
AND OF THE FUTURE -- WITH ME
TODAY ARE TO RESTORE YOUR OF HOG
ISLAND OYSTER FARM -- NO --
OPPENHEIM WILL BE HERE HE IS
STUCK IN LINE -- WE DO SOMETHING
ABOT THAT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR WELCOME WILL
DO TO TWO MINUTES EACH FOR
OPENING WITNESSES IF YOU WANT TO
RESERVE SOME ON THE BACK AND FOR
MR UP AND I'M.
FEEL FREE.
WELL GOOD MORNING -- WANT TO
THANK THE THE THE COMMITTEE FOR
HEARING WHAT I HAVE TO SAY TODAY --
HEADS THIS IS A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD I DON'T THINK IT'S A BIG
LIFT IN MANY WAYS -- A LOT OF
THIS IS ALIGNED WITH WHAT I'M
ALREADY DOING I'VE BEEN DOING
FOR THIRTY SIX YEARS I'M --
REPRESENTING MY COMPANY HOG
ISLAND OYSTER COMPANY.
WE'VE GOT -- ARE OF FARMS IN --
DEMOLISHED BAY IN IN HUMBOLDT
BAY.
WE HAVE OUR OWN RESTAURANTS IN
THE BAY AREA -- WERE IN THE
COASTAL ENVIRONMENT -- MAKING A
LIVING.
I HAVE -- THE I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE FACT THAT WE
BECAUSE OF THE TIME WE'VE BEEN
PUTTING IN IN THIRTY SIX YEARS
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF CHANGES.
WE'VE ALSO HAVING -- BEEN GOING
THROUGH THIS -- Và HAD TO BE
DEVELOPING RESILIENCY ON OUR
PART FROM A BUSINESS POINT OF
VIEW WERE ASKING THAT THAT'S
TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION THE
RESILIENCY IS A KEY PART.
OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE
NOT ONLY -- FOR THE NEXT
GENERATIONS TO HAVE SOMETHING.
FOR THE INCOME IN COASTAL
COMMUNITIES BUT ALSO -- FOR
RESILIENCY ON FOOD SECURITY AND
I THINK THAT'S A REALLY KEY PART
THERE'S A LOT OF CHANGES GOING
ON OUT THERE RIGHT NOW WE'RE
SEEING IT.
WERE PART OF THE INTEGRATED
OCEAN OBSERVATION SYSTEMS.
AND WE WE SEE A DAY TO DAY
WHAT'S GOING ON SO I WOULD
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE GOING FORWARD.
THANKS SO MUCH.
BROUGH. ONE CHAIRED MANY MEMBERS
MILLION SHAUN BOTTLE IN THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
CALIFORNIA'S KEEPER LANCE --
I'LL KEEP THIS SHORT FOR US NO
GETS HER.
WE'VE SEEN A LOTOF DIFFERENT
TYPE OF OCEAN BILLS -- OVER THE
PAST COUPLE YEARS A LOT OF
ADAPTATION BILLS SOMEONE OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION BUT THEY WERE ALL
THEY'VE ALL BEEN VERY MUCH STUDY
BILLS RESEARCHING DIFFERENT
TOPICS -- IT IN IN MY ESTIMATE
THIS IS ON THE FIRST BILLS IT
REALLY LOOKS AT A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY -- TO ADDRESS OCEAN
ACIDIFICATION AND ADDRESS OCEAN
ON HEALTH RESILIENCE IN THE FACE
OF CLIMATE CHANGE THERE'S
NUMEROUS ACTIONABLE STEPS THAT
IS IN THIS BILL -- THAT WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA IN OUR OCEANS --
BECOME MORE RESILIENT TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THERE'S INCLUDE CREDIBLE DONE
DIFFERENT ACTIONS ON IMPROVING
WATER QUALITY THINGS THAT ARE
ARE SOMEWHAT TAKING PLACE BUT
BUT WE'RE NOT MOVING THE BALL
FIVE FAR ENOUGH A QUICK ENOUGH --
TO ADDRESS CLICK ON COMING
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS -- SO
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
AND I CAN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU HAVE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
NAME NAME AND AFFILIATION UNLESS --
YOU WANT TO DO I THROW IN ONE
MINUTE AS LONG AS LEAD WITNESS
HERE MISTER OPPENHEIM.
WELL RESERVE A MINUTE FOR YOU.
VERY GOOD WELCOME GOOD MORNING.
ON BEHALF OF THE FISHING
COMMUNITIES OF THE BECAUSE OF
CALIFORNIA.
OCEAN POLICY CAN BE VISIONARY.
AND IT CAN BE COMPREHENSIVE IN
SB SIXTY NINE IS BOTH OF THOSE
THINGS -- THIS -- THE SO CALLED
PRODUCTION BILL AS COMMITTEE
STAFF OF CALL THAT IS A IS A
WONDERFUL RECIPE FOR OCEAN
HEALTH THE CONSERVATION OF
SALMON.
WATER QUALITY AND THE
PRESERVATION OF MARINE LIFE --
ALL THE WAY UP AND DOWN THE
TROPHIC FOOD WEB FROM WALES THE
SALMON.
TO ALL THE ANIMALS THAT RELY ON
THERE THE INTEGRITY OF THEIR
POPULATIONS FOR THEIR BENEFIT AS
WELL AS HUMAN LIFE.
FISHING COMMUNITIES SEAFOOD
CONSUMERS AND ALL.
CALIFORNIANS WHO RELY ON HEALTH
THE OCEAN AND HEALTHY WATER WAYS
INLAND.
BILL BENEFIT FROM THIS BILL SO I
STRONGLY REQUEST AND I BOTH.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT --
NAME AN AFFILIATION WILL DO
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT VERY
GOOD THANKS.
A JOHN BURKE WITH PACIFIC
MERCHANT SHIPPING ASSOCIATION WE
HAVE -- AMENDED A SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED OUR ONLY CONCERN IS A
MARINE INVASIVE SPECIES PROGRAM
AND JUST TO AVOID AY
DISRUPTIONS OR REDUNDANCY
THROUGH ADMINISTRATIVE CHANGES.
THANK YOU SIR. THIRTY GEORGIA'S
ANY MAERSK INC -- WE HAVE THE
SAME ISSUES AND WE'RE ALSO
SUPPORT IF AMENDED THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANKS.
I CAN'T LIKE LIVER ON BEHALF OF
THE FEDERAL DEFENSE CENTER
SEVENTH GENERATION ADVISERS THE
HUMBLE BEE.
CISCO BEEKEEPER AND COULD --
INLAND EMPIRE WATERKEEPER ON
STRONG SUPPORT THE BILL TO
AGGREGATE THANKS SO MUCH.
M. DELFINO DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
BURGER BUT SOMEHOW FEEL THE BAY
IN THE CLEAN SEIZE LOVING
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT.
A GOOD THANKS.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SCENE.
NINE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
WE JUST MAKE A LITTLE ROOM. TO A
TO INTO HERE.
YOU GUYS WANT TO MAKE A LITTLE
ROOM UP HERE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH [inaudible]
WELCOME SIR [inaudible] ONE ONE
YOUR FAMILY OR OKAY.
THE RIGHT THERE [inaudible]
YEAH.
ARE YOU TWO MINUTES. FIVE MORTAR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS LAURIE CAMP I AM A
REGISTERED PROFESSIONAL FORSTER
AND A SMALL LAND OWNER -- IT
WITH PROPERTY IN THAT ACCOUNT --
I'M HERE TODAY I'M ALSO A MEMBER
OF THE WAS REMEMBER THE TREE
MORTALITY TASK FORCE IN
CURRENTLY SIR ON THE FORESTALL
FORCE MANAGEMENT -- TASK FORCES
ARE VOLUNTEERS SO I'VE BEEN
INTIMATELY INVOLVED WITH THE
DECISIONS -- FOR FOUR YEARS OR
MORE NOW I'M HERE TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF FORCE LANDOWNERS OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S A STATEWIDE
GROUP OF NON INDUSTRIAL LAND
OWNERS -- WE MANAGE
APPROXIMATELY THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRES OF NINE
GOSH YOU'RE TIMBERLANDS ACROSS
THE STATE IN ALL REGIONS -- WE
ARE HERE IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL IS JUST CURRY WRITTEN WITH
RESPECT TO THE FORESTRY
PROVISIONS -- I'D LIKE -- TO
OFFER A COUPLE OF COMMENTS IF I
MAY. ONE WE BELIEVE THAT THE
BILL VIOLATES THE SPIRIT OF THE
EXECUTIVE ORDERS ISSUED BY BOTH
GOVERNOR BROWN AND GOVERNOR
NEWSOME WITH RESPECT -- TO
FOREST HEALTH AND FORCE
MANAGEMENT -- WE YOU KNOW
CURRENT LAW.
PROHIBITS A TIMBER HARVESTING
PLAN FROM BEING APPROVED SO THIS
IS A DUPLICATE OF PROCESS -- IN
TERMS OF THE REVIEW TEAMS WHICH
INCLUDES -- MEMBERS OF
CALIFORNIA VISION GAME
COMMISSION I'M SORRY -- FISH AND
GAME DEPARTMENT -- CAL FIRE WHO
IN I GUESS I'D LIKE TO FOCUS ON
ON THE COST OF POTENTIAL COST TO
THIS BILL.
I FOUND A STEADY.
GOING BACK TO TWO THOUSAND THREE
THAT INDICATED THAT IF WE DID
ALL OF THE STREAM EVERITT AT
RESTORATION INCLUDING ROADS AND
OTHER THINGS WE WOULD SPEND
THREE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT'S A BEAT WITH A BILLION --
TO REMEDY THE PROBLEM OF DEALING
WITH -- THEM -- PAST OUR
PRACTICES -- BUT THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF OTHER THINGS THAT
WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT -- YOU
KNOW -- THE PLAY INTO THE ROLE
OF SALMON PROTECTION THESE
INCLUDE WATER DIVISIONS
ARTIFICIAL BARRIERS -- THE YOU
KNOW FOR OCEAN CONDITIONS AND
TWO THOUSAND FIVE AND SIX THERE
WERE.
SOME.
MAJOR ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH --
SALMON POPULATION DECLINE
RELATED OCEAN CONDITIONS.
CLIMATE IS -- CERTAINLY AN ISSUE
AND FINALLY I THINK WE NEED TO
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FOR FRACTURES
RULES HAVE CHANGED SUBSTANTIALLY --
BEGINNING IN THE EARLY TWO
THOUSANDS.
LOOTING -- THE APPROVAL OF THE
IS P. OR OUR AND THE UNDER BE
SALMON RLES IN TWO THOUSAND
NINE THOSE ARE IN EFFECT NOW
THEY ALSO.
INCLUDE THE WERE REVISED RULES
WHICH HYDROLOGICALLY DISCONNECT
OR OUR PROPERTIES WE WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK -- FOR DROPPING
THE PROVISIONS OF OF THE
FORESTRY PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
OR ALTERNATIVELY -- ON OVER
THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR. TWO
MINUTES IT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
COMMITTEE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE -- MY NAME'S
HARLAN TREMOR ON THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
LICENSE FORSTER'S ASSOCIATION
[inaudible]
BOB.
ALSO KNOWN AS C. L. FAA SHE'LL
SAY.
THE GOALS OF THE SB SIX NINE BUT
WE OPPOSE THE BILL BECAUSE
REFILL WOULD SEVERELY DISRUPT A
REGULATORY PROCESS.%
THAT IS CURRENTLY MOVING AHEAD
WITH THE LEVEL OF CONSENSUS THAT
WE DON'T OFTEN SEE.
AND ALSO -- WITH THE URGENCY
PLACED ON US BY SOCIETY.
REQUIRING REGIONAL BOARDS TO
MAKE FINDINGS THAT EACH PLAN --
WOULD BE WITHOUT SENTIMENT
IMPACT.
WOULD CREATE A BOTTLENECK IN THE
SYSTEM.
AS WATER BOARD TO BE RELUCTANT
TO MAKE SUCH FINDINGS EVEN IF
THEY AND THE OTHER REVIEW TEAM
MEMBERS -- I AGREE WITH THAT.
THE OTHER MEMBERS THE REVIEW
TEAM INCLUDE.
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
WILDLIFE.
THE CALIFORNIA GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
SOMETIMES COUNTIES.
AND OTHER AGENCIES.
THE LANDSCAPES OF THE AND WATER
WAYS ARE SLOW TO RECOVER FROM
THE LEGACY DAMAGE.
WELL WHEN THE MITIGATION SEND
REPAIRS AND UPGRADES ARE
IMPLEMENTED THE RESPONSES SLOW
CURRENT DOWNSTREAM CONDITIONS
ARE NOT NECESSARILY INDICATIVE.
OF CURRENT PRACTICES.
THEY SHOULD BE MONITORED.
BUT THEY NEED THE RESULTS IN TO
BE LOOKED AT IN A LARGE TEMPORAL
SCALE.
THE BIGGEST PROBLEM WITH THIS
BILLS REQUIREMENTS.
THAT OPERATIONS DOES NOT RESULT
IN ANY DISCHARGE THE COMMITTEE
HAS RECOGNIZED AND MAYBE THE
AUTHORS HAVE.
TO THAT OPERATIONS.
UNDER SUCH RULES.
SUCH A STREAM CROSSING UPGRADES
WITH MINIMAL DISCHARGE SHOULD
NOT BE PROHIBITED.
WE WOULD TAKE THAT ONE STEP
FURTHER.
EVERY SITUATION IS DIFFERENT.
FORRESTER'S NEED.
IN THE REVIEW TEAMS NEED THE
FLEXIBILITY. TO CONSIDER THE
COSTS AND BENEFITS OF EACH
INDIVIDUAL SITUATION.
REGARDING THE SPECIFIC RULE
CHANGES THAT ARE PROPOSES IS
TYPICALLY DONE WITH EXPERT INPUT
RESEARCH AND BAY WHICH RESULTS
AND RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE BOARD
OF FORESTRY WHICH THEN.
THE ENTERS INTO A PUBLICLY
TRANSPARENT.
PROCESS.
LEGISLATION IS NOT THE WAY TO
REQUIRE. TO SAID CANNOT BE A
COVER REQUIREMENTS AND STREAM
BUFFER DISTANCES.
WAS GONNA ASK YOU TO WRAP UP
WITH OKAY THANK IN WRAPPING UP --
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THE
PROCESS IS NOT ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS -- AT A TIME WHEN TWO
CONSECUTIVE GOVERNORS HAVE
CALLED FOR AN INCREASE IN FUEL
TREATMENT THIS WOULD RESULT IN
LESS FEEL TREATMENT BECAUSE THE
WATER BOARD.
IS NOT EQUIPPED. TO OVERSEE.
THE TO MARTHA'S PLAN REVIEW
PROCESS UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU
THANK YOU SIR AND I KNOW THERE'S
AN AMENDMENT SUGGESTED BY THE
COMMITTEE ON THIS ISSUE I
RECOGNIZE YOU.
KNOW MAY STILL OF OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS IF THOSE OF YOU'VE READ
THE ANALYSIS BE.
THE AUTHORS TAKING THE AMENDS
AND SO JUST COMMENTARY FOCUS ON
THAT BECAUSE THAT'S SORT OF
WHERE WE WANT TO DO OUR WORK ON
FORD.
BUT I WELCOME ANY.
FURTHER OPPOSITION COMMENTS AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THE MORNING I'M JENNIFER PAIR
THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS WE
REPRESENT TWENTY SEVEN PUBLIC
WATER AGENCIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE -- ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
WATER PROJECT TIME WE APPRECIATE
THAT THE COMMITTEE WORKING
THROUGH SOME OF THE ISSUES
ALREADY SO THANK YOU FOR THAT
AND WE DID MEET WITH THE PRODUCT
PROPONENTS AND YOU KNOW WE HAVE-A LOT OF ALIGNED OBJECTIVES HERE
BUT TE CONCERN REGARDING THE
NET PEN.
STUDY AND SOME OF THE THE COATED
WIRE TAX STUDIES IS THAT -- WE
IT'S NOT CONCERNED ABOUT HOW THE
SCIENCE IS ACTUALLY BEING
PROPOSED IN THE BILL AND WE ALSO
HAVE CONCERNS WITH.
LEGISLATING THIS SORT OF SCIENCE
AND THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
COLLABORATIVE IN OTHER EFFORT SO
VERY HAPPY TO KEEP WORKING
TOWARDS THESE OBJECTIVES BUT NOT
I'M A FAN OF IT IN THE
LEGISLATION I THINK IT WAS.
TO THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING NO -- CREAMERS OF
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION IN THE ANALYSIS
HOWEVER DOESN'T THOSE AMENDMENTS
WOULD NOT GO FAR ENOUGH TO
REMOVE OUR OPPOSITION.
WE'RE PARTICULARLY CONCERNED
WITH -- WHAT HAS ALREADY BEEN
STATED BUT WE HAVE NOT BEEN
SHOWN -- THE SCIENCE TO BACK UP
THAT THIS WOULD SOLVE A PROBLEM
AND WITHOUT THAT WE CAN'T I'M
HAVE A MEANINGFUL DISCUSSION
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
YOU'RE FREE TO QUEUE UP.
WE GOT A LOT GOING ON THIS
MORNING GOOD MORNING JESSICA
GEIGER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES WERE OPPOSE LESS
AMENDED -- WE'RE PARTICULARLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE PROVISIONS
RELATING TO DENITRIFICATION
PROTOCOL UNDERSTAND THAT'LL BE
ADDRESSED IN EQ BUT SUNDAY
EXPRESS OUR OPPOSITION HERE
TODAY AND LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR.
AS IT CONTINUES FOR IT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THANKS.
BECKY WITH CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL WE HAVE PARTICULAR CONCERNS
WITH THE TIMBERLAND PROVISIONS
IN THE BILL -- WE APPRECIATE THE
MEANING THAT WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHORS OFFICE AND HOPE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THOSE POVISIONS
REMOVED FROM THE BILL.
OKAY THANKS.
ANY OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
SAYING NONE WE'RE GONNA TAKE A
pHERE.
SO -- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTERS STERN YEARS TURN
HERE JONES ALLEN.
ALLEN HERE BURGESS.
MERGES HERE CABALLERO
[inaudible]
HERTZBERG HUESO.
SO HERE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY IN HERE.
OKAY VERY GOOD.
NOW WE HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE
ESTABLISHED -- NO MORE
OPPOSITION.
BRING IT BACK TO DIS QUESTIONS
MEMBERS.
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND CENTER
HUESO.
THANK YOU SHERMAN [inaudible]
I WANTED TO GIVE THIS A THOROUGH
REVIEW IS WHILE IT'S ALLOWED
HERE.
AS THEIR REVIEW IT AS POSSIBLE --
I WENT TO A FISHING THIS PAST
WEEK IN OVER IN -- MEMBER
MORNINGS -- DISTRICT AND SIR FOR
YEARS AS THE CHAIR OF THE SAN
JOAQUIN RIVER CONSERVANCY.
SO I'M I HAVE STRONG SYMPATHIES
TOWARD MAKING CERTAIN THAT.
OUR ENVIRONMENT IS CLEANED AND
LOOKED AFTER FOR US AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS.
I ALSO WANT MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WERE WE APPROACH THINGS
PRAGMATICALLY.
CAN YOU I WAS TRYING TO FIND IS.
HAS THERE BEEN A QUANTIFICATION
OF THE COST OF IMPLEMENTING THIS
REGULATORY SYSTEM OR THESE
ENHANCEMENTS I'VE HEARD NUMBERS.
KIND OF ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION --
CENTER AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK -- I MEAN WE'RE ALL TRYING
TO BALANCE THE ALL THE THE P.
NEEDS AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
REALLY PROUD TO HAVE -- ARE THE
PEOPLE WHO MAKE THEIR LIVING
FISHING -- WHO ALSO RELY ON ON
THESE RESOURCES ON THERE WE'VE
NOT BEEN TO APPROACH YET AND
THERE WILL BE -- PRICE I WILL BE
PUT ON THAT IT WILL THIS WILL
NOT BE -- THERE WILL BE A REAL
PRICE TAG ON IT -- YOU'RE HAVING
A HEALTHY OCEAN.
AFTER EVERYTHING THAT WE'VE DONE --
TO CONTAMINATE OUR OCEANS -- IS
IS NOT GOING TO BE CHEAP.
SO WE WILL CERTAINLY BE WORKING
THROUGH THOSE ISSUES AND TRYING
TO MAKE THE BILL'S EFFICIENT AS
POSSIBLE BUT THERE WILL BE A
COST.
BUT NOT JUST THOSE FUNDS THAT
ARE EXPECTED FROM THE STATE OR
FOR THE STATE WATER PROJECT BUT
ALSO TO BE BORNE BY THE
INDIVIDUAL ENTITIES FOR
REGULATORY PURPOSES.
WHAT WERE WE WILL ABSOLUTELY
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH EACH OF
THE IMPACTED -- INDUSTRIES -- AS
WELL AS THE PUBLIC AGENCIES LIKE
THE SANITATION AGENCIES WILL
WORK WITH ALL OF THEM -- WE BY
BY MY STYLE MY STAFF STYLE IS TO
BE VERY COLLABORATIVE -- BUT YOU
KNOW AT THE SAME TIME -- WE DO
NEED TO DO THINGS DIFFERENTLY
WITH RESPECT TO OUR OUR OCEANS
THEIR OTHER BILLS.
YOU KNOW AROUND DISCHARGING
WASTE WATER INTO THE OCEAN AND
THE SINGLE USE PLASTIC SETTER --
GOING TO THE OCEAN SO THIS DOES
A LOT WE NEED TO DO TO PROTECT
OUR OCEANS AND WE WILL
ABSOLUTELY WORK. TO WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS ON TO TRY TO BE AS
COOPERATIVE AS POSSIBLE HEARD --
FROM ONE OF THE FOLKS THAT
OFFERED A COMMENT.
WHERE IS THE SCIENCE TO JUSTIFY
THAT THESE?
ENHANCEMENTS WILL PROVE THE
METRICS THAT WILL ACHIEVE THAT
AND A DESIRE GOAL.
I THINK THERE'S PLENTY OF
SCIENCE AND IT'S A VERY -- BROAD
QUESTION I'LL.
ASK OF EITHER MY WITNESSES WANT
TO COMMENT ON THAT BUT THAT THAT
ENCOMPASSES A LOT OF DIFFERENT --
IN AND IT WON'T LET ME LET ME
REFINE IT A BIT -- I HADN'T SEEN
IN THE MATERIALS THAT I'VE COME
ACROSS -- IS THIS.
INDUSTRY SOME ASSUMED AND
APPRECIATED -- IMPROVEMENTS THAT
WOULD ACHIEVE THE DESIRED GOAL.
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTION
SENATOR.
THE THE ANSWER THE SHORT ANSWER
IS YES THERE'S A WEALTH OF
SCIENTIFIC LITERATURE PRODUCED
BY AGENCIES AS WELL AS ACADEMICS
THAT DEMONSTRATE UNEQUIVOCALLY
THAT.
THE KINDS OF FOREST PRACTICE
CHANGES THAT ARE INCLUDED IN SB
SIXTY NINE WOULD PROVIDE WATER
QUALITY BENEFITS AND FISHERIES
PUBLIC TRUST RESOURCE BENEFITS
OF THOSE THE SCIENTIFIC STUDIES.
EXIST WE'RE IN THE PROCESS OF
AGGREGATING THEM AND WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSIONS WITH.
WITH THE COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE
RAISED THEIR OPPOSITION IN THE
PAST THOSE CONVERSATIONS.
WILL CONTINUE SIR AND I
APPRECIATE IT AND THAT'S I THINK
THAT'S WHERE I MY I'M ULTIMATELY
LEANING IS THIS IDEA THAT MAYBE
WE SHOULD.
AGGREGATE THAT MATERIAL AND HAVE
THESE CONVERSATIONS.
EARLIER THAN IN ITS FINAL FORM
OF PROPOSED LEGISLATION OR ITS
INTRODUCTORY FORM OF PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
I REPRESENT -- AREAS WHERE
THERE'S A LOT OF TIMBER A LOT OF
FORESTRY -- BECAUSE OF ALL THE
NORTHERN PORTIONS OF OF MY AREA
SO NATURALLY YOU KNOW I'M I'M
CONCERNED ON HELP.
HELLO THIS IS IMPACTING THEM.
BUT THERE'S A QUOTE HERE THAT I
THOUGHT KIND OF SUMS UP -- THIS
FROM THE STATE WATER CONTRACTORS.
SB SIXTY NINE MANDATES A GNETIC
TESTING PROTOCOL THAT USES
PERCENTAGE BASED TAGGING AND
ASSIGNS THE COST OF THE PROTOCOL
TO THE STATE WATER PROJECT.
IDENTIFYING A PUBLIC FUNDING
SOURCE INCREDIBLE INSTITUTION
UNDERTAKE INAPPROPRIATE STUDY IS
A MORE APPROPRIATE COURSE OF
ACTION AND HAVING THE
LEGISLATURE EMBARK.
ON THE MICROMANAGEMENT OF
HATCHERIES AND TAGGING
TECHNOLOGIES.
I THINK THAT IN CAPSULE IT'S AT
LEAST A BIT OF WHAT I'M.
TRYING TO APPRECIATE HERE IS
THAT MAYBE WE'RE JUST A LITTLE
BIT.
TO FAR AS THE HORSES TOO MUCH
HEAD OF THE CART I'M WONDERING.
HOW DO WE BRING ALL THIS
INFORMATION TOGETHER BECAUSE IF
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THIS IS
INTRODUCTION BILL -- THAT REALLY
IS I THINK SAYS SOMETHING THAT
WERE INCLUDING SO MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS -- IN THE MAYBE
MERITORIOUS ABSOLUTELY BUT HOW
DO WEBRING THEM TO BEAR AT THE
SAME APPROPRIATE TIME SO THEY'RE
PERFECTLY RIGHT FOR US TO REVIEW --
ALL IN MY COMMENTS THERE BUT I
APPRECIATE THE GOALS THAT YOU'RE
PURSUING PRESIDENT AND I
APPRECIATE THAT AND OF COURSE IS
WERE IN OUR FIRST.
BY HEARING OF A WILL BE A LINK
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AND
WE'VE ALREADY YOU KNOW EXCEPT
THE NUMBER OF AMENDMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE -- I AM I'M
CONFIDENT WE WORKING.
COLLABORATIVELY WITH -- CENTER
ALAN'S COMMITTEE AND WE'RE GONNA
I I THINK I I THINK WE'RE GONNA
MAKE THE BILL BETTER BETTER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADMIT THAT CENTER WAYS
OF THANK YOU EN AND I APPRECIATE
THE EXAMPLE THE THIRD TRADUCTION
BUT IF YOU'RE VEGAN THERE'S
NOTHING AND TRADUCTION FAURIA.
GOOD OF IT YOU GET A V. I. P.
THERE'S THERE BE GOING TO THE
CONCERT.
HI THERE OKAY.
YEAH.
WELL IT IT SAYS THAT IT'S IN THE
BONE TO THE BONUS TRACK AND THAT
WOULD BE A FRANCISCO WE CAN
PRODUCE THAT THE BONE SALARY
[inaudible]
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS IS A A
MASSIVE BILL.
IT'S ENORMOUS AND IF IT'S
LEANING TOWARD.
BETTER STEWARDSHIP BY I WANT TO
VOTE FOR IT.
I'M WONDERING WHAT IS THE ORIGIN
OF TIS BILL BECAUSE YOUR YOUR
SHIFT IN.
A REGULAR TERRY OVERSIGHT FROM
ONE DEPARTMENT TO ANOTHER YEAR
YOU'RE MOVING THINGS AROUND IN A
WAY THAT'S IF FROM FROM JUST.
A CURSORY REVIEW IT SEEMS VERY
AGGRESSIVE TO ME.
AND WHEN I LOOK AT THE LIST OF
SUPPORTERS.
AND OPPOSERS IT MAKES ME A
LITTLE BIT NERVOUS ABOUT WHAT
THE INTENT.
OF THE BILL REALLY AS AND IN
SOME CASES WE ALWAYS WANT TO
STREAMLINE THE REGULATORY
PROCESS WE WANT TO MAKE IT USER
FRIENDLY -- BUT WE ALSO -- WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
OBJECTIVES ARE ARE ACHIEVED IN
THAT WE'RE REALLY PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT OUT THERE AND NOT
JUST.
CREATE INIT SO -- SOME
INDUSTRIES COULD NO LONGER
EXISTS IN CALIFORNIA THAT'S JUST
MY CONCERN HERE IN LOOKING AT
SOME AREAS THAT MAKE ME WONDER
WHY IT WHERE DD YOU GET RID --
IDEAS FOR SHIFTING -- REGULATORY
VIEW FROM ONE AGENCY TO ANOTHER
I MEAN WE CAN WE CAN GET INTO
THE DETAILS AND MAYBE THAT'S
THAT WOULD TAKE. TOO MUCH OF THE
DISCUSSION HERE BUT GENERALLY
WHERE DID YOU GET THESE IDEAS
FROM I MEAN AE THESE ARE.
ARE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS FROM
SOME -- INDEPENDENT STUDY OR
EVERYONE WHERE DISCOMFORT.
THIS WAS -- ACTUALLY REPRESENTS
PROBABLY ABOUT A A YEAR AND A
HALF WORTH OF WORK THIS WASN'T
JUST.
YOU KNOW.
RIGHT A BILL IN A DAY AND
ANOTHER THREE MINUS IS NOT A
BILL THAT WAS WRITTEN A DAY I'LL
I'LL GIVE MY MY MY OFFICE WORKS --
INTENSELY FOR ABOUT A YEAR AND A
HOUSE -- WITH -- IN AND IT
STARTED WITH A FEW DIFFERENT
IDEAS ABOUT HOW TO IMPROVE.
OCEAN HEALTH AND THE HEALTH OF
YOUR ECOSYSTEMS AROUND HELPED
AND OTHER.
YOU KNOW -- ECOSYSTEMS THAT ARE
DYING -- IN THE OCEAN -- AND IT
AND WORKING WITH AN EXTENSIVE --
SO STAKEHOLDERS AND AND I THINK
I'M PRETTY PROUD OF THE OF THE
SUPPORT THAT WE HAVE.
ARE FOR THE BILL I CAN ALWAYS
IT'S AN AGGRESSIVE BUILD BUT
WERE -- FRANKLY WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE COLLAPSE
OF OUR OF SO MANY ECOSYSTEMS.
IT WOULD WE ARE WHO WERE IN AN
EMERGENCY AND SO -- YOU KNOW AS
I MENTIONED BEFORE WE ARE --
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
IMPACTED INDUSTRIES WERE NOT
TRYING TO DRIVE ANYONE OUT OF
BUSINESS OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT.
WE WANT TO TRY TO MAKE IT WORK
AND AND YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO DO THAT WORK -- BUT
YES WE DO -- YOU KNOW WE'RE
WE'RE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
STUDY.
A LOT OF ANALYSIS WE WE KNOW
WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND IT AND
IT IS AN EMERGENCY AND WERE --
AM IT'S TIME TO TAKE.
STEPS IN TERMS OF REASSIGNMENT
AGENCIES THERE WAS THE ONE
CONCERN ABOUT THE BALLAST WATER
AND STATE LANDS -- COMMISSION
AND WE BLOCK IT OUT WE CAN HAVE
PERHAPS HAVE A CONVERSATION
OFFLINE BUT WE WANTED TO TRY TO
MASON IS ALSO BEING ADMINISTERED
AS EFFECTIVELY AS POSSIBLE.
SENATOR MET MET RESPOND YOUR
COMMON QUESTION BRIEFLY I WAS
JUST GONNA WRAP UP AND SAY ASK
THAT SOME OF THAT INFORMATION
THAT -- HI LISA IS THE ANY OF
THE STUDIES OR ANY OF OF OF ANY
WORKING WORKING GROUP OF
PARTICULARLY I GUESS WE'LL.
WE'LL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU AND SEE
IF WE ARE HAPPY TO PROVIDE
WHATEVER WOULD BE HELPFUL AND
ALL.
OF SUPPORT YOU WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER HUESO CENTER
ALLEN DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION
COMMENT TWEET [inaudible]
THEN.
AN INMATE MAKE GAS HERE COMES OF
THE PRODUCTION -- COMMENT BUT IT
THEY'VE BEEN YOU MISS OUT ON MY
OWN IT'S A IT'S LIKE BEATING A
DEAD PRODUCTION -- BUT AT BUT I
WANT I MEAN I WANTED TO SAY I I
YOU KNOW IN TERMS OF ALL THESE
ANIMAL METAPHORS WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT PUTTING THE CART BEFORE
THE HORSE I THINK THAT THE ISSUE
IS -- SO GRAVE AND I I
UNDERSTAND THIS IS GOING TO BE A
A BIG WORK IN PROGRESS BUT
YOU'RE TOUCHING UPON SOME
ENORMOUSLY IMPORTANT
ENVIRONMENTAL ISSUES THAT WE'VE
BEEN LOOKING AT VERY CLOSELY
TEACH YOU COMMITTEE ON THIS
COMMITTEE.
I JUST COMMEND YOU FOR ONCE
AGAIN -- BITING OFF A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL AND AND BIG BILL I
MEAN YOU DO THAT A LOT A LOT OF
DIFFERENT AREAS -- BUT IT -- I
THINK IT'S TESTAMENT TO YOUR
FEARLESSNESS AND YOUR YOUR FOCUS
ON SOME OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES
THAT ARE FACING OUR STATE NINE
I'M I'M LOOKING FOR THIS BILL
COMING OVER THE Q. COMMITTEE
INTO SOME FOR THEIR WORK WITH
ALL OF YOU ON THIS.
THANK YOU SENATOR.
THERE ARE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CEREMONY YES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR NO REAL
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS RIGHT NOW I
ALSO JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR REPRESENTING. TWO HUNDRED
MILES OF COASTLINE -- I WOULD
UNDERSCORE THE COMMENT THAT WE
FACE AN URGENCY.
MOM WERE BEHIND WERE BEHIND THE
CURVE RIGHT NOW IN WE DO NEED TO
BE BOLD.
WE DO NEED TO GET IT RIGHT.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR COMMITMENT
TO CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH THOSE
WHO HAVE CONCERNS -- ALSO
APPRECIATE THE CHAIR IN THE
STAFF FOR BRINGING.
A NEW TERMINOLOGY THAT CAN NOW
BECOME A ESTABLISHED LEGISLATIVE
MONIKER FOR CERTAIN TYPES OF
THANK YOU.
WE ACTUALLY WERE WORKING ON A
NEW ONE SO WE THINK THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IS NOT A LAND BASED
ANIMALS THE WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU WRAP AND OYSTER INSIDE A
SALMON INSIDE THE GRASS INSIDE A
KELP BED HOPEFULLY YOU ACTUALLY
HAVE A SUSHI SENATOR.
YEAH.
BLUE CARBON SANDWICH -- SO -- WE
APPRECIATE ALL YOUR HARD WORK
WITH THE COMMITTEE I DON'T WANT
TO CATCH UP CENTER MONEY IT
ANYTHING MORE THERE -- SIR.
YES THANK YOU I'M SORRY I AM I
SHERRY PEMBERTON WITH THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND WE DON'T
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL AND
SUPPORTER OPPOSITION AND I
MISSED THE WINDOW WHEN YOU TOOK
OVER IN OPPOSITION.
WIENER.
YES YES I HAVE BUT I JUST WANTED
TO SPEAK IN REGARD TO THE
BALLAST WATER PROVISION IN OUR
MARINE INVASIVE SPECIES PROGRAM
WE DO HAVE A LOT OF
COLLABORATION AND WE WORK WITH A
TECHNICAL ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
WHEN WE DO THIS WORK AND DEVELOP
OUR TREATMENT TECHNOLOGY REPORT --
WE HAVE SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS TO CREATE A
COMMISSION WE JUST WANT TO KNOW
MORE ABOUT HOW THAT MIGHT WORK --
HOW WILL BE FUNDED AND WHETHER
IT MIGHT BE A TAD REDUNDANT
GIVEN THE EXISTING TECHNICAL
ADVISORY GROUP THAT WE WORK WITH
WHICH IS EXCEEDINGLY BROAD?
AND HAS A VAST ARRAY OF
STAKEHOLDERS -- WE ALSO JUST
WANTED TO MENTION THE FUNDING
OUR PROGRAM IS FUNDED THROUGH
VESSEL FEES AND WE EXPECT THAT --
REVENUE STREAM TO POTENTIALLY
DECLINE IN COMING YEARS BECAUSE
OF RECENT FEDERAL LEGISLATION.
THEY WERE JUST VERY COGNIZANT OF
THAT AS IT RELATES TO THIS
POTENTIAL DO COMMISSION TO LOOK
AT THAT.
THE SCIENCE AND THE OTHER DATA
ABOUT THE AVAILABILITY OF
TREATMENT TECHNOLOGY FOR BALLAST
WATER DISCHARGE PERFORMANCE
STANDARDS I THANK YOU IN COLLEGE
EYES FOR BEING NO NO NO APOLOGY
THANK YOU FOR THE THE
CONTRIBUTION AND WHAT I KNOW
WILL BE ENGAGING IN SOME OF
THESE ISSUES TO ANY Q..
GOING FORWARD -- AS WELL AS
LOOKING AT THAT COMMISSION ISSUE
AND MAKING SURE THERE'S SOME
SYNERGY -- SO APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS -- WE SHOULD THE
BOLDNESS COMPREHENSIVENESS YOUR
DILIGENCE WITH YOUR STAFF
WORKING WITH COMMITTEE --
FUNDING IS EMERGES A THEME THEIR
NUMBER DIFFERENT VEHICLES THEIR
MONEY AND I BROUGHT UP IN BUDGET
SAID TO A NUMBER OF TIMES A LACK
OF EMPHASIS.
ON FUNDING AROUND THE OCEANS
FROM G. G. R. F. WHICH IS A BIG
ISSUE THERE'S A CLIMATE
RESILIENCY BOND WE'RE LOOKING AT
WITH SB FORTY FIVE SO.
HOPEFULLY IS YOU START TO IRON
OUT SOME OF THIS SORT OF
REGULATORY TOOLS.
WE CAN LOOK AT SORT OF HOW TO
WRAP.
OF FUNDING FRAMEWORK AND REALLY
MAKE A DENT THIS YEAR I AGREE
IT'S AN EMERGENCY AND I KNOW
THERE KINGS TO BE WORKED OUT --
THE BASICS I THINK ARE PRETTY
CLEAR WHEN IT COMES TO SAY
INLAND IMPACTS.
ON THE OCEAN SEDIMENT THAT FLOWS
TO THE SEA.
HAS AN IMPACT DEPENDING ON WHAT
HE CARRIES WITH IT ON THE
CERTIFICATION LEVELS ON THE
ECOSYSTEMS THERE HOW MUCH FROM
WHAT STREAMS.
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE THESE ARE ALL
TENSIONS TAT THAT WILL FACE
GOING FORWARD BUT I THINK THE
BASICS OF THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN
ONE DOESN'T STAY INLAND IT.
IT IS ALL ONE CONNECTED
ECOSYSTEM IS IS PRETTY
ESTABLISHED SO.
WITH THAT I I TO ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE AN AYE AYE AYE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY THANK YOU.
THE QUESTION I HAVE A VERY GOOD
OUT WILL ENTERTAIN A MOTION --
WHICH WOULD BE A VERY GOOD SO
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED --
TO COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY PLEASE CALL THE VOTE.
CENTERS STERN HI STERN AYE JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BURGESS FORGES SNOW
COVER EURO HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY NINE BILLS ON CAREER WILL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL -- FOR TO
CENTER WHITE HOUSE KEY STEP
RIGHT UP [inaudible]
CLIMATE RESILIENCY.
LET'S JUST KEEP IT GOING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SO LET ME START BY
AGREED TO TAKE THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS AND ALSO THANK THE
CHAIR FOR JOINING MUSICAL AUTHOR
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
WE'VE SEEN THE TERRIBLE EFFECTS
OF THE CHANGING.
CLIMATE AND HOW SEVERELY CAN
CONSUME DESTROYER COMMUNITIES
AFFECT THE ECONOMY AND LEAD TO
LOSS OF LAW PROPERTY IN LIFE NOW
CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH CLIMATE
CHANGE ASSESSMENT.
POINTS TO THAT AN INEVITABLE
SITUATION DRIER CONDITIONS IN
THE FUTURE INTERRUPTED BY LARGER
INTENSE.
STORM BURST THAT INCREASE THE
RISK OF FLOODS WE NEED THIS WELL
COORDINATED STRATEGY BASED ON
THE LATEST SCIENCE CAN ABLE OUR
STATE TO BE RESILIENT ENOUGH TO
MEET THESE INCREDIBLE --
CHALLENGES NOW FOR THOSE WHO
WEREN'T HERE IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN I AUTHORED SB
TWENTY FORTY SIX WHICH ADDRESSED
THE LACK OF COMPREHENSIVE AND
COORDINATED CLIMATE ADAPTATION
PLANNING BETWEEN THE STATE THE
REGION'S AND LOCAL ENTITIES
CALIFORNIA STATE DOES A PRETTY
GOOD JOB HORIZONTALLY.
TALKING TO THE OTHER DEPARTMENTS
THIS BILL SB ONE SIX EIGHT IS
THE NEXT LOGICAL STEP IN THE
PROCESS HE CREATES THE CHIEF.
RESILIENCE OFFICER WITHIN THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH
STATUTORILY ESTABLISHING THIS --
CHIEF OFFICER WHO WOULD LEAD TO
STAY STATEWIDE.
EFFORTS TO MANAGE OUR ADAPTATION
THROUGH THE CHIEF RESILIENT
OFFICER DID FIVE THREE COUNCIL
AND STAFF WILL COORDINATE WILL
FACILITATE COORDINATION.
WITH THE STATE IN THE REGIONS
AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS IN EFFORTS
TO ADOPT TO THE IMPACT OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THE BILL ALSO
INCLUDES MEMBERS -- WITH
ADDITIONAL EXPERTISE FOR THE
ADVISORY COUNCIL AND SECTORS TO
FOUR YEAR TERMS AND I URGE AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU -- WHAT THIS IS IN
SUPPORT?
ELDORADO WITH CHRIS STRATEGIES
ON BEHALF OF THE CITY OF SAN
JOSE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL MASON THE PACIFIC FOR A
STRESS TO WOULD NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL SUPPORT POSITION BUT
CLEARLY THERE HE' BEAUTIFUL
COORDINATION HONOR ADAPTATION
EFFORTS IN SUPPORT OF A MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANKS.
GOOD MORNING GEORGE UNDER OCEAN
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANKS.
FOR GOOD MORNING ERIN RODRIGUEZ
WITH THE UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
TING OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY
OPPOSITION.
TING THAT WILL BRING IT BACK TO
THE DIS MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS CONCERNS.
EXCLAMATIONS.
MISTER VICE CHAIR.
WHICH IS WHICH WOULD HELP -- I'M
SORRY ALL RIGHT HAVE MADE I
DON'T.
TRY CENTER MORE JUST.
BY THAT.
THE MODEM OF HAVE WE HEARD FROM
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE ON THIS
ISSUE AT ALL.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THEM BUT
I HAVE AN HAS HE ENDORSED THE
BILL NOT YES.
THE REASON I ASK IS IT TO ME
THIS SOUNDS LIKE A MANAGEMENT
ISSUE.
THE CREATION OF POSITIONS --
ESPECIALLY ONES THAT I THINK
ALREADY HAVE LEADERSHIP IN THEIR
CURRENT CAPACITY.
AND I'VE THE NATURALLY ASSUME
THIS IS MORE OF AN EXECUTIVE
STYLE DECISION RATHER THAN A
LEGISLATIVE ONE I'D FIGURED I'D
ASK WILL REMEMBER THE OFFICE OF
PLANNING RESEARCH IS SERVES AT
THE PLEASURE OF THE GOVERNOR --
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO HERE IS
STATUTORILY CREATED CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER ON ADAPTATION
BECAUSE WE THINK IT'S SUCH A BIG
DEAL AND IN WELL THE STATE WAS
DOING A WONDERFUL JOB WITH THE
CLIMATE ACTION TEAM?
TALKING AMONG THE DIFFERENT
DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
THEY WEREN'T.
TALKING VERTICALLY AND THE GAME
THE ACTION IS HAPPENING AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL IN THE REGION LEVEL
AND THIS IS GOING TO BE
STATUTORILY DISK.
THIS SENATE AND THE LEGISLATURE
SETTING UP THAT PERSON THAT'S
GOING.
TO FINAL THE MONEY BUT FINAL
FINAL DE THE ADAPTIVE EFFORTS --
THROUGH THE THE GOVERNOR'S --
PLANNING AND RESEARCH -- PLACE
THAT'S THAT'S THE IDEA.
I FIGURED ON DOWN ON THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE WOULD WOULD
HAVE A OPINIONS ON EXECUTIVE
MANAGEMENT BUT THANK YOU BYE.
VERY GOOD OTHERS CRAMOND
COMMENTS QUESTIONS SEEING NONE
[inaudible]
GREAT BILL.
THANK YOU ARE YOU CLOSE VERY
GOOD.
THE MOTION WELL ENTERTAIN A
MOTION ACTUALLY THIS POINT.
THIS MOVE BY SENATOR MINING THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS STERN ALL RIGHTS
STERN AYE JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN ALLEN AYE PORCHES.
OR JUST NO CABALLERO HERTZBERG
HUESO [inaudible]
YES HI.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY MONEY
HIGH THE BILLS ON CALL.
FORTY TWO THANK YOU -- MISTER
VICE CHAIR CAN I GIVE YOU THIS
GAVEL I'M GONNA GO TRY TO
PRESENT SB ONE REAL.
QUICKLY HERE THANK YOU.
YOU TELL ME WHO WERE TAKEN NEXT --
SP ONE SINNER RECKONS PRO TO
MAKE ENDS.
YEAH I'M YOU'RE PRESENTING -- I
MISSED OKAY I'VE GOT YOU ALL
RIGHT.
JUST STEPPING CLOSER STERN THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
WE MIGHT GO TO SETTLE HERE WE
GOOD HI KAY MORNING.
YEAH.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE IS THE ALL
RIGHT.
FORGET STARTED I'M ALRIGHT
WITHOUT MY COUNSEL I'M HERE.
PRESENTING SB ONE TO ALL THIS
MORNING THANK YOU MISTER VICE
CHAIR -- THIS IS THE SECOND
COMMITTEE NOW WE'VE BEEN BEFORE
AND THE SECOND YEAR WE'VE
UNFORTUNATELY HAD TO KERRY THIS
MEASURE AND I SAY IT'S
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE AS A STATE I
DON'T THINK WE WANT TO BE PUT.
IN THIS POSITION -- BUT I THINK
WE'VE BEEN FORCED -- TO GIVEN
THE ACTIONS IN WASHINGTON OVER
THIRTY FOUR DIFFERENT.
CLEAN AIR WATER ENDANGERED
SPECIES -- WORKER SAFETY
STANDARDS HAVE BEEN -- WEEKEND
OR ELIMINATED.
KEY TO BORDERS ON ON EVERYTHING
FROM THE WATERS THE U. S. RULE
TO THE CLEAN WATER ACT CLEAN AIR
ACT STANDARDS IMPORTATION OF
IVORY -- BODY PARTS OF
THREATENED SPECIES SUCH AS
ELEPHANTS AND RHINOS.
MS WELL AS AN EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT ADOPTED -- IT WAS W. STOP
DISCLOSING TOXIC HAZARDS IN THE
WORKPLACE THE DIRECTLY AFFECTS
THE HELL THE WORKERS.
THESE ARE ALL ACTIONS COMING OUT
OF WASHINGTON SO THE PREMISE OF
THIS BILL [inaudible]
IS THAT.
WE CAN'T AFFORD TO GO BACKWARDS
THERE'S A LOT OF PROGRESS TO BE
MADE WHEN IT COMES TO WORKPLACE
SAFETY WHEN IT COMES TO TACKLING
CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN IT COMES TO
CLEANING UP.
OUR OCEANS OUR WATER OUR AIR OUR
LAND IS BE HEARD FROM NUMEROUS
AUTHORS EARLIER -- SO PROGRESS
REMAINS BUT WE AT LEAST CAN
ALLOW THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
UNDER CUT.
OUR STATE'S PLENARY POWER TO
PROTECT ITS HEALTH AND SAFETY --
TO ACTUALLY MAKE SURE CITIZENS
CAN.
LIVE HERE -- AND AFFORD TO BREED
HERE -- AND DRINK THE WATER HERE.
AND SO WE CONSIDER THIS A TYPE
OF INSURANCE POLICY THAT
HOPEFULLY WE WON'T HAVE TO
EXERCISE -- BUT IF NECESSARY --
THIS BILL WOULD AUTHORIZE STATE
AGENCIES TO STEP IN AND AT LEAST
ENFORCE THE BASELINE STANDARDS
THAT WE LEFT AT THE END OF THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
WE KNOW THE FEDERAL STANDARDS
ARE OFTEN WEAK -- EVEN EVEN WHEN
IT'S A SOLID PRESIDENT WHO
ACTUALLY BELIEVES IN SCIENCE BUT
IN THIS CASE.
WE'RE FACING ADMINISTRATION AND
FRANKLY CONGRESS THAT THAT -- WE
FEEL IS A RISK -- THIS IS NOT
INTENDED TO POKE ANYONE IN THE
EYE -- BACK IN DC AND IN FACT WE
WHICH WE WERE IN THIS FIGHT IN
THE FIRST PLACE BUT HERE WE ARE
AND WE'RE GONNA MOVE FORWARD AND
ASSERT OUR PLENARY POWER AND DO
WE HAVE TO DO TO PROTECT OUR
PEOPLE SO.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I THOUGHT.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KIM
DELFINO AND THE CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR FOR DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE WERE -- NATIONAL
ORGANIZATION BUT BASED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WITH ABOUT TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY NINE
THOUSAND MEMBERS AND SUPPORTERS
IN CALIFORNIA -- WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT SB ONE THE THREAT TO
CALIFORNIA'S AIR WATER AND
WILDLIFE IS REAL -- IT JUST IN
FEBRUARY THE U. S. BUREAU OF
RECLAMATION RELEASED DOCUMENTS
THAT JUSTIFY LOOSENING THE
RESTRICTIONS ON PROTECTING THE
DELTA.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT -- IMPERIL
POPULATIONS OF DELTA SMELT AND
MIGRATING SALMON AND WE EXPECT
THAT A NEW SET OF DELTA EXPORT
RULES WILL BE IN PLACE BY THE
SUMMER AND THEY WILL BE WEAKER.
THAN THE CURRENT FEDERAL
PROTECTIONS OF FURTHER ON OUR
PUBLIC LANDS WERE SEEN PROPOSALS
TO WEEKEND EXISTING WILDLIFE
PROTECTIONS -- IN ON PLAN SUCH
AS THE DESERT RENEWABLE ENERGY
CONSERVATION PLAN THAT COVERS
NEARLY TEN MILLION ACRES OF LAND
MANAGEMENT PLAN.
FORNEY HAS A LOT TO LOSE IF THE
IF IF THE CURRENT -- RIGHT ROLL
BACKS ARE SUCCESSFUL ACCORDING
TO NATURE SERVE CLIFORNIA'S THE
MOST BIOLOGICALLY DIVERSE STATE
IN THE NATION AND NOT HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF ENDEMIC
SPECIES.
WHICH OUR SPECIES FOUND NOWHERE
ELSE ON THE PLANET.
IT CALIFORNIA IS ALSO HOME TO
THE THIRD HIGHEST NUMBER OF
EXTINCT SPECIES AND THE SECOND
HIGHEST PERCENTAGE OF SPECIES AT
RISK.
AND ON OUR FEDERAL LANDS WHICH
ARE VERY CONCENTRATED WITH
WILDLIFE THE ENCOMPASSES NEARLY
HALF OF OUR STATE.
AND THAT'S ROLL BACKS IN
PROTECTIONS FOR WILDLIFE HABITAT
AND PUBLIC LANDS WILL HAVE A
PROFOUND AND COSTLY AFFECT ON
CALIFORNIA.
EXCEPT THAT THESE ROLL BACKS
DON'T JUST RIGHT IN CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE THE THREAT THEY POSE A
THREAT TO INTERNATIONAL.
INTERNATIONAL WILDLIFE AND
UNDERMINE IMPORTANT LAWS THAT
WE'VE ENACTED HERE IN CALIFORNIA
TO PROTECT INTERNATIONAL
WILDLIFE.
SPECIFICALLY THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION HAS LIFTED A BAN
ON IMPORTING SPORT HUNTED
TROPHIES OF ELEPHANTS FROM
CERTAIN AFRICAN COUNTRIES.
AND THE FISHER WALLACE SERVICES
ALSO ISSUED AN UNKNOWN NUMBER OF
PERMITS FOR LION TROPHIES SINCE
AUTHORIZING IMPORTS FROM
ZIMBABWE AND ZAMBIA -- THAT WERE
FIRST ALLOWED IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THERE'S AT
LEAST -- SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
SAYING HERE IS THAT WHAT
CALIFORNIA HAS ENACTED LAWS TO
PER PROTECT OUR WILDLIFE AND IN
PARTICULAR TO PERMIT TRADE.
ONLINE AN ELEPHANT PARTS --
THERE IS DEFINITE CONCERN THAT
THESE ROBOTS ARE GONNA HAVE
IMPACT SB ONE WILL ADDRESS THESE
ISSUES BY SETTING A BASELINE OF
PROTECTION FOR CALIFORNIA'S
WILDLIFE.
BY SIMPLY REQUIRING THAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
IN THE FISHING GAME COMMISSION
REVIEW ACTIONS BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. TO DETERMINE IF THEY
WEEKEND PRIOR PROTECTIONS AND
THEN TAKE ACTIONS TO ESTABLISH
THOSE PROTECTIONS IF THE
STANDARDS WERE WEEKEND.
THE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS TO SB
ONE WOULD ALSO ADDRESSED THE
ISSUE OF ILLEGAL IMPORTATION OF
WILDLIFE PARTS BY CONFIRMING
THAT THE TRANSPORTATION SALE OR
PURCHASE OF FISHER WHILE I FOR
PLANTS TAKEN POSSESSED.
TRANSPORTED OR SOLD IN VIOLATION
OF FEDERAL STATE OR AN
INTERNATIONAL LAW ARE STILL A
VIOLATION OF LAW.
AND THEN THE LAST AMENDMENT THAT
WAS PROPOSED REGARDING SPECIES
SUBSPECIES AND DISTINCT
POPULATION SEGMENTS IS REALLY
JUST A CLARIFYING -- AMENDMENT
THAT WOULD TRUE UP -- THIS UP
BILL WITH THE FEDERAL ESA.
SB ONE IS AN IMPORTANT
PROTECTION FOR OUR STATES
WILDLIFE AND IT IS A COMMON
SENSE PROTECTION AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR SIAM LINDA
ESCALANTE WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL OR AN
RTC I'M HERE ON BEHALF.
OF OUR NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND MEMBERS AND
SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA. TO
EXPRESS OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR
SB.
ONE WHICH IS DESIGNED TO
MAINTAIN CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL AND PUBLIC PUBLIC
HEALTH AND WORKER SAFETY
PROTECTIONS.
AGAINST THE RECKLESS TAX FROM
OUR FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
SB ONE WOULD INCORPORATE INTO X.
TO STATE LAW EXISTING FEDERAL
STANDARDS UNDER THE CLEAN AIR
ACT THE CLEAN WATER ACT THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER ACT AND THE
WORKER SAFETY LAWS.
IF THEY ARE ROLLED BACK.
THOSE STANDARDS CURRENTLY
APPLYING TO AFFECTED INDUSTRIES
THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE THAT.
BUT IT DOES MAINTAIN THE STATUS
QUO IN CALIFORNIA IF FORCES IN
DC SUCCEED A ROLLING BACK THOSE
CRITICAL PROTECTIONS.
AS YOU WILL NOW CALIFORNIA'S
ALREADY ARE SUFFERING FROM THE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE THEM CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
STRUGGLE WITH POOR AIR QUALITY.
AND WATER QUALITY DESPITE
INCREASINGLY FREQUENT AN
UNPRECEDENTED NATURAL DISASTERS
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
CONTINUES TO PUSH THE ANTI
ENVIRONMENT AGENDA THAT BENEFITS
POLLUTERS AT THE EXPENSE OF OUR
NATION'S MOST IMPORTANT ASSETS.
OUR PEOPLE AND OUR NATURAL
RESOURCES.
ALLOWING POLLUTION FROM OTHER
STATES TO CROSS STATE LINES AT
HIGHER LEVELS WITHOUT
CONSIDERING THE DANGERS HEALTH
IMPACTS THIS COULD HAVE ON
FAMILIES. TO DISMANTLING
PROTECTIONS FOR LOCAL DRINKING
WATER SUPPLIES RIVER SINCE
ESTUARIES.
ALLOWING MORE TOXIC POLLUTANTS
SUCH AS ARSENIC LEAD AND MERCURY
TO BE DISCHARGED INTO OR SURFACE
WATERS. TO QUIETLY PROPOSING TO
LITERALLY CHANGE THE DEFINITION
OF AMBIENT AIR TO ALLOW
COMPANIES TO CIRCUMVENT AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL REQUIREMENTS
AND THE LIST OF FEDERAL THREATS
AND ROLL BACKS.
GOES ON AND IT'S ALARMING.
NOW SOME OF THE APPOINTMENTS
OPEN AS OF THIS BILL ARGUE THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD WAIT UNTIL THE
ADMINISTRATION DOES BAD THINGS
BEFORE REACTING ON APPEAL MADE
PEACE MET MEAL BASIS.
BUT WE SIMPLY DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY.
OF REACTING TO EACH DECISION
THAT COMES DOWN FROM DC.
GIVEN THE EXTRAORDINARY PACE OF
THE ATTACKS.
AS WE ONE SIMPLY SET UP A
PROCESS FOR SPECIFIED AGENCIES
TO BREAK OR REGULARLY REVIEW
CHANGES HIS FEDERAL STANDARDS
AND CONSIDER ADOPTING INTO STATE
LAW EXISTING BASELINE FEDERAL
PROTECTIONS FOR CLEAN AIR.
CLEAN WATER ENDANGERED SPECIES
AND WORKER SAFETY AND SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
CALIFORNIA HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
HERE HERE TO BUILD ON ITS
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP.
AND PUT IN PLACE AND EVEN
STRONGER FIREWALL AGAINST SHORT
SIGHTED ACTIONS.
FROM THE FEDS BECAUSE THERE'S NO
DOUBT.
THAT THEY ARE HELL BENT ON
WEAKENING OUR BEDROCK
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTIONS SB ONE
IS CALIFORNIA PROTECTING
CALIFORNIANS IN THE ENVIRONMENT
OUR LIVES DEPEND ON THANK YOU
AND I URGE FOR YOU'RE ABLE
[inaudible]
WHICH FIVE ANY OTHER SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NORMALLY IF YOU CAN LINE UP AT
THE MICROPHONE IN THE BACK AND
IF THEY CAN BE BRIEF PLEASE
THANK YOU WE'VE HAD OUR TO IN.
FAVOR THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A KILLER BACK ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT I WOULD JUST MENTION
THAT THERE HAS BEEN A STEADY
ROLLBACK OF WORKER PROTECTION
SAFETY PROTECTION LAWS.
ON THIS BILL IS ESSENTIAL TO
PRESERVING THE ONES THAT
CALIFORNIA WORKERS RELY UPON
THANK YOU.
YOU VERY MUCH YOU CAN STATE YOUR
NAME AND ORGANIZATION PLEASE AND
POSITION THANK YOU MISTER
RESTAURANT MEMBERS DECIDE ON
SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
CAITLYN CLUE I WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COAST KEEPER ALLIANCE
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS CARSON MEYER I AM
HERE WITH ENERGY CM FROM MALIBU
AND GRADUATED FROM THE SAME
PUBLIC HIGH SCHOOL SENATOR STERN
I'M PROUD TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
SB.
ONE ALL OF HIS FINDINGS.
TINA GAILLARD FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO AND FOSSEL FREE
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
SURE MEMBERS AS EARLY AS A
BEHALF THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL ALSO
TRANSPORT.
JERRY NELSON WITH THE GOLDEN
GATE SAMUS ASSOCIATION ON BEHALF
OF MORE THAN TWENTY THOUSAND
JOBS IN THE SALMON FISHING
INDUSTRY IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GEORGE HONORED OCEAN CONSERVANCY
BOTH IN CALIFORNIA AND IN
WASHINGTON DC IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THE BARBER MATH I'M A RESIDENT
OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA I'M WITH
THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF AN RTC.
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE THIS IS NOT ONLY FOR MY
CHILDREN AND MY GRANDCHILDREN
BUT IT'S FOR YOUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN.
PLEASE SUPPORT IT.
HI I AM JOANNE KAPLAN AND FROM
LOS ANGELES I'M ALSO HERE WITHIN
OUR DC LEADERSHIP COUNCIL.
AND I SUPPORT SB WHEN VERY
STRONGLY.
THANK YOU.
HEY LAURA BRIDGMAN OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA -- ON BEHALF OF IN
DEFENSE OF ANIMALS IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS HERE CA
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
HE'LL DECIDE NATIONAL PARKS
CONSERVATION ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT.
THE VOICE CUT OFF WITH NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THE CARD WITH AN RTC REGISTERING
SUPPORT FOR THE TRUST FOR PUBLIC
LAND THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAVE CONSERVATION
VOTERS IN STRONG SUPPORT AND I
WAS ALSO ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR OUT OF ON CALIFORNIA
AND THE ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE
FUND THANK YOU.
IN A SECOND THOUGHTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAND THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
NO OPPENHEIM WITH THE PACIFIC
COAST FEDERATION OF FISHERMEN'S
ASSOCIATIONS IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF BREAST
CANCER PREVENTION PARTNERS IN
MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
MORNING I'M TALIBAN IT I'M
RESIDENT OF LOS ANGELES AND
SENATOR ALLEN'S DISTRICT AND I'M
HERE TO URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB
ONE THANK YOU SO MUCH.
READ ADDISON BEHALF OF THE LOCAL
CONSERVATION CORES AND CAL STAR
CAN SUPPORT.
ANY NOT OFTENER DC IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB.
ONE MY NAME IS DORA FOR KERN I'M
A FROM THE LEADERSHIP COUNCIL OF
THE NRDC AND I AM FROM LOS
ANGELES AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING JUDY MAN CREW SO
FOUNDER PRESIDENT SOCIAL
COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S PHOEBE TONKIN A
MISTRIAL AND NOW LIVING IN
CALIFORNIA I'M HERE WITH AND ON
THE SCENE I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB.
ONE SUSAN TEASING PROUD A MEMBER
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE SACRAMENTO
RESIDENT AND VOTER.
DEREK MILLS BOARD MEMBER FOR
PAUL BACK IN STRONG SUPPORT HIGH
SCHOOL YARD VOTE.
LAST CALL FOR SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT IF YOU CAN MAKE YOUR WAY
TO THE MICROPHONE PLEASE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT CAROL GAUGE
SACRAMENTO SUPPORT.
HIS INCOME FORTY AUBURN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH LAST CALL ON
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT SPEAKERS
AGAINST THE BILL.
WE HAVE -- TO PRISONERS AT THE
TABLE AND THEN OTHERS CAN LINE
UP AT THE MICROPHONE PLEASE.
SPEAKERS AGAINST THE BILL.
MORNING.
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ADAM WRIGLEY ON BEHALF OF THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE OR HERE IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
I WANNA BEGIN WE'RE NOT OPPOSED
TO SB ONE STATED INTENT OF
PRESERVING CALIFORNIA'S
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP.
AND LABOR LEADERSHIP. FIVE
DECADES AGAINST ANY FEDERAL ROLL
BACKS.
THE CHAMBER OF COMMERCE AND THE
FIFTY PLUS ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE OPPOSE OPPOSE ON TECHNICAL
AND PROCESS SEES IN SB ONE THAT
WE FEEL HAVE ON AND HAD A
CONSEQUENCES.
ON THE REGULATED COMMUNITY -- I
WANNA I'D BE REMISS NOT TO SAY
THAT WE THE OPPOSITION HAVE BEEN --
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE PROPONENTS
TO ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AND
WE'VE BEEN OPERATE IN GOOD FAITH
I'M OPTIMISTIC THAT.
SB ONE CAN BE.
AMENDED TO ADDRESS THOSE
CONCERNS AND STILL PRESERVE THE
INTENT OF THE BILL WHICH IS TO
PREVENT FEDERAL ROLLBACKS -- IN
THE ENVIRONMENTAL LABOR CONTEXT.
BUT SB ONE IS AN INCREDIBLY
BROAD BILL IT DEALS WITH THE
CLEAN AIR ACT CLEAN WATER ACT
THE SAFE DRINKING WATER ACT.
AND ALL WE DID OUR OR LAWS UNDER
THE FEDERAL LABOR STANDARDS ACT
OF NINETEEN THIRTY SIX WHICH TO
BE CANDID IS THE HE ANYONE OF
THESE ISSUE AREAS COULD BE A
BILL.
IN AND OF ITSELF AND WE GET WHY
SB ONE IS INCREDIBLY BROAD BUT
BECAUSE IT IS BROAD -- THERE ARE
A NUMBER OF TECHNICAL ISSUES IN
THE BILL -- THAT WE FEEL MUST BE
ADDRESSED AND FOR THE INTEREST
OF TIME I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT A
FEW.
FIRST SEIZURE ACT DUE PROCESS
THAT MEANS NO NOTICE -- NO
PUBLIC COMMENT THAT'S FOR NGOS
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND
OBVIOUSLY THE THE THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THESE.
NEW REGULATIONS.
THE THERE IS NO OFFICE OF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW OVERSIGHT AT
ALL IN THE BILL.
SO BASICALLY -- THE SIX A. P. A.
STANDARDS ARE NOT AT ALL ADDRESS.
FOR ANY PROFLIGATE RULE MAKING.
AND JUST TO ADDRESS THE THE IDEA
THAT SB ONE LITERALLY COPIES AND
PASTES FEDERAL LAW IN THE STATE
LAW IS -- OVERSIMPLIFICATION OF
HOW ALL FEDERAL AND STATE LAW --
INTERACT I THINK THE PUBLICATION
OF RULE MAKING THE DEVIL IN THE
DETAILS AND PUBLIC NOTICE AND
COMMENT ARE ESSENTIAL. TO AVOID
THE ONLY OTHER REDRESS WOULD BE
LITIGATION AND SO FOR US.
THAT'S ONE MAJOR CONCERN AND
ANOTHER MAJOR ISSUE IS -- AROUND
THE BIOLOGICAL -- OPINIONS AND
IT'S IT'LL TAKE PERMITS UNDER
HOW THE ESSAYS OPERATES UNDER SB
ONE WE DO NOT OPPOSE HOW SB --
ONE ADDRESSES -- THE LISTING OR
DOWN THE SCENE AT THE FEDERAL
LEVEL BUT AGAIN HOW THEY GO
ABOUT THAT WE HAVE CONCERNS AND
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
PROPONENTS WE ARE WORKING TO
ADDRESS THESE TECHNICAL CONCERNS
BUT OVERALL ARE NOT OPPOSE THE
INTENT.
THANK YOU.
THE MORNING NO -- KRAMER'S THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU
FEDERATION.
I THINK WE WE SHARE THE THE
TECHNICAL CONCERNS THAT THE
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE -- OUTLINED
I WANT TO GET A LITTLE MORE
SPECIFIC IN THE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT PROVISIONS OF THE
BILL.
SO THE BILL I'M PURPORTS TO JUST
MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE PROTECTING
ANY SPECIES ARE CHANGES THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THE
CHALLENGES IT ALSO GIVES THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
GREATER AUTHORITY TO STEP IN AND
STOP ACTIONS AND CONTROL ACTIONS --
IN WHICH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
AND IS INVOLVED.
THAT IS THE LARGEST CONCERN I AM
BUT ON THE THE DELISTING AND
DOWN LISTING PIECE IS IT DOESN'T
REALLY ALLOW FOR A RECOGNITION
THAT TIME SOMETIMES THE
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT IS
SUCCESSFUL AND SPECIES ARE
RECOVERED.
AND SO WE NEED TO HAVE THE BILL
RECOGNIZE THAT WE DON'T NEED TO
LIST SPECIES IF THEY'RE REMOVED
IT FROM THE FEDERAL ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT BECAUSE ACTIONS HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL IN THEY HAVE
RECOVERED.
SO THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT WE NEED
TO DEAL WITH I'M THE OTHER ISSUE
WHICH IS IS MUCH LARGER.
IS HOW THIS WILL AFFECT THE
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS THAT HAVE
JUST BEEN SUBMITTED TO THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
IN THAT NOW SB ONE WOULD GIVE
THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE GREATER AUTHORITY TO
SAY NO TO ANY CHANGES THAT COULD
BE VIEWED.
AS BACKSLIDING SO IF WE ARE
FOLLOWING SCIENCE AND SCIENCE
DICTATES CHANGES YET BACK IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN OR TWENTY FIFTEEN
OR TWO THOUSAND WE WEREN'T AS
UNDERSTANDING OF THE SCIENCE.
AND SO THE FEDERAL STANDARDS AT
THAT DATE WERE DIFFERENT WE
WOULD NOT BE ALLOWED UNDER SB
ONE TO MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
AND SO UNDER THOSE SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENTS.
THEY MAY BE THROWN OUT OR MAY
NOT BE ALLOWED TO PROCEED
BECAUSE THE DEPARTMENT COULD GET
SUED IF THEY ALLOW AN ACTION
THAT COULD BE VIEWED AS
BACKSLIDING.
THAT'S OUR BIGGEST CONCERN.
I'M IS THAT.
IT'S GOING TO STOP ACTIONS AND
STOP CALIFORNIA FROM MOVING
FORWARD WITH THE SCIENCE.
AND THE OTHER PIECE THE BILL
ALSO HAS A PROVISION THAT
ATTEMPTS TO GIVE THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AUTHORITY --
OVER CONTROL OF THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT OBVIOUSLY THEY
HAVE TO COMPLY WITH -- SEASON
NOW BUT THE BILL IS DOING IS
TRYING TO EQUATE ENDANGERED
SPECIES ACT PROTECTIONS WITH
WATER RATES -- AND FINALLY ON
THE AMENDMENTS PROPOSED IN THE
ANALYSIS I THINK THERE DOES NEED
TO BE MORE DISCUSSION ABOUT THE
DISTINCT POPULATION SEGMENT WE
DO NOT LIST -- DISTINCT
POPULATION SEGMENTS UNDER
CALIFORNIA LAW SB ONE ACTUALLY
DID A GOOD JOB OF RECOGNIZING.
UNLIKE IN SB FORTY NINE THAT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD ONLY BE
LISTING SPECIES THAT ARE ALLOWED
TO BE LISTED UNDER THE
CALIFORNIA LAW.
I'M SO THERE DOES NEED TO BE
MORE DISCUSSION ON THAT.
THAK YOU VERY MUCH OTHERS
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL IF YOU CAN STATE YOUR NAME
AND ORGANIZATION AND IF YOU
CHOOSE -- WHERE YOU'RE FROMIN
THE STATE THAT BE FINE -- TOO
TOM JACOB ON BEHALF OF THE
CHEMICAL INDUSTRY COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA THE POST FOR THE
REASONS STATED THANK YOU.
KELLY GOVERNOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS OPPOSE FOR THE REASONS
STATED.
JOHN LEWIS THE NATIONAL
FEDERATION IN A MINUTE BUSINESS
REPRESENTING SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS ALSO POSE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LARA
KNOWING HE TO COME HAVE A
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL
CALIFORNIA CONGENERS AND REYES
ASSOCIATION WESTERN AG
PROCESSORS ASSOCIATION --
CALIFORNIA TOMATO GROWERS
ASSOCIATION IN VARIOUS OTHER AG
TRADE ASSOCIATIONS AND
COMMISSIONS IN OPPOSITION BUT WE
DO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THAT PRO TEM STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US.
MR TURN MEMBERS BETH A LOSS OF
JUST FOR THE AGRICULTURAL ENERGY
CONSUMERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING THE COOKING UNITS
ON BEHALF OF THE HOUSEHOLD AND
COMMERCIAL PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION.
THAT IS ALL WE ONLY HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA GRAIN FEED
ASSOCIATION COVERS THE
DISSOCIATION THE ALLMAN ALLIANCE
AND THE FAMILY BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION WE
APPRECIATE WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND AND WE'LL.
KEEP WORKING ON THE PROCESS.
SURE MEMBERS CANDIDATE JOGO THE
QUALITY GROUP ON THE HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR
ENVIRONMENTAL AND CONFOUNDS A
HEARING OPPOSITION AS WELL.
HE'LL TELL HIM WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION -- WHILE WE
AGREE WITH THE OPPOSITION THAT
WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE INTENT --
WE ARE VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
REGULATORY COSTS ON FARMERS.
JUST A A NOTE THAT OVER SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND SIX THERE WAS A
STUDY DONE ON A SALINAS.
LETTUCE GROWER AND HIS
REGULATORY COSTS OF THE HUMOR TO
THE FACT OF ALL THE REGULATORY --
REQUIREMENTS FOR FOR FARMERS HAS
RISEN ALMOST 8100%.
SO WHEN YOU GO FROM A HUNDRED
NINE DOLLARS AN ACRE.
ON REGULATORY COSTS -- TO NINE
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SEVEN
DOLLARS AN ACRE.
YOU'RE PUTTING FARMERS WHO GROW
FRESH FRUITS AND VEGETABLES
PRETTY MUCH OUT OF BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA SO AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
A AND LIKE YOU'D BE COGNIZANT OF
THAT THANK YOU.
CHRIS ANDERSON ON BEHALF OF
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES IN OPPOSITION.
THE OTHER SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SING NOBODY MAKING THEIR WAY TO
THE MICROPHONE -- CENTER STERN
I'VE RECEIVED TWO NOTES ASKING
YOU IF YOU ARE GOING TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
I AM I THINK THAT'LL HELP THE
CONVERSATION SO -- THERE'S NO
OTHER SPEAKERS I WILL BRING THE
DISCUSSION TO THE DíAS --
CENTER HUESO.
THANK YOU JUST WANTED A STATE.
AND FOR THE PEOPLE YOU KNOW I I
AM [inaudible]
SYMPATHETIC THAT.
THIS CREATES SOME CONFLICT.
WHAT THE FEDS?
BUT SOMETIMES WE NEED CONFLICT.
WITH A GOVERNMENT THAT'S TRYING
TO ATTACK.
ARE VERY HEALTH.
OUR ECONOMY.
OUR ENVIRONMENT.
WITH NO REAL SCIENCE BUT NO REAL
ACTION BASED ON SOLID SCIENTIFIC
PRINCIPLES WE WE OFTEN HEAR.
WHAT'S THE SCIENCE WHAT'S A
SCIENCE AND NOBODY SEEMS TO BE
ASKING WHAT'S THE SCIENCE OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION.
AND THERE IS NO SCIENCE.
AND AND WHERE IS THE OUTRAGE AT
THAT THOUGHT I'D LIKE TO SEE
PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC.
RISE UP AND SAY THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AND IT'S CREATING
HURT US.
AS BUSINESS PEOPLE AND FARMERS
AND AND YES IT WILL.
WHAT DO WE DO WE JUST SIT BACK
AND LET THEM ROLL OVER?
ALL THE ALL THE WORK WE'VE DONE
TO FOR YOU KNOW PROTECT OUR
STATE WE WE HAVE A BEAUTIFUL
STATE.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME WE HAVE A
LOT OF THREATEN WATER BODIES I
REPRESENT.
BUT TWO OF THEM.
I REPRESENT A SEE THAT IS
ENDANGERED AND SHRINKING IN AND
WILL PRETTY MUCH [inaudible]
HURT PEOPLE.
BY A IT'S ALREADY HURTING
PEOPLE'S CAUSING ASTHMA.
THIS IS MISS MINISTRATION HAS
BEEN SILENT ON THAT THE CUENTA
RIVER VALLEY ON THE NEW RIVER ON
THE SALTON SEA.
WE HAVE MORE THREATENED SPECIES
NOW THAN EVER AND THEIR SILENT
ON THAT.
ON ON ON GLOW THEIR SILENT ON
GLOBAL CHANGE ON CLIMATE CHANGE.
EVERYTHING THAT IS.
LEE THE BIGGEST THREAT ON OUR
HEALTH.
I IN OUR EXISTENCE.
THERE ARE SILENT ON THE QUOTE
QUITE THE CONTRARY THEY'RE
TAKING THEIR GOING BACK DECADES
AND DECADES.
IN HISTORY. TO REPEAT POLICIES
THAT GOT US EXACTLY WHERE WE ARE
WHEN WE NEED TO DO THE OPPOSITE.
SO.
I THINK THIS IS A WONDERFUL BILL
I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY AT THIS TIME OF WAR
WHERE WE WHERE WHEN.
WE ARE DEALING WITH SOMEBODY
THAT -- LEADING THIS COUNTRY
BACK -- TO A PAST.
THAT HAS CREATED ENORMOUS
PROBLEMS.
YES.
THAT WE NEED TO BE SOLVING NOW
WHEN AND I I THINK.
I'D LIKE TO SEE PEOPLE ASKING
THE ADMINISTRATION WHERE'S THE
SCIENCE WARS ASSIGNMENTS IN YOUR
ACTIONS.
SO WE CAN SO WE CAN SUPPORT THE
SUN.
IF THERE'S NONE.
AND IF THERE'S NO SCIENCE THEY
SHOULD DO SOME ABOUT IT BECAUSE
THIS IS AND THIS IS NOT GOOD
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN EVERY.
ASPECT OF OF WHAT'S HAPPENING TO
OUR COUNTRY RIGHT NOW.
I MEAN THERE THE LIST IS SO
LARGE THAT.
MOST PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THE TIME.
TO SPEND TO JUST GO THROUGH.
ALL THE HORRIBLETHINGS THAT ARE
HAPPENING IN OUR COUNTRY AND I
THINK WE NEED TO FIGHT BACK AND
THIS IS A BILL AT LEAST.
IT THIS SEEMS LIKE.
A REASONABLE BILL TO ME BECAUSE
I THINK THIS IS A MUCH BIGGER
PROBLEM WE SHOULD BE DOING BUT
BUT AT LEAST.
THIS IS A STATUS QUO BILL AND I
THINK FURTHER OUR STAFF LOCALLY --
AS THEY TRY TO ENFORCE THIS.
YOU KNOW THIS THIS WILL BE MUCH
EASIER TO DO THAN IF WE CREATED
ENORMOUS CHANGES SAY NOW WE HAVE.
TO CREATE NEW REGULATIONS RIGHT
NOW I THINK.
IN DEALING WITH ANY CHANGES IF
THEY'RE NOT BASED ON SOLID
SCIENCE IT GIVES US.
A PLATFORM TO ROUTE TO TO
CHALLENGE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WE HAVE TO PREPARE OURSELVES
FOR THAT AND WHATEVER.
WHATEVER THE REACTION IS ON OUR
BEHALF IT'S GOING TO BE BASED ON
OF FEDERAL ACTION THAT'S NOT
BASED ON SCIENCE AND I THINK
WILL WIN THAT DEBATE IN COURT.
AND IF IT AND IF FOR CHOIRS THIS
TO DO THAT I THINK WE HAVE TO WE
HAVE -- TO WE HAVE TO MARK MARK
OUR POSITION AND HOLD IT.
AND NOT LET UP.
SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR WORK ON
THIS AND I EVEN LOVE TO BE A CO
AUTHOR AND SCALE.
POSSIBLE THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU SIR HUESO SENATOR
BARGES.
I I COME AT THIS FROM A
DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE --
REPRESENTING -- THE CENTRAL
VALLEY -- I FIRST CAME TO THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AFTER LAW SCHOOL
TO CLERK FOR A FEDERAL JUDGE --
NATIONALLY REGARDED BY WATER
JUDGE.
AND DURING THE YEAR OF THAT
CLERKSHIP -- I WAS INUNDATED --
INTO THE ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT.
AND WHAT EXACTLY THAT MEANT FOR
AGRICULTURE FOR FISHING --
ANYTHING THAT -- IN ITS
TENTACLES WOULD REACH INTO.
WHAT I REALIZED IS THAT?
THE INTERPRETATION OF THE
BIOLOGICAL OPINIONS THE
POLITICAL.
INFLUENCE AGENTS THAT WERE AT
PLAY IN THIS.
IT'S EASY FOR US TO TAKE A STEP
BACK OR TOO EASY FOR US TO TO
COMMENT THAT.
THIS IS A WASHINGTON VERSUS
SACRAMENTO ISSUE IF WASHINGTON
WON'T STEP IN AND SACRAMENTO
MUST.
I THINK THAT IS A GROSS
OVERSIMPLIFICATION OF A VERY
SOPHISTICATED PROBLEM.
THAT IS DEALING WITH THE
LIFESTYLE -- THAT EXIST IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY AND ELSEWHERE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT IF WE IF WE GIVE UNFETTERED
POWERS THE STATE AGENTS.
GIVEN THE THE INFLUENCE OF
CERTAIN -- LAYERS HAVE IN THE
CAPITAL HERE.
I'M AFRAID THAT THE HUMAN
ELEMENT THAT HAS BEEN LITIGATE --
FOR YEARS IN PARTICULAR WE GO
BACK TO THE DELTA SMELT ISSUE.
HOW EXACTLY DOES THE PROTECTION
OF?
THE SPECIES WHERE THERE IS
DIVERGENT BIOLOGICAL
INTERPRETATIONS.
BUT ULTIMATELY RESULTING IN THE
FOLLOWING OF GROUND BECAUSE
FARMERS IN AGRICULTURALIST
CANNOT SURVIVE.
WE CALL OURSELVES THE BREAD
BASKET OF OF THE WORLD.
WELL THAT'S NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE FOLKS.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE THAT GOAL WAY.
SO WE MAY BE LOOKING AT
ENVIRONMENTAL A PRISTINE VISION
FOR TOMORROW AND TAKING UP THE
MANTLE AGAINST WASHINGTON.
BUT WE ARE ERODING WAY HOW WE
PRODUCE FOOD IN IN THE VALLEY
AND ELSEWHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SO ELL I APPRECIATE THE STATED
GOALS OF THIS PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
I THINK IT IS. TO DRIVING AWAY
AGRICULTURE FOR ALL OF
CALIFORNIA IT'S NOT JUST.
UP FROM THE VALLEY BUT WINE
COUNTRY AND IN FISHING I THINK
WE ARE OPENING UP A PANDORA'S
BOX -- WE HEARD FROM ONE OF THE
FOLKS WHO TESTIFIED EARLIER.
THAT IF WE BELIEVE THAT SCIENCE
IS PROGRESSIVE AND I DO BELIEVE
IN SCIENCE.
IN ANY OF THOSE THAT -- THAT
THINK OTHERWISE I THINK NEED TO
OPEN UP THEIR TEXTBOOKS I
BELIEVE IN -- SCALI MET THAT I
BELIEVE IN PEER REVIEW.
IT HAS ABSOLUTE MERIT.
AND FOR THOSE THAT THINK THAT
SCIENCE SHOULD BE TOSSED OUT
WELL I DON'T AGREE WITH THAT.
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
WE BALANCE SCIENCE WITH OUR WAY
OF LIFE.
HE CANNOT BE ONE OR THE OTHER IT
HAS TO BE BOTH IN THEY HAVE TO
BE SYNERGISTC AN APPRECIATIVE
OF THE OTHER SURVIVAL.
AND MY MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS
DOES NOT DO THAT.
THIS IS TAKING A WASHINGTON
FIGHT BUT KILLING.
OUR CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE
THAT'S MY PERSONAL OPINION.
THE OTHER SENATORS COMMENTS
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
THUNDERSTORMS.
THANK YOU.
I'LL CLOSE.
OKAY WELL.
I'LL JUST SAY.
BUT BEFORE YOU CLOSED PLEASE
LET'S MAKE SURE WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY YEAH YOU MAY CLOSE VERY
GOOD.
I WANT TO ADDRESS IN THE CLOSE
SOME OF THE SENSITIVITIES AROUND
THERE SPECIALLY IN THE
AGRICULTURE COMMUNITY AS WELL AS
THE BROADER BUSINESS COMMUNITY --
THERE'S A TRUST DEFICIT RIGHT
NOW WITH WASHINGTON.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHAT'S DRIVING
THIS.
GIVEN OIL LOBBYIST.
EARNING DEPARTMENT INTERIOR AND
A COLD LOBBYIST RUNNING EPA
[inaudible]
THAT DOESN'T.
EARN US A LOT OF DIFFERENCE
TOWARDS THE FEDERAL AUTHORITY.
I RECOGNIZE SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT FOLKS HAVE FACED
OVER THE YEARS WITH THE
ENFORCEMENT OF FEDERAL
ENDANGERED SPECIES ACT BUT I
WILL SAY THE QUALM THAT I'M
HEARING.
TODAY IS NOT SO MUCH WITH THE
STATE'S ROLE BUT WITH THE
MECHANICS OF THE LAW.
THE ADMINISTRATION HOWEVER OF
THAT LAW.
WE DO NOT -- PROPOSE HERE SOME
RADICAL OVERHAUL OF HOW IT'S
CURRENTLY BEING IMPLEMENTED AND
ENFORCED -- I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE OPPOSITE OF UNFETTERED IS
BUT I THINK THERE'S THERE'S
THERE'S PLENTY OF FEDERATION --
I GUESS IN THIS LEGISLATION OR
AT LEAST THAT'S THE INTENT --
THAT THIS IS NOT DESIGNED TO BE
A SORT OF WIDE OPEN DOOR -- TO
PASS A WHOLE SERIES OF NEW
UNANTICIPATED REGULATIONS THIS
IS ACTUALLY SUPPOSED TO HELP THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY HAVE SOME
CERTAINTY THAT AT LEAST THINGS
ARE GOING TO STAY THE WAY THEY
WERE.
BACK BEFORE WE FORGOT ABOUT
SCIENCE AND WE'RE HOPING THAT
WITH THAT SORT OF BRIEF PERIOD
OF CALM WE CAN GET THROUGH THE
NEXT COUPLE YEARS AND GET BACK
TO NORMAL -- THEN WE CAN
ACTUALLY START TO MOVE FOR TO
WRESTLE WITH SOME OF THESE
LARGER ISSUE SO.
LOOK I RECOGNIZE THIS THIS
CREATES AN UNCOMFORTABLE TENSION
AND I KNOW THAT THIS IS GONNA
NECESSITATES A MAD BECAUSE HE
BACK IN WASHINGTON ESPECIALLY
FROM OUR PARTNERS IN THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY SAY.
STOP THE GAME PLAYING LIKE WE WE
CANNOT PLAY SOME HIGH STAKES
GAMBLE WITH OUR ENVIRONMENT OR
WITH YOU KNOW ENDANGERED AFRICAN
SPECIES THAT ARE BEING TROPHY
HUNTED AND WE'RE GONNA SUDDENLY
JUST UP GIVE A BACK DOOR BECAUSE
SOMEONE WANTS TO HOLD THE TAIL
AND LOOK LIKE A TOUGH GUY --
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WE HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO DO THIS WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE THESE CONVERSATIONS ON
I KNOW THEY'VE BEEN PRODUCTIVE
THUS FAR AND I DO APPRECIATE THE
FEEDBACK -- AND I APPRECIATE
ALSO THE BIG KNOWLEDGE MEANT
THAT.
THE THE THE THE INTENT THAT
THERE ACTUALLY IS SOME COHESION
HERE AND I WANT TO SEE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURE RC
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS SHOW
THEMSELVES TO BE BOLD AND TO BE
PROGRESSIVE I THINK WE HAVE A
PATH TO GET THERE.
BUT I DO APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
TODAY AND I WISH WE DIDN'T HAVE
TO PUT THIS INSURANCE POLICY IN
PLACE BUT ARE THE TIMES DEMANDED
SO.
WITH THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
I THOUGHT.
THE USER STERN L. CAN CALL THE
ROLL.
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY
SENATOR STERN HI STERN I'D JONES.
GEN SNOW ALLEN ALLEN AYE BARGES
BARGES SNOW COVER EURO.
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY IN THE
BILL'S ON CALL [inaudible]
322- THERE ARE [inaudible]
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER VICE CHAIR --
WELCOME SENATOR ROTH WE HAVE --
SB THREE OH SEVEN FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
SEVEN RIGHT CHANGING OF THE
GUARD.
TECH CLEAN UP.
WELCOME CENTER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE
BILL -- THREE OH SEVEN AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW FOR THE PAST --
TWENTY YEARS COULD TEASE A
CORPORATE LANDAU AROUND IN THE
MOJAVE DESERT.
HAS PROPOSED TO PUMP AN AVERAGE
OF FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET OF
WATER PER YEAR THAT'S OVER
SIXTEEN BILLION GALLONS. FOR
FIFTY YEARS FROM THE AQUIFER
UNDERNEATH THE MOJAVE.
AND SELL IT TO VARIOUS WATER
DISTRICTS IN ORANGE AND LOS
ANGELES COUNTIES IN OTHER
COUNTIES AT A PROFIT FOR
PURPOSES OF GUARANTEEING WATER.
TO ABOUT A HUNDRED THOUSAND NEW
HOMES.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE
SCIENCE IS IN CONFLICT AS TO
WHAT THE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE LEVEL OF PUMPING IS.
AND IF FRANKLY COULD THESE IS
WRONG ON THE SUBJECT A LEVEL OF
PUMPING COULD POTENTIALLY
DESTROY THE MOJAVE DESERT.
IN THE PROCESS THAT'S THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON ON THIS MASSIVE WATER
EXTRACTION PROJECT.
IN THIS VERY FRAGILE ECOSYSTEM
THAT HAS EXISTED IN BALANCE FOR
CENTURIES.
HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON SO WE
REVIEW ANALYZE AND GET THE
SCIENCE RIGHT.
NOW THE PROJECT HAS BEEN STALLED
FOR YEARS BECAUSE IN THE MINDS
OF MANY THE MATH JUST DOESN'T
ADD UP.
KITTY IS AS I SAID WANTS TO PULL
FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER
YEAR OUT BUT I CAN'T EVEN HEAR
MYSELF.
BUT ADMITS THAT THE AQUIFER ONLY
REFILLS AT A RATE OF THIRTY TWO
THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER YEAR.
RENOWNED SCIENTISTS WORKING WITH
THE U. S. GEOLOGICAL SURVEY AND
THE NATIONAL PARK SERVICE.
SAY THE REFILL RATE IS MORE LIKE
200-021-0000 ACRE FEET PER YEAR
NOW KIDDIES HASN'T EVAPORATION
THEORY TO ATTACH TO THE PROJECT.
ON WHICH IT'S PUMPING PLAN IS
BASED.
BUT THE SCIENTIFIC REPORTS ARE
IN CONFLICT AS TO THE EFFICACY
INVALIDITY OF THAT EVAPORATION
PLAN.
SO IF THE U. S. G. S. AND THE
PARK SERVICE SCIENCE IS CORRECT.
THAT'S AT LEAST FORTY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET PER YEAR FOURTEEN
BILLION GALLONS LESS THAN THE
COULD THESE PLAN.
CLEARLY.
THERE IS A SERIOUS CONFLICT IN
THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE THAT'S
THAT'S BEING PRESENTED IN THIS
CASE AND THAT SURROUNDING THIS
PROJECT.
AND IF COULD DISS MISCALCULATED
THE SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RATE NOT
ONLY WILL THE ECO SYSTEM IN THE
HOBBY FACE DESTRUCTION.
BUT WHAT ABOUT THE ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND NEW HOUSEHOLDS THAT
COME TO DEPEND ON THE WATER
SUPPLY.
THOSE HOUSEHOLDS WILL HAVE A
VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM AS WELL IF
AND WHEN COULD DISS FORCED TO
STOP PUMPING.
SO WE THINK THAT CONFLICT SHOULD
BE RESOLVED BEFORE THE PUMPING
STARTS AND THAT'S ESSENTIALLY
WHAT THIS BILL DOES NO MORE NO
LESS.
NOW YOU HAVE HEARD OR WILL HEAR
A LOT ABOUT KIDDIES IN THE CUT A
SEQUEL RATHER IN THE CONTEXT OF
THIS BILL SEQUEL.
AND HOW COULD THESE IN ITS
PROJECTS OF ONE FIVE OR SIX
SEQUEL LAWSUITS.
AND THAT THE COURTS HAVE CLEARLY
RESOLVE THE SCIENCE IN FAVOR OF
CANDIES AND HAVE VALIDATED.
IT'S PUMPING PROPOSAL
UNFORTUNATELY THOSE OF YOU WHO
ARE FAMILIAR WITH SEEK WINDOW
THAT IS SIMPLY NOT THE CASE.
SEEK WHAT IS A PUBLIC DISCLOSURE
STATUTE THAT REQUIRES PROJECT
PROPONENTS AND THE COURTS TO
IDENTIFY THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS OF THE PROPOSED PROJECT.
THOSE IMPACTS IN FACT IN
REVIEWING THE SCIENTIFIC
EVIDENCE FOR AND AGAINST THE
PROJECTS SUCH AS THE PUMPING
RATES HERE.
AS THE COURT IN COULD DISS OWN
APPELLATE CASE NOTED COURTS ARE
NOT PERMITTED TO WEIGH AND
RESOLVE CONFLICTS.
IN THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
PRESENTED AND THIS IS WHAT THE
COURT SAID IN THAT APPELLATE
DECISION IN REVIEWING THE LEAD
AGENCIES ACTIONS UNDER SEQUEL WE
MAY NOT.
SET ASIDE AN AGENCIES APPROVAL
OF ANY I ARE ON THE GROUND AT
THE OPPOSITE CONCLUSION WOULD
HAVE BEEN EQUALLY OR MORE
REASONABLE IN OTHER WORDS.
NO WEIGHING OF SCIENCE.
NOW IN CASE THERE'S ANY DOUBT
AND THEY SHOULDN'T BE SINCE I'VE
BEEN SAYING THE SAME THING FROM
THE OUTSET OF MY PARTICIPATION
IN THIS BILL I AM NOT -- WILL
REPEAT NOT TRYING TO PREVENT THE
PUMPING OF WATER FROM THIS
AQUIFER BYE KIDDIES. FOR ANY
FUTURE LANDOWNER IN THE MOJAVE
BECAUSE THIS BILL IS NOT
STRICTLY TARGETING TO DETECT
GOODIES.
IT IS A BILL PROTECTING THE
MOJAVE DESERT FROM LANDOWNERS
WHO PROPOSED TO PUMP WATER FROM
THE AQUIFER.
I'M SIMPLY TRYING TO ENSURE THAT
ANY PUMPING NEW OR IN THE FUTURE
IS DONE AT AN ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE RATE [inaudible]
SO. TO BRING THIS TO A CLOSE I
THINK WE SHOULD HIT THE PAUSE
BUTTON AND HEAD OF AN
INDEPENDENT TEAM OF SCIENTISTS
REVIEWED THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE.
FOR AND AGAINST THE KIDDIES
PROJECT.
AND RESOLVE THE CONFLICT AND
THEN BASED ON THAT REVIEW SAID
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE
PUMPING RATE ONE THAT ENSURES AN
UNINTERRUPTED SUPPLY OF WATER TO
ALL RESIDENTS.
WHILE PRESERVING AND PROTECTING
THIS NATIONAL TREASURE WE CALL
THE MOJAVE FROM ANY POTENTIAL
MANMADE DESTRUCTION.
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT SENATE BILL
THREE OF SEVEN DOES NO MORE OR
NO LESS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE POINT IN TIME.
THANK YOU SENATOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT -- WILL DO -- TWO
MINUTES EACH FOR THE LEAD WITH
[inaudible]
Q..
GOOD MORNING CHAIR STERN
SENATORS NEIL THE SIDE WITH THE
NATIONAL PARKS CONSERVATION
ASSOCIATION WE'VE BEEN
ADVOCATING FOR THE PROTECTION OF
OUR NATIONAL PARKS FOR ONE
HUNDRED YEARS.
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
SB THREE OH SEVEN TO PROTECT OUR
CALIFORNIA DESERT.
WE SEE THE CALIFORNIA DESERT AS
A AS AN ASSET WORTHY OF
CONTINUED INVESTMENT WE TOGETHER
HAVE PROTECTED LANDSCAPES
INCREASE RECREATION
OPPORTUNITIES IN INCOME INCREASE
THE QUALITY OF LIVES. FOR SO
MANY PEOPLE WITHIN THE STATE AND
PROTECTED ICONIC PLACES LIKE
JOSHUA TREE IN THE MOJAVE FOR
GENERATIONS TO COME -- KIDDIES
IS EXHIBIT A OF FEDERAL
ADMINISTRATION BACKSLIDING THAT
HARMS OUR NATIONAL PARKS.
BOB THE CONCERNS OF
ENVIRONMENTAL ROLLBACKS THAT
WE'RE WE'RE JUST DISCUSS DIED
DURING SB ONE ON WHAT THEY'RE
HAPPENING RIGHT NOW IN OUR
CALIFORNIA DESERT THIS IS REAL --
SO PRIOR TO THE FEDERAL THIS
FEDERAL MINISTRATION COULD THESE
WERE WAS REQUIRED TO COMPLETE
FEDERAL NEED TO REVIEW IN
ADDITION TO SEE WHAT BECAUSE THE
PROJECT PIPELINE WOULD RUN
THROUGH THE MOJAVE TRAILS
NATIONAL MONUMENTS.
AND WOOD OVER DRAFTING AQUIFER
THAT IMPACTS UP TO A LOT MORE
THAN ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
ACRES OF FEDERALLY PROTECTED
LANDS.
THESE WERE THE RULES AND THEY
PROVIDE A CERTAINTY TO ALL
STAKEHOLDERS PROJECT YOU KNOW
FOR DECADES PRIOR.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT THE
HISTORY NGUYEN KIDDIES AS
PROPOSED TWENTY YEARS AGO IT
UNDERWENT BOTH FEDERAL AND
SEQUEL REVIEW.
ODJICK WAS REVIEWED BY THE
METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT AND
THAT DISTRICT REJECTED THE
PROJECT -- BECAUSE IT THE
FEDERAL REVIEW SAD KIDDIES YOU
CAN'T PUMP AS MUCH WATER AS YOU
WANT TO WE CAN LIKE ALLOW YOU TO
PUMP IS STABLE RATE BUT NOT THE
AMOUNT THAT YOU WANT TO BECAUSE
IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE IT'S GROUND
WATER MINING.
AND THE DIFFERENCE AS CENTER
ROSS EXPLAINED WAS STAGGERING --
AND SO FAST FOR TO OUR CURRENT
PROPOSAL -- THE KIDDIES COMPANY
STILL HAD A MAJOR ROADBLOCK WITH
OUR FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION --
THEY SOUGHT AN EXEMPTION THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION SAID NOW.
DO THESE NEVER INITIATED THE
FEDERAL REVIEW THAT WAS REQUIRED
THE INSTEAD WAITED FOR THE
TWENTY SIXTEEN ELECTION.
AND THEY GOT EXACTLY WHAT THEY
NEEDED -- KIDDIES IS FORMER --
LOBBYIST AND REPRESENTATIVE JOIN
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN TRANSITION
TEAM -- AND THAT TEAM
MIRACULOUSLY CALLED THE KIDDIES
PROJECT OUR NATION'S NUMBER
FIFTEEN NATIONAL.
EMERGENCY AND SECURITY PROJECT --
IN THE IN THE COUNTRY AND THE IN
THE IN NEED A FAST TRACKING --
WITHIN MONTHS THAT -- IN
MINISTRATION REMOVED THE
SAFEGUARDS SB THREE OH SEVEN
SIMPLY PUT SINCE OUR REVIEW BACK
INTO PLACE.
THAT SAID NOTHING MORE WE NEED
THIS BECAUSE THE RULES AND THE
PROCESS FEES ARE IMPORTANT THEY
MEAN SOMETHING WE RESPECT YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING.
CHAIR STERN AND SENATORS MY NAME
IS MICHAEL MADRIGAL MEMBER OF
THE CALL WE A BAND OF INDIANS.
AND HERE TODAY AS PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIVE AMERICAN LAND
CONSERVANCY OR IN A LC.
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB THREE OH
SEVEN WHICH WILL PROTECT THE
CALIFORNIA DESERT AND ITS
IMMENSE CULTURAL SIGNIFICANCE.
FOR THE PEOPLES WHO HAVE CALLED
THIS REGION HOME SINCE TIME
IMMEMORIAL.
NALC IS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
FOCUSING ON THE TRADITIONAL
HOMELANDS OF TRIBES IN PRESENT
DAY SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WE RESTORE SACRED SITES AND
PROVIDE EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMMING
FOR NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH AND
THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR UP FRONT IF
WE DO NOT GET THIS RIGHT.
IF WE ALLOW THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION'S RECKLESS DE
REGULATION TO STAND THE
CONTINUES GROUNDWATER MINING
PROJECT WILL PERMANENTLY DESTROY
OUR CULTURAL SITES AND SACRED
LANDSCAPES.
THIS LEGISLATURE EACH ONE OF YOU
ON THIS COMMITTEE.
WILL DETERMINE THE PATH TAKEN.
THE STAKES COULD NOT BE HIGHER
THE URGENCY FOR SB THREE OH
SEVEN COULD NOT BE GREATER.
THIS IS WHY THE NLC STANDS IN
SOLIDARITY WITH TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS AND ASSOCIATIONS
THAT HAVE CALLED FOR THIS-LEGISLATION.
INCLUDING THE TRIBAL ALLIANCE OF
SOVEREIGN INDIAN NATIONS.
NALC RECOGNIZES AND ALWAYS
BRINGS FORWARD THE NECESSARY
ROLE OF GOVERNMENT TO GOVERNMENT
CONSULTATION WITH CALIFORNIANS
AMERICAN INDIAN NATIONS.
EVERY SPRING RIVER SEEP IN
ANCIENT WELL IN THE CALIFORNIA
DESERT HAS BEEN KNOWN TO US FOR
THOUSANDS OF YEARS.
TODAY JUST LIKE MANY YEARS AGO
DESERT SPRINGS ARE CRUCIAL TO
OUR WAY OF LIFE AS TRADITIONAL
GATHERING PLACES SACRED SITES
FOR PRAYER AND CEREMONY.
AS PLACES TO REST AND RESTORE
OURSELVES.
AS CALIFORNIA'S INDIGENOUS
PEOPLES WE ARE INEXTRICABLY
LINKED TO TO THE NATURAL
LANDSCAPE.
THE PLANTS ANIMALS AIR AND WATER
OF CALIFORNIA'S DESERTS.
THE CHOICE BEFORE EACH OF YOU IS
CLEAR SUPPORT SB THREE OH SEVEN
AND RESTORE THE RESPONSIBLE
SAFEGUARDS THAT HAVE PREVIOUSLY
OF BEEN AFFORDED TO OUR HOMELAND.
VOTE OTHERWISE AND KNOW THAT YOU
ARE THREATENING THE EXISTENCE OF
RESOURCES THAT TRIBAL PEOPLES
DEPEND ON FOR OUR CULTURAL
SURVIVAL.
THE SAYING WATER IS LIFE IS TRUE
IN THE CALIFORNIA DESERT ACID IS
AT STANDING ROCK.
THIS IS WHY WE THE DESERT TRIBES
SUPPOSED TO CONDUCE PROJECT IT
DOES NOT SAVE A DROP OF WATER
FOR OUR CHILDREN OR
GRANDCHILDREN.
AND SO WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF
SB.
THREE OH SEVEN THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
PLEASE COME FOR NAME AND
AFFILIATION.
GOOD MORNING CAM DELFINO WITH
DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT
JUST WANTED TO NOTE THAT THE
AQUIFER UNDERLYING THE KEYS
VALLEY IS A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT.
TO PEOPLE AND WILDLIFE THE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIAL WHILE I WAS
ACTUALLY TRACKED GPS TRACK BUT
MORE SHEEP WHICH ARE PROTECTED
SPECIES THAT USE BORREGO I MEAN
BRENT BONANZA SPRINGS -- AS A
CRITICAL WATERING POINT OUR
STATE IS INVESTED A LOT OF MONEY
IN BRINGING THE SPECIES BACK
WERE VERY.
CONCERNED ABOUT THE IMPACTS TO
WILDLIFE AND I WOULD JUST SIMPLY
NOTE THAT -- THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT SEQUEL -- IT IS NOT ABOUT
WHEELING STATUTES IT'S ABOUT
ESTABLISHING AN ENVIRONMENT RE
ESTABLISHING AN ENVIRONMENTAL
BASELINE THAT HAD BEEN IN PLACE
BEFORE THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
TOOK OFFICE.
AND REQUIRING THIS PROJECT TO GO
THROUGH AN ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
IT SHOULD HAVE GONE THROUGH AND
SHOULD GO THROUGH.
THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
OVERALL POLICY AN ATTIC IN
CALIFORNIA THAT WE ARE NOT GOING
TO STEP ASIDE AND LET THE
CURRENT FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION
ROLL BACK ENVIRONMENTAL.
REVIEW AND TO PROTECTIONS AS WE
JUST DISCUSSED WITH SB ONE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SELLER GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND WE ARE IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT AND WHAT ARE LINE
OUR COMMENTS WITH DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE THANK YOU.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF PROTECTING
CALIFORNIA'S DESERTS.
I ALSO WAS ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY A CIVIL AND
OUT OF ON CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS LAND TRITON
REPRESENT A NEXT GEN CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR BILL GAINES ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAPTER
THE WILD SHEEP FOUNDATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT.
BILL ALLEY -- FOR ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP IN SUPPORT.
EXCERPTED.
WHEN I THINK IN THE US ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE PARKS
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT?
THANK YOU MA'AM.
AND ALSO WE HAVE A CYNICAL
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT
[inaudible]
YOU.
TRACY WENT ON BEHALF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN STRONG SUPPORT THANKS.
MR TURN MEMBER SYLVIA'S SILLY
SHAUN BEHALF OF CITY OF LOS
ANGELES MAYOR ERIC GARCETTI IN
STRONG SUPPORT THINGS ARE GOOD
THANK YOU.
SUSAN TEASING FORMER TRIBAL
COUNCIL MEMBER OF MORE TELL
RANCHERIA.
OF CON CALL MY DO INDIANS WE ARE
A FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED TRIBES WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE THOSE IN OPPOSITION
PLEASE MAKE YOUR WAY UP.
THANK YOU GUYS.
ALRIGHT WE'LL DO. TWO POINT FIVE
MINUTES EACH SINCE I GAVE THE
OTHERS THE ONLY WAY.
TO SO VERY GOOD GERMAN.
ALWAYS FAIR THANK YOU.
OF MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I'M JOE
LÏNG REPRESENTING CAN DISS AND
WITH ME TO ASSIST IN ANSWERING
QUESTIONS IS MISTER SCOTT SLATER
THE CEO OF COMMITTEES.
YEAH I THINK MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
YOUR COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ACTUALLY
RAISES THE RIGHT QUESTION.
IT RAISES THE QUESTION.
WHAT WHAT IS THIS BILL ABOUT
WHAT IS THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL?
ON ONE HAND IS IT POTENTIALLY AS
I BELIEVE MANY OF THE SUPPORTERS
OF THE BILL WOULD SAY.
TO ESSENTIALLY THROW WHATEVER
ROADBLOCK COULD BE PUT IN FRONT
OF THIS PROJECT IN AN EFFORT TO
DEFEAT THE PROJECT SO IT NEVER
OCCURS.
OR IS IT I BELIEVE AS AS THE
AUTHOR OF THE BILL WOULD
ARTICULATE IS AN ATTEMPT TO TRY
AND FIND A WAY TO RECONCILE.
THE DIFFERENT SCIENTIFIC REPORTS
THAT HAVE COME OUT REGARDING THE
PROJECT.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT IS THE
PURPOSE.
THE SUPPORTERS HERE.
BEFORE YOU TODAY WHO HOLD THE
SEAT WERE.
PROCESS AS THE GOLD STANDARD.
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW.
ARE THE SAME SUPPORTERS BEFORE
YOU TODAY EVEN THOUGH THIS
PROJECT HAS GONE THROUGH THE
SEQUEL PROCESS.
A SEQUEL PROCESSES THAT INVOLVED
OVER TWENTY STATE AND LOCAL
AGENCIES.
THEY'RE HERE TODAY SUPPORTING
THE BILL BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
LIKE THE OUTCOME OF THAT PROCESS
THEY WANT TO RAISE THE BAR
HIGHER BECAUSE THAT GOLD
STANDARD THAT THEY HOLD DIDN'T
RESULT IN THE OUTCOME THAT THEY
WANTED TO ACHIEVE.
IN ADDITION TO THOSE STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES THAT WERE
INVOLVED THE COUNTY SAMBAR DINO
WAS NOT.
THE LEAD AGENCY IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS SO THEY ACTUALLY LAYERED
ON TOP OF THAT REVIEW.
THEIR OWN SPECIFIC INDEPENDENT
REVIEW OF BOTH THE SCIENCE IN
THE OPERATION.
A VERY THOROUGH VETTING A VERY
EXHAUSTIVE VETTING.
AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO POINT THAT
OUT BECAUSE THE COUNTY WAS
REALLY INDEPENDENT FROM THE
SEQUEL PROCESS.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE SCOPE
FOR JUST A MINUTE WHAT'S THE
SCOPE OF THIS PROJECT.
IT'S POTENTIALLY FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRE FEET A YEAR.
THAT'S FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET
COMPARED TO THE VOLUME OF AT
LEAST TWENTY MILLION ACRE FEET
THAT IS ESTIMATED TO BE IN THIS
AQUIFER.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LESS THAN 1%
A YEAR BACK LESS THAN ONE HALF
PERCENT A YEAR.
COMPARE THAT TO SOME OF THE
OTHER GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
BASINS THAT HAVE OVER DRAFTED
VERY SIX SIGNIFICANTLY AND YOU
BEGIN TO UNDERSTAND.
THE SCOPE OF THIS PROJECT IS
QUITE SMALL.
I'D ALSO LIKE TO CORRECT ONE
THING THAT WAS THAT WAS TALKED
ABOUT IN THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
BILL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ACTUALLY DID APPROVE THIS
PROJECT IT WAS REVIEWED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TEN WAS APPROVED.
HAVING SAID THAT AND
UNDERSTANDING THE AUTHOR'S
DESIRE TO HAVE A REVIEW OR
RECONCILIATION OF OF THE SCIENCE
BEHIND THIS PROJECT.
WE DID SERIOUSLY PROVIDE OF AN
OFFER OF AN AMENDMENT TO THE
AUTHOR.
THAT WOULD DO TWO THINGS. ONE IT
WOULD ALLOW AND BRING INTO THE
MANAGEMENT PLAN FOR THE PROJECT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES AS A PARTNER IN THAT.
PLAN.
THAT WOULD ALLOW THE W. R. TO
BOTH REVIEW.
THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE. FOR
THE PROJECT PRIOR TO ANY WATER
TRANSFERS.
BUT EVEN IN ADDITION AND GOING
WAY BEYOND THAT GIVING THEM AN
ONGOING ROLE FOR THE FIFTY YEARS
OF THE PROJECT IN BOTH REVIEWING
ALL OF THE MONITORING RESULTS
THAT OCCUR.
AND GIVING THEM THE ABILITY. TOO
TO WEIGH IN AS AN EQUAL PARTNER
ABOUT THE SCIENCE.
OF WE THINK THAT THAT WAS A
REALLY BEYOND JUST RECONCILING
THE SCIENCE OF MAKING SURE THE
PROJECT OPERATED PROPERLY.
BUT HAVING THE DEPARTMENT IN
THAT PROCESS ALL ALONG THE WAY
IT'S AN EQUAL PARTNER WE THINK
THAT'S UNPRECEDENTED IN A
PROJECT LIKE THIS.
SO WHY ARE WE OPPOSE THE BILL A
COUPLE OF REASONS ONE THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY IN FACT WAS INVITED
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS TO PROVIDE COMMENTS ON
THE PROJECT. TO EXPRESS ANY
CONCERNS THAT THEY HAD.
THE REALITY IS THEY CHOSE NOT.
TO NOW THIS BILL WANTS TO GIVE
THEM THE PRIMARY ROLE IN
REVIEWING THE PROJECT ONE MORE
TIME WHEN THEY HAD THAT
OPPORTUNITY AND DIDN'T TAKE THAT
OPPORTUNITY IN THE SEQUEL
PROCESS.
SECONDLY THERE'S NO SPECIFIC
PROCESS IN THIS BILL.
BILL LANGUAGE ASKED THE
DEPARTMENT TO PROVE A NEGATIVE.
TO PROVE THAT IN FACT THERE
WOULD BE NO ADVERSE IMPACT.
NOT ONLY IS THAT DIFFICULT TO DO
BUT EVEN MORE IMPORTANTLY
BECAUSE THERE'S NO
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS SPELLED
OUT IN THE BILL.
IT ACTUALLY WOULD ALLOW THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION EVEN IF
THE SCIENCE WERE BORN OUT TO BE.
SAFE AND NOT PROVIDE ANY.
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS THE
COMMISSION MEMBERS THEMSELVES
COULD SIMPLY VOTE TO REJECT THE
PROJECT EVEN IF THE SCIENCE IS
BORN OUT.
BECAUSE OF THAT DISCRETION
BECAUSE THERE'S NO PROCESS.
WE HAVE TO OPPOSE THE BILL NOW
WE HAVE HAD SIGNIFICANT
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR WE
RECOGNIZE.
HIS WELL INTENTIONED APPROACH
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO TO TRYING
TO FIND A WAY TO GET TO THAT
PLACE WHERE THE SCIENCE ANSWERS
CAN BE.
PROVIDED TO THE AUTHOR IT AT THE
SAME TIME NOT RECREATE THE WILL
FOR THE PROJECT A GOOD THANK YOU
I'M GONNA TREAT THAT AS A TWO
AND A HALF MINUTES TIMES TO
WHICH WAS FIVE MINUTES.
I WOULD ASSUME YOU OPPOSE THE
BILL MR SLATER.
YES OKAY.
I'M HERE TO ANSWER WHATEVER I
YEAH SO THE I. QUESTIONS BUT
WE'RE GONNA DOIS.
I'M GO TO THE REST OPPOSITION TO
MAYBE WILL COME BACK TO IF
THEY'RE FOR THE QUESTION.
NAME AN AFFILIATION IF YOU COULD
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS KITTANI
DURAN WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN OPPOSITION WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL SUCH A
DANGEROUS PRECEDENT THAT COULD.
POTENTIALLY HALL R DELAYED
OTHER PROJECTS THAT ARE REQUIRED
TO GO THROUGH THE SECRET PROCESS.
WHETHER IT'S ADDITIONAL UNITS TO
ADDRESS THE STATE'S CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS OR OTHER
INVESTIGATIONAL DO WIN THROUGH
THAT BUT THANK YOU YEAH.
UNLESS YOU HAVE SOMETHING NOVEL
TO ADD JUST PLEASE TRY TO STICK.
TO GENTLY SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT WHERE THE LEAD AGENCY
ON THE PROJECT WE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSE BILL OKAY THANK YOU SIR.
THERE IS THE RISK THIS BILL
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MR MEMBERS ALLEN
CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES OPPOSED AGAIN JUST FOR
THE PRESIDENT THAT THIS BILL
WOULD SET.
OKAY THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD MORNING TO RIGHT RIGHT
POLICY MANAGER LA COUNTY
BUSINESS FEDERATION OPPOSITION
THIS IS LIKE.
LUCY MOVING THE FOOTBALL IN
PEANUTS.
THANK YOU SIR.
CHRISSY FOR ON BEHALF OF THREE
VALLEY'S MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
ATTY MUNSON ON BEHALF OF THE AND
WHEN EMPIRE UTILITIES AGENCY
EYELINER COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF
AQUA IN OPPOSITION VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
STEVE KERR'S FOR THE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION THANKS SIR.
KRISTIN OLSON WITH THE PROTECT
WATER IN JOBS COALITION A GROUP
OF FIFTY ORGANIZATIONS OPPOSED
TO THE BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
RENDON PENSACOLA FERREIRA
CONSTRUCTION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA PARTNERSHIP FOR JOBS
WERE VISITING -- NINETY THOUSAND
UNION EMPLOYEES IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY CONTRACTORS
THANK IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
GREGORY FOSTER WITH ENGINEERING
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION WE
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANK YOU SIR.
MORNING MR TURN SENATORS ROSANNA
CARVE OUT TO HEAR ME OFF OF THE
TIDEWATER DISTRICT AS WELL AS
THE CALIFORNIA GROUNDWATER
COALITION IN STRONG OPPOSITION
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING -- SENATOR STERN.
AND COMMITTEE CAN MY NAME IS TIM
PARKER AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
GROUND WATER RESOURCES
ASSOCIATION A CALIFORNIA.
I'M ALSO ONE OF THE SCIENTISTS.
THAT REVIEWED A LOT OF THE
REPORTS -- INVOLVED WITH THIS
PROJECT YOU MAY THINK IT'S A
LITTLE ODD FOR D. R. RATED TO
OPPOSE SOMETHING LIKE THIS BUT
WE KIND OF FELT IT -- WOULD.
POTENTIALLY SET SOME.
PRECEDENTS ON CONVEYANCE OF
CONSTRAINTS.
AND ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT AND
REVIEW OF PROJECTS THAT ARE
ALREADY -- PRETTY WELL REVIEWED
UNDER SYKORA.
AT A TIME WITH SIGMUND PLACE
WHEN WE'VE GOT ALL THESE BASINS
THAT ARE OVER DRAFTED AND NEED
WATER IN THE FUTURE.
AND WE REALLY HAVE TO HAVE CALLS
EVERYTHING ON THE TABLE TO TRY.
TO MEET THOSE TWENTY YEAR
CONSTRAINTS IN THE FUTURE SO
THAT'S WHY WE OPPOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH [inaudible]
IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE WILL BRING IT BACK
TO THE DíAS MEMBERS QUESTIONS
COMMENTS [inaudible]
HUESO.
JUST GENERALLY I JUST WANTED TO
COMMENT IN A LIVE.
THIS IS A REALLY TOUGH BILL THIS
IS A CONTROVERSIAL ISSUE AND
HONESTLY I MEAN AND AND
REVIEWING THIS IS EASY.
TO GO ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
AND BUT OVERALL THE WAY WE'VE
DONE ON LEAVE WE HADN'T BEEN
GOING OVER THIS BILL FOR YEARS
NOW.
AND THAT WE'VE HAD A CHANCE TO
REALLY LOOK AT EVERYTHING THIS
FOR THIS PROJECT HAS GONE
THROUGH AND I I JUST THINK OF
THAT.
THE THE PROPONENTS OF THIS
PROJECT OF GONE THROUGH.
EVERY STEP OF THE PROCESS
INCLUDING NEW LAWS THAT WE HAVE
PASSED IN THAT PROCESS THAT
REQUIRE GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
SO.
WENT WHEN THEIR CONCERNS ARE
REYES SAID THERE'S A GROUND.
WATER MANAGEMENT CONCERNED I'M
VERY SKEPTICAL BECAUSE OF THE
STRICT MEASURES WE'VE PUT IN
CALIFORNIA THAT.
ARE INTENDED TO PER PROTECT
PROTECT OUR AQUIFER'S AND KEEP
THEM -- KEEP THEM OF SUSTAINABLE.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE I MEAN THERE
THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF OVER
DRAWING OF WATER RESOURCES
ACROSS THE STATE OF THAT HAVE
REDUCED OUR AQUIFER'S TO
DANGEROUS LEVELS AND I DON'T
THINK THIS IS.
ONE THAT WITH THE CURRENT.
SEE THAT WE HAVE IN PLACE ARE
THREAT OF THAT.
BUT I I AGREE THAT -- THE THE
PROPONENTS OF THE PROJECT THE
GONE THROUGH EVERY STEP.
HAVE HAVE GONE THROUGH A VERY
RIGOROUS ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS AND THEY HAVE MET EVERY
REQUIREMENTS.
AND IT'S A IT'S A TOUGH THING TO
DO -- IT WOULD BE UNJUST AND WE
WOULDN'T BE DOING OUR JOBS IF WE
CONTINUE TO MOVE THE GOAL POST.
IN THAT PROCESS.
AND AND NO I I THINK THIS BILL
ISN'T UNNECESSARY THINK WE HAVE
ENOUGH LAWS THAT WOULD HOLD THEM
ACCOUNTABLE AND MAKING SURE THAT
THIS [inaudible]
BOB PROJECT.
DOES NOT NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
ENVIRONMENT AND IF THERE ARE
IMPACTS AT THEIR MEDICATED AND I
SEE.
SOME ARGUMENTS INCLUDING ONES
THAT THIS MAY REDUCE THE
SALINITY OF THE SOFT FOR OVER
THE COURSE OF TIME.
THAT I THINK IS TO VISIT IS A
POSITIVE THING CAN HAPPEN FROM
THIS BUT GENERALLY -- MUSTAPHA
THE BILL TODAY -- SENATOR.
SIMPLY BECAUSE I THINK THERE
ENOUGH CONTROLS IN PLACE THAT
GOVERN THIS SPECIFIC SITE
[inaudible]
AND I I JUST FIND IT HARD TO
TAKE A POSITION HERE ON THIS
THAT WOULD -- PUNISH SOMEBODY
THAT HAS GONE THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
AND SPENT.
A NORMA SAMANA MONEY DOING THAT
AND BECAUSE IT WOULD IT WOULD IT
WOULD SET A DIFFERENT THEY'VE.
A VERY BAD PRECEDENT AND IF WE
ARE PURSUING PROJECTS IN THE
FUTURE IN THE STATE.
THEN AND THIS IS THE WAY WE DEAL
WITH THEM I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE
ABLE TO EVER.
DEVELOP A MEANINGFUL PROJECT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT I THINK
SHOULD CONCERN US ALL.
THERE WAS A READY TO THE VICE
CHAIR THAN CENTER BOARD IS THE
WILL COME BACK OVER.
THANK YOU SENATOR ALLEN NEXT
THANK YOU MISTER MANAGEMENT OF
TELLING A COUPLE COMMENTS -- MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO
MENTIONED AND GET TO IS A COUPLE
SPECIFIC POINTS -- MISTER LANG
OR YOU OR THE YOUR WITNESS.
I UNDERSTAND THIS IS SENDING SAN
BENITO COUNTY I HAD A ROLE IN
THE PROJECT AND YOU KNOW CAN YOU
EXPLAIN WHAT WHAT THEIR ROLE IS
AND WHAT POWER OVERSIGHT.
AND I HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHORS AND MISTER.
YES.
MISTER MEMBERS OF THE COULD AT
THE COMMITTEE THE ROLE THE SAME
YOU KNOW COUNTY WAS SAID THAT --
FOLLOWING THE THE CONSIDERATION
OF THE PROJECT IN TWO THOUSAND
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
CLAIMS STATUTORY IMMUNITY FROM
ANY LOCAL REGULATION BY THE
COUNTY.
IN RESPONSE THE COUNTY ADOPTED A
A INDEPENDENT GRANT DESERT
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
ORDINANCE.
WHICH REQUIRED COMPLIANCE EITHER
BY DIRECT COMPLIANCE OR
SUBMITTING A GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT PLAN WHICH WOULD BE
APPROVED BY THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
SANTA MARGARITA AGREED TO WAIVE
ANY STATUTORY IMMUNITY FROM THAT
REGULATION AND THE COUNTY SET
UPON ITS OWN INDEPENDENT.
REVIEW OF THE THE E. I. R. AND
OF THE PROJECT ULTIMATELY IT
HELD.
I THINK AT LEAST HALF A DOZEN I
HEARINGS THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
TESTIFIED IT HAD ITS OWN EMPLOY
TECHNICAL EXPERT A GENTLEMAN
HERE FROM.
THE SACRAMENTO AREA NOTICED JUST
COMPANIES QUITE -- IN AND WILL
HOW AGAIN WHO ARE BOTH RENOWNED --
HYDROGEL JUST SAID THE LAWYER
WAS KEVIN O'BRIEN -- THEY NOT
ONLY REVIEW THE PROJECT AND
FOUND -- THAT THERE WOULD BE NO
UNDESIRABLE RESULTS WHICH IS THE
SIGMA STANDARD THAT THE YIELD
WAS SUSTAINABLE.
AND THEY ALSO DID SOMETHING
WHICHWAS VERY NOVEL OF THE
COUNTY IMPOSED WHAT ARE CALLED
AREA OF ORIGIN PROTECTIONS. FOR
THE BENEFIT OF THE COUNTY SO
THAT THEY LIMITED THE TERM OF
THE PROJECT TO FIFTY YEARS AND
AT THE END OF THE FIFTY YEAR
PERIOD THEY ENABLE TO RE
SHUFFLING THE DECK. FOR THOSE OF
YOU WHO KNOW HOW THE CENTRAL
VALLEY PROJECT THE STATE WATER
PROJECT WORK THEIR BURDEN BY
SOMETHING CALLED THE STE THE
AREA OF ORIGIN COUNTY OF ORIGIN
RESTRICTIONS.
THEYIMPOSE THAT ON THE PROJECT
WHICH MEANS THAT THE INTO THE
FIFTY YEAR PERIOD.
USES WITHIN THE COUNTY WOULD
HAVE PRIORITY THE WATER FROM THE
PROJECT.
ESTABLISH A LIFELINE A
DEDICATION FROM -- KIDDIES WHICH
WERE WHERE THE KIDDIES WOULD
GRANT TWENTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET
OF WATER TO THE COUNTY TO USE IN
ITS DISCRETION FOR USES INSIDE
THE COUNTY.
AND THEY ALSO INCLUDED A
CLAWBACK PROVISION THAT SAID
EVEN IF RESIDENTS AND BUSINESSES
AND SAN MARINO COUNTY DON'T WANT
TO WATER NOW THEY HAVE THE RIGHT
TO OPT INTO INTO IT T A LATER
DATE.
AND TO MY KNOWLEDGE IS THE ONLY
GROUND WATER MANSION PLAN IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S INCLUDED THOSE
PROVISIONS.
MR ROTH TO FOLLOW UP ON THAT YOU
KNOW THE COURTS HAVE RULED ON
THIS.
NUMBER AND YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
HAS.
SOME STRONG PROTECTIONS ON IT.
HI INCLUDING OF IN ON THE FLOOR
ESTABLISHED BY THE COUNTY THE
COURTS HAVE UPHELD THE COUNTIES
GROUNDWATER MANAGEMENT PLAN WE
GOT SEGMENT AS IS BEEN MENTIONED --
D. W. R. HAS BEEN MENTIONED AS
AN AS AN OPTION -- TO OVERSEE.
AND YOU'VE STATED THAT YOU'RE
JUST LOOKING FOR A PEN
ASSESSMENT THE SCIENCE.
BUT IT SEEMS LIKE TO ME IN AND I
I THINK MY AGAIN MY COLLEAGUE
FROM SANDIEGO -- ADEQUATELY --
MENTION THIS AS WELL -- IT SEEMS
LIKE IT'S OCCURRED.
AND IT SEEMS LIKE A STRETCH THAT
OUR COURTS.
ARE NOT.
TRUSTWORTHY WHEN FACING
QUESTIONS OF THE STATE'S
RESOURCES AND WE WE TRUST THE
COURTS A LOT.
IN ON THESE KIND OF ISSUES AND
THE SCIENCE.
HAS UNDERTAKEN WOULD YOU KNOW IF
YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO YOU KNOW
THOSE COMMENTS [inaudible]
WELL SURE.
IN THE FIRST PLACE THE COMMENTS
THE OF COULD DISS COMMENTS.
IGNORE THE FINAL REASON THAT I
GOT INVOLVED IN THIS BILL I'M
NOT KNOWN AS AN ENVIRONMENTALIST
I DON'T THINK I'VE TOUCHED A
WATER ISSUE IN THE SIX PLUS
YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE.
BUT I'M BOTHERED BY THE FACT
THAT THERE IS A AT LEAST A FORTY
THOUSAND ACRE FOOT WHICH IS
FOURTEEN BILLION GALLONS. FORTY
THOUSAND ACRE FOOT DISCREPANCY
IN THE SCIENCES TO WHAT CAN BE
PULLED OUT OF THIS BASIN.
NO.
THE INITIAL COMMENT BY THE
KIDDIES WAS THAT SUPPORTERS ARE
NOT SATISFIED WITH SEEK WERE.
ROSS THE COURTS HAVE RULED OF AN
ANSWER QUESTIONS AND YEAH BUT I
I MEAN I I THINK THE COURTS OF
THE COULD DIS.
DOES NOT RESOLVE SCIENCE I READ
A QUOTE FROM THE APPELLATE
DECISION IN THE COULD DIS APPEAL
WHERE THE COURT SAID WE DO NOT
RESOLVE CONFLICTS IN THE SCIENCE.
THE STANDARD IS SUBSTANTIAL
EVIDENCE WE LOOK TO SEE IF THERE
IS SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE WHICH IS
ANY REASONABLE F..
EVIDENCE AND THE INFERENCES THAT
CAN BE DRAWN THEREFROM TO
SUPPORT THE CONCLUSION OF THE
LEAD AGENCY.
EVEN IN THE FACE OF MORE
COMPELLING.
EVIDENCE IN THE RECORD SO
THERE'S NO RESOLUTION AND THE
PROBLEM HERE THE BASIC PROBLEM
HERE.
IS.
THIS IN THE NORMAL COULD SEE FOR
PROCESS.
YOU HAVE A LEAD AGENCY THAT ACTS
IN A RATHER OBJECTIVE WAY.
YOU SELECT EXPERTS YOU EVALUATE
THE SCIENCE YOU IS THE LEAD
AGENCY RESOLVE THE CONFLICTS.
YOU THEN SUBMIT YOUR FINAL E. I.
ARE OU APPROVE IT IT MAY BE
CHALLENGED IN COURT AND THEN THE
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE TEST
APPLIES.
IN THIS CASE THERE WAS AN
INITIAL TUSSLE.
IN COURT BETWEEN THE COUNTY OF
SAN BERNARDINO.
AND THE SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT AS TO CENTIMETER
MARGARITAS DESIRE TO BE THE LEAD
AGENCY SAN BERNARDINO THE COUNTY
WHERE THE PROJECT IS LOCATED.
WANTED TO BE THE LEAD AGENCY IN
THE END OF THE DAY SANTA MARIA
MARGARITA WHICH HAS NO GROUND
WATER.
AND HAS A THIRTY PER IS A
LARGEST.
INTEREST IN THE PUMPING PROJECT
WITH THE 30% WATER INTEREST.
WAS THE LEAD AGENCY SO THE LEAD
AGENCY IN THE SEQUEL PROCESS
GETS TO PICK THE AXE.
AND I'VE HEARD MANY AN EXPERT IN
FORTY FIVE YEARS AS IT DOES OF
LITIGATION ATTORNEY AND YOU
NEVER HER AN EXPERT UNLESS YOU
KNOW WHAT THE RESULTS GONNA BE.
SO THE SANTA MARGARITA WATER
DISTRICT HIRES THE EXPERT PUTS
THE EVIDENCE IN THE E. I. R.
WHEN THE IRISH CHALLENGED IN THE
COURTS UNDER THE SEEK WITH
STANDARD.
SUBSTANTIAL EVIDENCE THE COURT
LOOKS TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE IN THE E. I. R. REPORT
THAT SOME SORTS SUPPORTS THE
CONCLUSION AND IF THERE IS.
THAT'S THE END OF THE
CONVERSATION SO WHEN YOU SAY
COURTS REVIEW THERE WAS NO COURT
EVALUATION AND VALIDATION OF THE
PARTICULAR SCIENCE HERE.
I'M NOT TRYING TO STOP THE
PROJECT.
I'M TRYING TO RESOLVE THE
SCIENCE BECAUSE IF WE GET THIS
WRONG.
EVEN UNDER COULD DISS VIEW IT'S
GOING TO TAKE THIRTY YEARS TO
RECHARGE THE AQUIFER RESTORE THE
AQUIFER AND IN THE IN THE
OPINION OF SOME SCIENTISTS.
THAT THIRTY YEARS GOES TO FOUR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS SO I
DON'T THINK WE CAN DO THE BACK
AND REVIEW THAT MY COLLEAGUES
HERE.
MY FRIENDS ARE ARE PROPOSING WE
NEED TO DO THE FRONT AND REVIEW
AND WITH RESPECT TO THE SAN
BERNARDINO COUNTY GRAND WATER
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT
MONITORING PLAN.
THEIR FIVE YEAR REPORTS THERE'S-A TECHNICAL COMMITTEE COMPRISED
OF THREE THE COUNTY SANTA.
MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT IN A
THIRD PARTY THAT THEY PICK.
THE TEN REVIEWS WHAT THEY CALL
ACTION CRITERIA AND IF THERE
ACTION CRITERIA THAT OCCUR WHICH
IS A DECLINE IN THE STATIC WATER
LEVELS.
THEN THERE'S THIRTY DAYS AND
SIXTY DAYS AN APPEALS IN THIS
THAT THE OTHER.
AND IF WE GET IT WRONG AND THE
WATER LEVEL IN THE BONANZA
SPRINGS GOES AWAY.
THAT WILL HAVE.
PERMANENT LASTING EFFECTS ON
BIGHORN SHEEP THE VEGETATION AND
THE AND THE WILDLIFE AND THE FUN
AND THE FLOOR AND THE MOJAVE
DESERT AND WE CAN'T AFFORD THAT.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE -- AND IF YOU WANT TO
GIVE THE OPPONENTS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS A COUPLE
OF THINGS -- WHY DON'T WE JUST
TO MAYBE CENTER BOARD JUST WANT
TO JUMP IN AND WE CAN FLESH THIS
OUT IF?
YOU HAVE FURTHER COMMENTS.
THIS IS KIND OF REFER THIS ISSUE
AND FORGIVE ME FOR A BABY BEING
L. CALLOUS -- REMINDS ME OF AN
INFOMERCIAL.
YOU KNOW THAT SAYS IF YOU BUY
THIS WIDGET.
AWFULLY -- THIRTY NINE NINETY
FIVE YOU CAN GET SO MUCH MORE
BUT WAIT THERE'S EVEN MORE.
THAT'S KIND OF WHERE I SEE THIS
THE C. QUOTE OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
REVIEW PROCESS PLAYING OUT.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
AND I THINK IT WAS STATED
EARLIER THAT SOMETIMES -- WHEN
FOLKS ADVOCATE FOR THE
IMPLEMENTATION IN APPLICATION OF
SYKORA -- WHAT THEY REALLY MEAN
IS TO ACHIEVE THE DESIRED
OUTCOME?
IT IS NOT.
EARLY ON SCIENCE OR CONCERN FOR
THE ENVIRONMENT BUT TO ACHIEVE A
POLITICAL OUTCOME.
AND SO I GUESS WHAT I'M WHAT I'M
WONDERING TODAY IS.
WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY -- A
PASSIONATE TESTIMONY OF FOLKS
THAT DO NOT WANT THIS PROJECT TO
MOVE FORWARD AND WE'VE HEARD
MERITORIOUS ALSO MERITORIOUS
COMMENTARY.
OF FROM -- PROPONENTS THAT -- I
BELIEVE -- SHOULD BE ENTITLED TO
MOVE FORWARD HAVING JUMP THROUGH
EVERY A RELEVANT APPLICABLE WHO.
ONE SAN DIEGO EVEN -- ATTESTED
TO TO SUCH.
I'M KIND OF THE OPINION THAT.
SOUND MINDS CAN CAN REACH
CONSENSUS AS LONG AS PEOPLE ARE
INTELLECTUALLY HONEST AND
PRAGMATIC ABOUT THINGS.
IS THERE A PATH FORWARD HERE.
FOR A A REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION
FOR EXAMPLE YOU SAY THAT.
THE CONSEQUENCES OF THE THE
WATER EXTRACTION COULD BE
CATASTROPHIC.
I'VE I'M I'M AWARE THAT THERE IS --
A PROPOSAL -- OR AT LEAST ONE
COMPONENT IS THAT -- PUMPING
WHICH SEES IF IT DIPS BELOW
EIGHTY FEET -- MAYBE YOU CAN
CORRECT ME IF I'M MISTAKEN ABOUT
THAT.
BUT THERE ARE SAFE IS THAT A
SAFEGUARD THAT IS BUILT IN THERE
YES OR NO PLEASE YES.
SO I THINK WHEN WE HAVE A SAFE
CORD LIKE THAT THAT BUILDS
CONFIDENCE.
NOW I'M WONDERING IS THERE ANY
OTHER PROPOSAL THAT.
HAS BEEN PUT FORWARD OR BABY HAS
YET TO BE PUT FOR NOW YOU'LL MY
TIME IN THAT REGARD.
THAT -- CAN LOOK AFTER THE
ENVIRONMENTAL INTERESTS.
AND CREATE THE SAFEGUARDS IT
SHOULD THERE BE.
SCIENTIFICALLY DEMONSTRABLE --
EVIDENCE THAT THERE IS -- I'D
DAMAGE BEING DONE TO THE
ENVIRONMENT OR LIKELY DAMAGE TO
INTO.
THAT THERE BE US THAT THERE BE --
REVERSAL OF COURSE OPPORTUNITIES
SO MAYBE WITH THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO HEAR OTHER ANY IDEAS -- THAT
COULD BE PUT FORWARD.
ABOUT MY COLLEAGUES.
YOU WANT ME TO RESPOND IN IDEAS
I THINK IT'S A CALL IS IN OUR
CITY FOR IDEAS.
ABOUT.
AS SENATOR.
YOUR BILL WELL MISTER.
WELL FIRST OF ALL A MAYBE MISTER
SLATER COULD POINTED OUT TO ME
BUT I HAVEN'T FOUND IT IN THE
SAND WATER IN THE SENATE IN A
GROW WATER MANAGEMENT MONITORING
PLAN.
THERE'S A REFERENCE TO EIGHTY
FEET BUT THAT THERE'S NOT
LANGUAGE ABOUT A HARD STOP THE
TECHNICAL COMMITTEE LOOKS AT THE
ACTION CRITERIA AND THERE'S A
PROCESS BY WHICH THE COMMITTEE
REVIEWS AND ANALYZES -- THINGS
LIKE THAT THAT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING OF MY READ OF THE
GROUND WATER MANAGEMENT AND
MONITORING PLAN I DIDN'T DRAFTED
SO.
OF WHAT PERHAPS I WILL DEFER OF
THOSE WHO DID.
OF LET ME ADDRESS THE ISSUE
ABOUT ALTERNATIVES -- I'M
CERTAINLY OPEN TO CONVERSATION
FRANKLY IF YOU KNOW I CAME TO
THIS THING AT THE END OF AUGUST
OF TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN AND
BETWEEN AUGUST OF TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN AND AND CERTAINLY TILL
THE END OF LAST WEEK -- OF I'VE
HAD VERY LITTLE CONVERSATION --
WITH THE KIDDIES PROPONENTS
ABOUT WHAT I WHAT BROUGHT ME TO
THE TABLE WHICH IS THE FRONT AND
THE VLUATION.
AND ASSESSMENT AND SETTING OF AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE --
PUMPING RATE I'M NOT SATISFIED
THAT THE GROW WATER MANAGEMENT
MONITORING PLAN -- DOES THAT
WITH ENOUGH -- AGILITY AND
FLEXIBILITY TO CATCH ANY
PROBLEMS AND EIGHTY FOUR DROP IN
THE OXFORD IS FUNNY WATER IN THE
AQUIFER THAT'S NOT NECESSARILY
THE ISSUE THE ISSUE IS THE
IMPACT.
I AGREE I CAN'T EITHER THE ISSUE
IS THE IMPACT TO THE BONANZA
SPRINGS IN ANY OTHER SPRINGS
THAT HAPPEN TO BE IN INTER
CONNECTED WITH THE AQUIFER.
THERE IS A SCIENTIFIC DISPUTE
ABOUT HAVING TO DO WITH ICE OF
ISOTOPES AN ANALYSIS OF WATER IN
TEMPERATURE AND WE'RE AS TO
WHETHER THOSE SPRINGS ARE
INTERCONNECTED WHICH NEEDS TO BE
RESOLVED BECAUSE IF THERE IS AN
INTER CONNECTION.
A DROP OF ONE TO TWO TO THREE TO
SIX FEET IN FINANCES BRINGS
COULD HAVE AN EXTRAORDINARILY
DETRIMENTAL EFFECT ON ON
WILDLIFE AND THE AND THE
VEGETATION.
A COULD EASE -- AS I RECALL
ADMITS IN SOME OF ITS OWN
FILINGS THAT THE PUMPING WILL
RESULT IN A IN A DROP OF OF
SEVERAL FEET IN BONANZA SPRINGS.
AT LEAST IN SOME OF THE FILINGS
AND SO WE NEED TO RESOLVE THAT
IN MY READY TO SIT DOWN AND TALK
ABOUT ALL TO IT IS AS LONG AS IT
INVOLVES THE FRONT END
ASSESSMENT ABSOLUTELY -- AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO THAT SHOULD
THIS BILL MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE ON THE WAY TO LET ME
AND LET ME JUST SEIZE ON THAT
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR IT TO GO
THROUGH ITS NEST NEXT ITERATIONS
OF VARIOUS COMMITTEES -- BECAUSE
WE'VE SEEN IT SOMETIMES IT WORKS
SOMETIMES IT IT DOESN'T.
THESE PER GIVE ME FOR PUTTING ON
THE ON THE ON THE SPOT HERE --
ARE YOU OPEN TO THE IDEA OF SOME
SORT OF ANNUAL REVIEW -- YOU GET
MENTIONED EARLIER THAT THERE
WOULD BE -- ALLY A DIRECT --
TRUSTEE MEMBERSHIP ALLOWED --
FOR FOR EVERYBODY.
I'M SORRY W. R. E. W. R. DOES
THAT SEEM SATISFACTORY DO YOU TO
ACTUALLY INVITE D. W.OR TO BE
PART OF THIS THIS TRUSTEE GROUP
THE FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM WITH
FUNDAMENTAL PROBLEM THAT I'VE
HAD WITH EVERY SINGLE
CONVERSATION I'VE HAD WITH
REPRESENTATIVES OF GOODIES.
AND IT FOCUSES ON A BACK IN
[inaudible]
REVIEW.
EITHER IMMEDIATELY PRESS PRETTY
FRONT END OF MAY.
THAT'S NOT WHAT HE'S SAYING
SENATOR MOVEMENT MAYBE I
DESTRUCTION SO WORDS IN YOUR
MOUTH IF MISTER SLATER WILL
COMMIT. TO A FRONT END REVIEW BY
INDEPENDENT SCIENCE -- THAT'S
DIFFERENT I'M TALKING ABOUT I'M
DID NOT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
COMMISSION CONVENING TO ROUTE TO
START A THROUGH Z. ALL OVER
AGAIN THAT'S NOT WHAT I'M
TALKING I'M TALKING ABOUT IT.
SOMETHING FAR MORE PRAGMATIC
TOLD MISTER SLATER.
AND HIS REPRESENTATIVES.
THAT IF THEY WANT TO SET A TIME
LINE FOR THIS LET'S FIGURE OUT
HOW LONG IT TAKES IN SET A
TIMELINE.
I AM NOT TALKING ABOUT RE DOING
A SEQUEL REVIEW PROCESS.
BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT RESOLVING
SINCE VERY SERIOUS CONFLICTS IN
THE IN THE SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE
MISTER SLATER HAS AN INNOVATIVE
THEORY HAVING TO DO WITH
EVAPORATION IN THE MOJAVE DESERT
IN AQUIFER'S IN.
BACK FLOWS IN ALL OF IT TO
CAPTURE OF ABERRATION TO TO COME
UP WITH THE FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OTHER SCIENTISTS TO DATE.
AS I READ THE REPORTS DO NOT
SEEM TO AGREE NOW IF I'VE TOLD
MISTER SLATER THAT IF HIS
INNOVATIVE PROPOSAL HAVING TO DO
WITH EVAPORATION SUCH AN
ENVIRONMENTALLY SUSTAINABLE RATE
OF FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET PER
YEAR.
OF WATER DRAWING I DON'T THAT
AQUIFER I'M ALL FOR THAT BUT IT
NEEDS WE NEED TO HAVE SOME
SCIENTIFIC CONSENSUS ON THAT
POINT AND THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING
FOR HERE IF THERE'S A WAY. TO TO
TO MODIFY THE LANGUAGE OF THE
BILL IN A DIFFERENT FASHION TO
MAKE.
MISTER SLATER AND HIS COMPANY
HAVE MORE CONFIDENCE IN THE
PROCESS.
I'M HAPPY TO SIT DOWN WITH
MISTER SLATER WITH GOODIES AND
ANYBODY ELSE WHO WANTS TO COME
TO THE TABLE ARE ALL AT ALL IN
MY COMMENTS HERE AND WAIT FOR
OTHERS -- TO JUMP IN BUT
NORMALLY I'M I'M NOT KEEN ON
NEGOTIATING FROM -- FROM THE
DAIS -- SOMETIMES WHEN IT
APPEARS IF THEY'RE EASY AMPLE --
OPPORTUNITIES FOR AN
ACCOMMODATION AND CONSENTS TO BE
CHEAP SOMETIMES IT'S WARRANTED I
THINK IN THIS SITUATION THERE
MIGHT VERY WELL BE THAT
OPPORTUNITY BUT I NEED TO HEAR
IT FROM COULD THESE AND FROM THE
MAKERS OF THE THE MOTION -- MR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES.
SO TO BEGIN WITH A ARE GOOD
FAITH INTENTION WAS.
ATTEMPT. TO MEET US SENATOR ROSS
CONCERNED ABOUT AN ADVANCE
REVIEW AND ACTUALLY DO BETTER
THAN THAT OUR INTENTION WAS TO
INVITE D. W. R. INTO.
A SHARED MANAGEMENT
RESPONSIBILITY WHICH GAVE THEM
THE RIGHT TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
LONG.
REVIEW.
WHICH INCLUDES ANNUAL REVIEWS
AND THEN FIVE YOU'RE REQUIRED
ADJUSTMENTS ON ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT AND THERE IS A RAMP
IN PERIOD SO WOULD NOBODY'S
DELIVERING WATER TOMORROW.
IT'S NOT POSSIBLE SO THERE'S
THERE THE INTENTION WAS IS THAT
D. W. R. WOULD BE SET BE PUT
INTO THAT MANAGEMENT
RESPONSIBILITY NOW.
TODAY OR WHENEVER THIS BILL WAS
EFFECTIVE IF AND IF NOT BEFORE
SO THAT THEY WOULD HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TODAY JUST TO FOCUS
THE CONVERSATION I THINK.
THE WHAT I HEARD FROM THE AUTHOR
IS FRONT END.
PRE REVIEW RATE SO WE'RE TIED I
GUESS I APPRECIATE THE THE
FLUSHING OUT WHAT AN ADAPTIVE
MANAGEMENT PLAN WOULD LOOK LIKE
BUT I THINK WITH CENTER BOARD IS
GETTING AT WAS SENATE ROTH IS
GETTING AS THE FRONT END SO
WHAT'S THE AND SO.
THE PAIN HAVING SPENT SOME TIME --
THIS RECENTLY AS THIS MORNING
WAS SENATOR ROTH.
I THINK THAT.
AGAIN OUR INTENTION WOULD BE.
D. W. R. WOULD BE IMMEDIATELY
ENABLED TO BEGIN REVIEWING
ANYTHING I WANTED BUT BUT HE
WOULD BE MY TO JUST.
JUMP TO THE POINT.
THE THE THE PRIMARY CONCERN IS
IS ABOUT THE POTENTIAL FOR THE
PROJECT INTERFERE WITH THE
SPRINGS IN THE ADJACENT
WATERSHED.
IT'S NOT ABOUT WITH WITH ALL DUE
RESPECT IT'S NOT ABOUT WHETHER
THE PUMPING RAY ARE THAT
RECHARGE RATE IS THIRTY ONE
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED OR
NINETEEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
IT'S REALLY WHETHER THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
WILL CAUSE AN IMPACT IN THE
SPECIFIC IMPACT OF CONCERN IN
THIS IN THIS WATERSHED IS FIRST
AND FOREMOST SORT OF THE CANARY
IN THE COAL MINE.
THE DEMANDS OF SPRING IN THE
POTENTIAL THAT WOULD -- WOULD
HARM OTHER -- SPRINGS IN THE
HIGHER UP IN THE WATERSHED SO
FIRST OF ALL THE INTENTION I
THINK WE WOULD WE WOULD BE
WILLING AS A PART OF THE NOTION
OF INTRODUCING D. W. R. INTO THE
TRUSTEE ROLE. TO DO A A AND NOW.
ASSESSMENT OF THE
INTERCONNECTEDNESS OF THE THE
ALLUVIAL AQUIFER WERE PUMPING
FROM IN THE SPRING WE WE WILLING
TO DO THAT TODAY.
THAT'S THE FIRST PIECE BUT I
ALSO WANT TO POINT OUT THAT THE
E. I. ARE ALREADY.
DID TWO THINGS IT CAME TO THE
CONCLUSION THAT THERE WASN'T A
HYDRAULIC CONNECTION.
BUT THEN FOR AVOIDANCE OF DOUBT
MODEL WHAT THE IMPACTS WOULD BE
INCLUDED THAT THEY WERE NOT
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE THEY WERE
THE AT VARIATION WITHIN THE BAND
WITH THE WHAT HAPPENS NATURALLY.
SO THAT WAS IN THE AYE ARE IN I
ALSO WANT TO SAY THE COUNTY LOOK
AT THAT TO THE COUNTY WAS NOT
BOUND BY THE I. R. AND THE TRIAL
COURT.
REVIEW THAT FINDING SO IN THE
END WE WOULD AGREE TO THAT FOCUS
STUDY.
NOW. FOR YOU WANNA JUMP INTO
THIS AND I'LL COME BACK TO
CENTER JACKSON.
I DO.
ON THE I JUST WONDER WAS THAT A
YES OR NO. TO THE PROPOSAL OF
DOING ADVANCE I APOLOGIZE
CENTERS BUT BUT IN IT IS SORT OF
THE FINAL CONCLUSION TO THAT
CONVERSATION I DON'T KNOW IF
THERE'S A FINAL CONCLUSION YET
TO THAT COVERS ALL RIGHT OKAY I
JUST THOUGHT IT WAS WE COULD
MOVE ALONG.
NOT YEAH WE'RE GETTING THERE.
DID BY BIT.
NO IT'S OKAY -- COUPLE COMMENTS
A COUPLE QUESTIONS AND
SUGGESTIONS BASED UPON THE
SENATORS GOOD THE PRICE YOUR
FIRST.
I AM IS CHAIRMAN.
COMPELLED BY THE ARGUMENT THAT
SOMEBODY WHO JUMP THROUGH ALL
THE HOOPS.
LITIGATE EVERYTHING AND WE COME
AS A LEGISLATURE IN THE LAST DAY
AND TRY TO CHANGE THE RULES IS
WRONG.
I SEEN IT IN OTHER BODIES AND
I'VE SEEN IT HAPPEN.
IT IS A COMPELLING ARGUMENT.
BUT FOR THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
THIS CASE WHICH I THINK BECAUSE
A DIFFERENT CONCLUSION.
AND THE BECAUSE LOOK YOU KNOW
YOU YOU YOU GOTHROUGH ALL THIS
STUFF AND WHAT'S THE POINT IF
EVERY TIME THE GOVERNMENT CAN
JUST SIMPLY CHANGE THE RULES THE
END OF THE GAME.
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION ON EITHER
SIDE NO MATTER WHAT THE
CIRCUMSTANCES ARE WE HAVE TO
JUDGE THESE THINGS YOU KNOW WE
HAVE WAS IN THE STORE CONTEXT
DEPENDING ON WHO'S IN POWER
THERE'S A PROCESS AND RULE OF
LAW WE SHOULD FOLLOW IT.
BUT THE DIFFERENCE IN THIS CASE
ARE TWO THINGS THAT ARE CRITICAL.
ONE IS THAT ARMED.
YOU KNOW THE THE LEAD AGENCY HAD
A THUMB ON THE SCALE THEY HAD AN
INTEREST IN THE DEAL.
SANTA MARGARITA WATER DISTRICT
HAD INTEREST AND THERE ARE TO ME.
NO NO DISRESPECT TO THEM BUT
IT'S JUST TO MAKE IT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT FUNDAMENTAL IT'S
LIKE CHANGING A CASE IN THE
SUPREME COURT.
THAT'S FUNDAMENTAL TO THE
OUTCOME OF THE OF THE MATTER.
AND YOU CAN'T IGNORE THAT IN
TERMS OF HAVING AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW.
WHAT SENATE ROTH INDICATED OF
COURSES FIRING EXPERT WITNESSES
YOU ALWAYS WANT THE OUTCOME AND
I DON'T BLAME SOMEBODY FOR DOING
THAT BUT THEIR OBLIGATION IS
DIFFERENT THAN OURS ARE JOB IN
THE GOVERNMENT?
IS TO DEAL WITH THE TRUTH AND
FAIRNESS OF PROCESS.
BOB AND THE SECOND THING IS THE
CLIMATE CHANGE ARGUMENT IN THE
SENSE THAT THE SCIENCE IS SOUL
FOR PARK.
YOU DON'T FORTY THOUSAND ACRE
FEET IS A LOT OF WATER I MEAN I
IT'S A CITY OF WHAT.
FORWARD FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT
DENNIS AUTO IT'S A PRETTY BIG
NUMBER IN TERMS OF WHAT THE
DISTRICT NUMBERS ARE AND THE
UNIQUE NATURE OF THE SOCCER FOR
THAT THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN
AROUND FOR MANY YEARS ARE KEENLY
AWARE OF SO.
THE QUESTION IS FAIR I MEAN I
THINK THAT THE CONSULTANT A
MISTER CONNOR SAID CLEARLY IN
TERMS OF WHAT'S REALLY GOING ON
HERE IN IS IN ON PAGE NINE OF
HIS ANALYSIS.
THIS IS WHAT IS THE OBJECTIVE OF
THE PROPONENTS THERE AT LEAST
TWO CAMPS ONE GROUP WAS COOLEY
TRYING TO SIMPLY KILL THE
PROJECT.
THERE WON'T BE SATISFIED INTO
THE PROJECTS TOTALLY ABANDONED.
ANOTHER GROUP SIMPLY WANTS TO
ENSURE THE PROJECT IS SIZED
APPROPRIATELY WHATEVER THAT SIZE
MIGHT BE.
THE AUTHOR APPEARS TO BE FIRMLY
IN THIS SECOND CAMP I AGREE WITH
THAT DIAGNOSTIC.
HE CLEARLY IS IN THAT SECOND
CAMP I I BELIEVE HIM IN TERMS OF
WHERE HE'S AT I BELIEVE THERE'S
OTHER PEOPLE ARE DIFFERENT CAN'T.
FIND THAT'S YOUR RIGHT IN
DEMOCRACY TO BE IN THAT CAMP SO
HE WANTS TO TRY TO SOLVE THIS
CHALLENGE THAT WE FACE.
SO GOING TO WHAT CENTER BOARD
JUST SAYS IS THERE A SOLUTION TO
THIS THING WHAT I HAD SUGGESTED
IN CONVERSATIONS WITH GERMAN IN
THE OR THE PROPONENT OTHERS WAS
TWO THINGS THAT.
INFORM THE PROBLEM IF IN FACT
THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
REALLY TEST THE SCIENCE.
IF IN FACT YOU HAVE A HAPPY Là
MCCOY PALESTINIANS AND THE JEWS.
THANK WERE NEITHER SIDE TRUST
EACH OTHER HOW DO YOU CREATE A
PROCESS THAT PEOPLE TRUST. ONE
YOU PUT A TIME LINE ON IT.
YOU PUT A TIME LINE ON IT YOU
SAY THAT OKAY WE'RE GONNA DO
THIS DIAGNOSTIC BUT THIS ISN'T
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE JUST GOING
TO DELAY FOREVER BECAUSE NO ONE
TRUSTS THE PARTIES LET'S PUT A
TIME LINE.
THAT SAYS THAT THIS SCIENCE
REFUTES SCIENTIFIC REVIEW TO BE
ABLE TO BE CERTAIN BECAUSE THE
CONSEQUENCES OF OF A MISTAKE IN
ENVIRONMENTAL CONSEQUENCE
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
THIS PROPERTY WHICH IS SO UNIQUE.
IN THE MIDDLE OF NO WHERE THIS
TRUCK CANTIK AQUIFER THAT WAS
DISCOVERED GUT THIRTY SOME YEARS
AGO FORTY WHATEVERIT WAS BACK
WILL DISCOVERED IT.
BUT THE POINT IS THAT.
ALL YOU PUT A TIME ON IT.
AND THE TEST SHOULD BE DONE TO
DETERMINE BY WHAT WE SAY BUT
WHAT THE SCIENTISTS AT HOW MUCH
TIME TO THE THE SIX MONTHS THAT
YEAR WHATEVER IT IS AND PUSH
THEM TO BASICALLY GET TO THE
TRUTH.
WHATEVER IT IS IT IS FACTUAL
SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES THE AUTHOR
SAYS LET THE SCIENCE SPEAK.
TO I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THIS QUESTION BUT IT'S CERTAINLY
BEEN REYES AND I SHOULD TYPE
PROPOSED TO THE CHAIR IS ONE OF
THE LAST QUESTION IS HIS WHO ARE
THE WHO'S THE JUDGE AND JURY.
ONE OF THE REASONS THERE'S THE
CHALLENGE WITH RESPECT TO SANTA
MARGARITA IS THEY HAVE A FARM ON
THE SCALE THEY HAD AN INTEREST
IN THE OUTCOME WHICH SHOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN THE CASE TONIGHT
BUT I KNOW THAT CENTER OFFICE
RIGHT WITH RESPECT TO THE
STANDARD REVIEW.
OF THE COURT CASE AND THE I
AGREE WITH HIS ANALYSIS SO HOW
DO YOU GET IN IN THE AN ENTITY
IT WAS SUGGESTEDIN THE ANALYSIS
SOME OPTIONS I'M AGNOSTIC ON
WHAT THOSE ARE -- THERE'S AN
OPINION WELL PEOPLE ALREADY HAVE
AN OPINION THE PROJECT'S BEEN
AROUND A LONG TIME FAIR ARGUMENT
BUT AGAIN GET TO THE POINT WHERE.
YOU DON'T RESPECT THE LEGITIMACY
OF WHAT THE AUTHORS BRINGING.
POINT TAKEN CHECK DONE. TO
CREATE A A PROCESS THAT IS TOO
QUICK SO THAT NO VINCE IS NOT
ABOUT DELAY BUT IT'S ABOUT.
GETTING TO THE ISSUES TO WHICH
THE CAMP THAT.
THE GENERAL OFFICE INVOLVED AND
THREE ANOTHER ONLY ANSWER THIS
ONE I ONLY RAISE IT.
MAKE SURE THAT THE JUDGE AND
JURY OF THAT DATA IS SOMEBODY
WHO EVER BOTH SIDES HAV
CONFIDENCE IN YOU GET TO THE END
GAME THAT CENTER BOARDS I THINK
IS THE ANSWER. TO ADDRESS THE
LEGITIMACY OF BUT AVOID A AN
ISSUE WITH THE BOTH SIDES ARE IN
THE GAME AND CUT TO THE CHASE OF
WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE I DON'T
HAVE THE ANSWER IN TERMS A JUDGE
AND JURY BUT I CERTAINLY THINK A
TIME LINE.
AS GENERAL TALKED ABOUT WOULD BE
A REASONABLE SOLUTION.
BUT OTHERWISE I THINK THAT HE'S
CORRECT WITH RESPECT TO THE NEED
TO DO THIS ON THE FRONT END.
WELL MY UNDERSTANDING CENTER
HERTZBERG IS THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME IDEAS
ALREADY PROPOSED SENATE ROTH
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG EVEN
LAST YEAR OR RECENTLY ABOUT.
SOME JOINT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE
DOING FRONT AND SCIENTIFIC
REVIEW THAT.
WE STILL DON'T HAVE A RESPONSE
FROM THE OPPONENTS -- THE
PROJECT PROPONENTS YET -- I I I
KNOW THAT THERE'D BEEN SOME IDEA
LIKE WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
DIFFERENT.
AGENCIES RIGHT NOW WE'RE TO
FOCUS ON STATE LANDS COMMISSION
IN THE PRESENT BILL.
THERE'S THERE'S DISCUSSION ABOUT
D. W. ARE YOU AT ONE POINT HAD
NO IDEA ABOUT.
PUTTING THEM ALL TOGETHER ALONG
WITH DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE WHO BY THE WAY IS THE
ANALYSIS POINTS OUT STILL HAS.
SOME PURVIEW HERE -- HAVE YOU
HAD A RESPONSE YET.
FROM.
SO I WOULD ASK THE MISTER SLATER
DO YOU HAVE A A RESPONSE TO THIS
THIS CONCEPT OF DOING THE KIND
OF FRONT AND REVIEW THE AS YOU
SAID THE NOW ASSESSMENT THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT -- WITH D.
W. R. -- AS WELL AS WHAT I HAD
HEARD WAS DEPARTMENT EFFICIENT
WILDLIFE AND STATE LANDS
COMMISSION SO CERTAIN SOME SORT
OF JOINT GOVERNANCE STRUCTURES
THE NOW SAYS POINTS OUT.
THERE'S A CONFLICT AS TO WHO IS
A FAIR OBJECTIVE AN INDEPENDENT
ARBITER -- EVERYONE SORT OF HAS
A VENUE PREFERENCE I UNDERSTAND
HERE BUT EVEN OPINION ON THAT
SORT OF FRAMEWORK.
PROPOSED I DO -- THE YOU YOU
WOULD START WITH A SUBJECT
MATTER GROUNDWATER BEING RIPOSTE
IN THE DEPARTMENT OF WATER
RESOURCES IT IS THE ENTITY WHICH
IS ACTED AS A WATER MASTER
GROUNDWATER CONTACTS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES -- IT IS --
THE OVERSIGHT ENTITY FOR CIGNA
IT UNDERSTANDS THE
INTERCONNECTION BETWEEN
GROUNDWATER AND IN SERVICE WATER --
AND AND SO I WOULD SAY IT WOULD
BE THE NATURAL CONVENER FOR THE
TITULAR HEAD OF WHATEVER INTO DE
THERE WAS.
MAN I THINK YOU COULD YOU COULD
DO IT IN AS LONG AS IT'S OPEN
AND TRANSPARENT AND I THINK
FOCUSED ON THE SUBJECT MATTER
THAT THE SENATOR HAS.
AND AND THE PROJECT OPPONENTS
HAVE GREATEST FOCUS ON IS.
IS THE INTERCONNECTION IN THE
SPRING IN THE HARM TO FISH AND
WILDLIFE AT THAT SPRING -- YOU
COULD EITHER HAVE DEAL YOU ARE
HANDLED INDEPENDENTLY OR CONVENE
A PROCESS AND IT IS NOT UNLIKE
OTHER TECHNICAL REVIEW PROCESS
SEES WHERE.
ALL SCIENTISTS WITH CREDENTIALS
CAN COME AND PARTICIPATE AND THE
ARBITER OF THE THE FINDER AND
AND THE RECEIVER OF THAT
INFORMATION AND DECISION MAKER
IS D. W. R. -- BUT IT'S NOT
LIMITING IN WHO IT LISTENS TO IT
LISTENS THE BEST AVAILABLE
SCIENCE AND WHOEVER'S PRODUCING
IT AND HOLD IT UP TO CRITICAL
THOUGHT.
SO.
WHAT'S YOUR OPINION ON THE JOINT
GOVERNANCE STRUCTURE I THINK
THAT THE JOINT GOVERNANCE IS
MORE CUMBERSOME THERE'S NOT A
LOT OF EXPERIENCE AT THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AT EVALUATING
GROUNDWATER ISSUES -- AND AND I
THINK IF YOU ASSIGNED TO YOU
HAVE YOU ARE THE RESPONSIBILITY
THEY HAVE THE THEY SHOULD HAVE
THE RIGHT. TO INTERVIEW ANYBODY
THEY WANT TO TO GAIN THE BEST
AVAILABLE SCIENCE AND
INFORMATION WHICH HELPS THEM
COME TO THE CONCLUSION THAT
NEEDS TO BE.
GAINED SO I THINK BY LAW BY
POINTING TO HAVE YOU ARE YOU
OPEN AND OPEN IT UP -- TATE TO A
PROCESS AND INPUT.
IT WOULD BE.
COULD INCLUDE PROJECT OPPONENTS
OCCUR IN IN IN IN IN INDEED IN
FACT TO GET THE RESOLUTION WE
HOPE FOR WE WANT THEM TO COME
FORWARD WITH THEIR SCIENTIFIC
POSITION SO AGAIN IT CAN BE HELD
UP TO CRITICAL THOUGHT AND
LIKEWISE.
PAPERS AND AND SCIENTIFIC
REPORTS THAT HAVE BEEN COMPILED
BY THE SANTA MARGARITA THE
COUNTY -- IN KIDDIES COULD ALSO
BE CONSIDERED THESE ARE.
A SAID EARLIER IN A CONVERSATION --
A MEASURING TAPE IS IS A
MEASURING TAPE AND IT AND AND WE
MEASURE DATA AND THAT IS RIGHT
THAT SHOULD NOT BE TO SUB -- THE
SUBJECT OF OPINION AND AND THOSE
THINGS THAT ARE PRESENTED AND
AND ANALYZED MEDIA BY D. W. R.
SHOULD BE.
OPEN TRANSPARENT AND THE AND THE
DECISIONS BASED ON IT.
AVAILABLE UNDERSTOOD -- AND I
WANTED TO GET AN OPINION FROM
FROM THE PROPONENTS OF BILLS WAS
THE OPPONENTS ABOUT THE ANALYSIS
IT DOES POINT OUT SOME OF THESE
FURTHER PENDING REGULATORY.
DECISIONS.
IN BOTH FROM I BELIEVE STATE
LANDS.
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE'S.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN I'M SORRY IN
THE METROPOLITAN WATER DISTRICT
AS TO WHETHER TO OPERATE UNDER.
THE PRIOR WHEELING AGREEMENT OR
OR OR SOME NEW FORMAL WHEELING
BECAUSE OF ITS YET TO BE
SUBMITTED SO.
MAYBE I'LL STOP I'LL START WITH
THE AUTHOR AND AND AND SPONSOR
ON ON THAT.
WELL SUBSEQUENT -- WELL MISTER
CHAIR IN THE FIRST PLACE THERE
ARE AGENCIES THAT SHOULD THIS
PROJECT -- MOVE START TO MOVE
FURTHER HAVE ADDITIONAL ROLES TO
PLAY.
BERMAN OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AS A
LAKE AND STREAM BED ALTERATION
PROCESS TO DETERMINE AN
AGREEMENT WHERE.
THE PROJECT CROSSES DOES IT
WASHES AND THINGS LIKE THAT BUT
REMEMBER AT THAT POINT IT'S I
THINK THE TERM OF ART IS
RESPONSIBLE AGENCY SO.
DE BERMAN FISH AND WILDLIFE'S
BOUND BY THE CAN BY THE WITH THE
SCIENCE IN THE E. R. -- SO
THERE'S NO AND AND IN ANY EVENT
WHETHER IT IS OR IT ISN'T
THERE'S NO INDEPENDENT REVIEW
THE KIND OF FRONT END ASSESSMENT
AND I'M TALKING ABOUT.
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION OF
COURSE SAYS.
AUTHORITY WHERE THE PROJECT
CROSSES OF STATE OWNED LAND AND
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THERE'S A
STRIP ABOUT A MILE LONG AND TWO
HUNDRED FEET WIDE.
THAT MAY OR MAY NOT BE IMPACTED
OR CROSSED BY THIS PROPOSED
PROJECT AND IF IT IS THEN -- AS
A LEASE WITH THE STATE IN THE
STATE LANDS COMMISSION NEEDS TO
BE NEGOTIATED AGAIN.
NO INDEPENDENT AUTHORITY TO
CONDUCT ANY SORT OF FRONT AND
SCIENTIFIC REVIEW ASSESSMENT IN
RECONCILIATION BY.
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION AND
OF COURSE THE METROPOLITAN WATER
DISTRICT IN THE WHEELING
AGREEMENT THE PROPOSAL HERE.
IS TO IS TO PUT THE PUB TAKE
TRANSPORT THE WATER.
FROM THE AQUIFER ABOUT FORTY SIX
OR SO MILES IN PIPE UNDERGROUND
TO THE CALIFORNIA AQUEDUCT AS I
RECALL.
AND M. W. D.'S AUTHORITY AT THAT
POINT IS TO ASSESS.
THE IMPACT ON THE ACT WITH A TO
PROVE THE DESIGN OF THE FACILITY
AND ALSO -- RESOLVE ANY CONCERNS
THAT M. M. W. D. HAS WITH
RESPECT TO CHEMICALS IN THE
WATER THAT ARE PULLED OUT.
OF THE AQUIFER THERE'S A AN
ISSUE HAVING TO DO WITH CHROME --
SIX AND PERHAPS SOME OTHER
ISSUES -- HAVING TO DO WITH THE
WATER THAT WOULD NEED TO BE
RESOLVED BY END OF THE DAY BUT
AGAIN.
IN W. YOU KNOW AND I'M NOT THE
WATER EXPERT MISTER SLATER.
HAS OF A FEW MORE YEARS AND I
BUT IN W. D. HAS THE AUTHORITY
TO DEAL WITH THESE ISSUES.
NOT CONDUCT THE KIND OF
INDEPENDENT SCIENTIFIC ASSESS
WHEN AT THE FRONT IN THE
RECONCILIATION OF U. S.
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY NATIONAL PARK
SERVICE SCIENCE OTHER SCIENCE.
WITH THE KIDDIES OF PROPOSAL --
ON THE FIFTY THOUSAND ACRE FEET
DOES THAT ADDRESS YOUR
CONGESTION DOES.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- SO LET LET ME BEGIN
WITH -- NOTHING THAT WE WOULD DO
HERE WOULD BE INTENDED TO YOU
SIR FOR TAKE AWAY THE
JURISDICTION OF THE OTHER
AGENCIES ARE YET TO PASS ON THE
PROJECT.
SO I START WITH WATER CODE
SECTION THIS IS AN AMENDMENT
INTO THE WHEELING STATURE.
SO -- WATER CODE SECTION
EIGHTEEN TEN D..
AT THE REQUEST OF INYO MONO
COUNTY BACK IN NINETEEN EIGHTY
SIX INCLUDED A PROVISION.
PREVENTED TRANSFERS OCCURRING
THROUGH WHEELING -- IF THAT
WOULD HARM FISH AND WILDLIFE'S
SO WHAT THIS IS IS THIS IS A
SEPARATE ONE OFF.
AND I CAN GIVE YOU PRESIDENT FOR
THIS WHEN THEY WERE WHEN THE
WILLING STATURE WAS INITIALLY
PUT IN PLACE THERE WAS A TIME IN.
NINETEEN NINETY SEVEN THAT THE
LEGISLATURE FOR EXIGENT
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT EXISTED --
OVER THE USE OF THE COLORADO
RIVER ACT WITH OCT -- IMPOSER
ADOPTED A BILL EIGHTEEN TWELVE
POINT FIVE WHICH DIRECTED THE
DEPARTMENT OF WATER RESOURCES TO
CONDUCT IN AN INVESTIGATION TO
MAKE A RECOMMENDATION -- IT WAS
URGENCY BILL IT LASTED -- FOR I
BELIEVE EIGHTEEN MONTHS WHILE
DAVID KENNEDY PROVIDED HIS INPUT
I RAISE THAT BECAUSE THIS
PROVISION NEED TO BE RECONCILED
WITH EIGHTEEN TEN DAY MATT MATT
IS GOING TO MAKE ITS
DETERMINATIONS UNDER EIGHTEEN
TEN D. LOOK AT ALL OF THE THE
PROVISIONS THAT HOUSE TO LOOK AT
THIS IS.
A MORE FOCUSED ANALYSIS WHICH
WOULD BE ADDITIVE AND IT WOULD
BE FOCUSED ON A COUNTY AND A
SPECIFIC PROJECT.
SOIN IN THIS INSTANCE THEN WE
WOULD WE WOULD RECONCILE THE
POTENTIAL INCONSISTENCIES
BETWEEN EIGHTEEN TEN THE AND
THIS PROVISION BY MAKING IT
APPLICABLES ONLY. TO THIS AREA.
AND IN AND THINK THIS IS A
PERFECTLY SUITABLE WAY TO GO
ABOUT IT.
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF A COMMONER
QUESTION -- SENATE JACKSON THANK
YOU HAD.
I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF HISTORY TO THIS
AND AND I'M VERY SENSITIVE TO IT
I HAVE A LOCAL.
A WONDERFUL COMPANY THAT.
DOESN'T WANT TO SEE THIS BILL
PASSED SO I'M PARTICULARLY
SENSITIVE TO THIS ISSUE BUT IT
SEEMS TO ME AND I HAVE THE
HIGHEST REGARD.
FOR US SENATOR ROTH HE DOES HIS
HOMEWORK LIKE NOBODY I KNOW.
AND MY UNDERSTANDING IS REALLY
WHAT HE'S ASKING FORCES UP FRONT.
EFFORT.
AND AND SO I I WANT TO SIMPLIFY
THIS CONSENT MY QUESTION WAS A
GENUINE.
ONE REGARDLESS OF HOW YOU
ULTIMATELY DECIDE WHAT THAT UP
FRONT APPROACH WOULD BE.
ARE YOU WILLING TO CONSIDER.
DOING THIS BEFORE YOU INVEST ALL
THAT MONEY BEFORE A LOT OF
PEOPLE CONTRACT WITH YOU FOR
THAT WATER BEFORE BEFORE THE
TABLE IS SET YOU KNOW SOMETIMES.
IT'S IT'S EASIER TO ASK
FORGIVENESS THAN PERMISSION AND
MIKE MY QUESTION HERE IS WHETHER
OR NOT YOU WOULD BE WILLING TO
HAVE THIS AND ALEC ALL
EVERYTHING ELSE.
WHATEVER'S HAPPENED HAPPENED WE
ARE HERE TODAY WOULD YOU BE
WILLING TO DO THIS UP FRONT --
IMPACT IF VALUE OR FRONT END
IMPACT EVALUATION THAT
SPECIFICALLY DEALS WITH THIS
PARTICULAR SPRING.
AND SO THERE CAN BE SOME.
SOME UNDERSTANDING RECOGNITION
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THE JUDGMENT IF
INDEED THIS IS GOING TO HAVE
THAT.
SACRAMENTO IMPACT IT IS POSSIBLE
THAT IS BELIEVED TO BE THE CASE.
THAT'S JUST HOW I WANT TO KNOW
IS MATTER WOULD YOU DINNER
SENATOR JACKSON ANSWERS YES
[inaudible]
UNEQUIVOCALLY YES.
THANK YOU THAT HAS DEFINED AS
YOU JUST DEFINED IT AS THE AS
THE CHAIR TO FIND.
LET THE RECORD SHOW UP WE'RE
GONNA WE'RE GONNA TRY TO
TRUNCATE THIS THIS UP SO OF ONE
LEARN COMMON AND THEY'LL MOVE
FORWARD.
I WANNA MAKE CERTAIN -- THAT
WE'RE ON THE SAME PAGE I WANT TO
THANK -- AND CENTER ROTH FOR ALL
THAT YOU'RE DOING OF COURSE --
KIDDIES AND THE COMMENTS -- I'M
FROM NOW FOR MORE FIRMLY THE
OPINION THAT REASONABLE MINDS
CAN CERTAINLY PREVAIL EVEN IN
COMPLICATED SITUATIONS.
JUST SO I'M.
CLEAR A JOT DOWN A COUPLE OF
NOTES ON WHAT.
WOULD BE PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
DECEIVES THE MAKER OF THE ITEM
WOULD BE WILLING TO MOVE FORWARD.
BASED ON WHAT CENTER JACKSON HAD
SAID IN YOUR AGREEMENT --
RESPONSE.
IS THAT THERE WOULD BE A THAT D.
W. R..
WOULD YOU SERVE AS LEAD AGENCY
TO CONVENE AN UP FRONT.
OUR STUDY.
OF THIS PROJECT.
AND IT'S SUSTAINABILITY.
THE D. W. R. WOULD SIT AS A
TRUSTEE -- ON THE BOARD.
MOVING FORWARD.
AND THAT THERE WOULD BE AN
ANNUAL OR AS NEEDED TO REVIEW TO
MAKE CERTAIN THAT THERE IS NO
DEPLETION -- THAT IS UNFORESEEN.
BUT THAT THAT STUDY BY D. W. R.
IS LIMITED TO THE SPRINGS.
IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID EARLIER MR
OFF ITS.
SENATOR THE PROBLEM WITH
NEGOTIATING AMENDMENTS FROM THE
NOW IS IT'S TOUGH.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE LANGUAGE
REALLY LOOKS LIKE AND THEIR
IMPLICATIONS LOCATIONS.
I DISAGREE WITH WHAT MISTER
SLATER SAID WITH THE DIP WITH
RESPECT TO THE DISCHARGE AND
RECHARGE RATES THE DISCHARGING
RESEARCH JUST CHARGE AND
RECHARGE RATES DIRECTLY IMPACT
THE SPRINGS IF YOU'RE PULLING
MORE WATER OUT OF THE AQUIFER.
THEN YOU'RE PUTTING BACK IN
DEPENDING ON HOW THE SCIENCE
RESOLVES THIS.
IF THE SPRINGS ARE CONNECTED
BOTH BONANZA AND ANY OTHER THERE
FOR FIVE OTHER SPRINGS
ASSOCIATED OUT THERE IN THE
WATER LEVEL IN THE SPRINGS IS
DEPLETED WHICH IMPACTS BIGHORN
SHEEP VEGETATION THIS SAID THE
OTHER SO IT'S ALL INTERCONNECTED.
AND IT IS A IT IS A TOP TO
BOTTOM REVIEW AND RECONCILIATION
OF THE SCIENCE.
I'M PERFECTLY WILLING TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHO DOES IT
I'M MORE PERSONALLY AGNOSTIC ON
THE POINT.
BUT I'VE NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
BECAUSE UNTIL THIS MORNING.
WE HAVE NOT HAD A CONVERSATION
ABOUT FRONT END REVIEW EVER.
WITH KIDDIES SO I'M PERFECTLY
WILLING IF THIS BILL SHOULD
HAPPEN TO MOVE OUT OF THIS
COMMITTEE AND I HAVE NO IDEA. TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION AND TO WORK TO A A
COMPROMISE SOLUTION THAT MISTER
SLATER AND HIS COMPANY HAVE
CONFIDENCE.
IT ACCOMPLISHES MY SOLE
OBJECTIVE HERE WHICH IS TO
RESOLVE RECONCILE THE SCIENCE
AND SENATE ENVIRONMENTALLY
SUSTAINABLE PUMPING RIGHT UP I
PLEDGE THAT TO YOU [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
SO THERE'S A MOTION I DON'T
THINK WE'RE GOING TO RESOLVE
DECADES OF CONFLICT HERE FROM
THE DIS TODAY BUT I DO WANT TO
NOTE THAT I THINK SOME PROGRESS
HAS BEEN MADE.
SOME POSITIONS HAVE BEEN HAVE
EVOLVED.
I TRUST IN THE SENATOR IN THE
AUTHOR FOR ALL HIS DILIGENCE. TO
TO TO TAKE THIS INTO
CONSIDERATION -- WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AT TO TO A MEN AT TWO MEN
THEN MOVED TO APPROPRIATIONS BUT
YOU KNOW THE THE RECORD
ESTABLISHED IN THIS HEARING THEN
THE WILLINGNESS TO LOOK AT SOME
OTHER KIND OF FRONT AND REVIEW --
PRIOR TO PROJECT INITIATION I
THINK IS.
NOT WORTHY AND WORTHY OF
CONSIDERATION.
SO I WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU.
YOU IN THE PROPONENTS CONSIDER
THAT GOING FORWARD.
AND WORK WITH US IN THE-COMMITTEE -- SHOULD THIS BILL
MOVE FORWARD I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THE MEASURE TODAY.
AND IGN NOW JING THAT YOU'VE
BEEN WORKING IN GOOD FAITH THIS
WHOLE TIME AND I KNOW IT'S BEEN
A HEADACHE.
BUT ALL IMPORTANT ISSUES ARE.
CENTERS FOR DO YOU WANT TO JUMP
IN WITH ONE LAST A PIECE OF
WISDOM YES SIR I JUST THINK
MISTER MAYES WANNA MAKE SURE.
I WAS SUPPORTED BUT I I I JUST
CANNOT STRESS ENOUGH.
THAT I THINK THAT THE TWO ISSUES
I REYES NEED TO BE RESOLVED AT
LEAST AS RELATES FROM MY OWN
VOTING ON THIS THING GOING
FORWARD IS.
ONE FIGURING OUT A TIME LINES
THAT IT'S FAIR PROCESS WHATEVER
THAT IS I I DON'T KNOW THAT IS
I'M NOT AN EXPERT.
BUT I THINK IT'S A FAIR
OBSERVATION IT SHOULD BE A TIME
LINE FOR THIS THIS ANALYSIS TO
BE DONE EXPERTS WILL HAVE TO
MAKE THAT DETERMINATION AND I
ASK THAT YOU.
WORK ON THAT AND SECONDLY YOU
KNOW THE ISSUE OF WHO THE THAT
THE JURY IS IF YOU WILL BECOMES
VERY IMPORTANT A JUDGE AND JURY
BECOME VERY IMPORTANT AGAIN WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO DO IS TO ANSWER
A VERY IMPORTANT QUESTION.
IN A MANNER THAT'S FAIR AND
PROVIDES CONFIDENCE TO TO OUR
ROLE AS IN GOVERNMENT THAT WE
WE'VE DONE THIS THING RIGHT.
AND NOT JUST STUCK A FINGER IN
SOMEBODY'S ON CENTER WE DO HAVE
A MOTION.
WITH THAT PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
IS TO PASS AS A MINUTE TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN
STERN HI ACCIONES ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE PORGES [inaudible]
ZERO HERTZBERG BOB HERTZBERG BY
HUESO.
JACKSON AYE JACKSON AYE MONNING.
MONEY.
NINE THE BILL HAS FIVE ROOMS SO.
THE BILL AS FIVE VOTES WE WILL
LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL -- FOR
THE VICE CHAIR -- BUT WE HAVE
IT'S FIVE ZERO AS OF NOW.
THANK YOU SENATOR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR
PATIENCE THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT YOU OKAY SINCE
[inaudible]
I GUESS
.
FILE ITEM SIX SENATOR NIELSEN.
SB.
TWO TWO SIX BUT IN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THIS PAST SEE.
THIS BILL IS DEALING WITH.
THE DAMAGE THUS FAR WROUGHT.
BUT I COULD CONTEMPLATE AN
ONGOING NEED.
BUT THIS COULD SET.
A PATTERN.
FOR THE SENATE BILL.
TWO TWO SIX I WILL ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
IT CREATES A WATERSHED
RESTORATION GRANT PROGRAM AND
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE OF UP TO
MILLION DOLLARS FOR UP TO FIVE
TIME FIVE YEARS.
THE COUNTIES THAT WERE.
UNDER EMERGENCY PROCLAMATIONS
FOR THE 202-017-22018.
WILDFIRES.
NOW THAT'S THE UNIVERSE WE'RE
DEALING WITH THAT WE'RE PROBABLY
GOING TO HAVE MORE PROBLEMS.
CAN GET CATASTROPHIC THINGS IN
THE SITUATION IN THE FUTURE.
THESE FIRES COME THROUGH AND ONE
OF THEM THAT I DEALT WITH WAS.
SKIPPING AHEAD SIX FOOTBALL
FIELDS.
THE MINUTE.
IN FIFTY MILE AN HOUR WINDS WITH
CANYONS ON EITHER SIDE.
HAVING.
DEALT WITH THESE FOR MOST
WILDLIFE [inaudible]
THE DESTRUCTION.
CAN BE LONG LASTING.
IN SOME CASES.
THE TOPSOIL IS STERILIZED.
TAKES MANY MANY DECADES. TO COME
BACK [inaudible]
WILDLIFE'S [inaudible]
IS DESTROYED.
COMMERCIAL PRODUCT AND PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
IN THE CASE OF SOME FIRES IT
WITH EXPERIENCE.
MY CASE EIGHTY FIVE HUMAN LIVES
WERE LOST LAST YEAR.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS A
WATERSHED RESTORATION GRANT
PROGRAM? TO ALLOW SOME HELP
LET'S SAVE ABOUT A MILLION
DOLLARS FOR A GRANT. FOR A FIVE
YEAR PERIOD OF TIME.
THE COUNTIES TO DO WILDLIFE.
MEANWHILE FIRE.
RESTORATION NOW ADDED WILD LIFE
TO THAT BECAUSE IF YOU RESTORE.
THE FORCE IN THE WILD LANDS
YOU'RE GOING TO RESTORE.
THE WILDLIFE AS WELL.
IT IS CRITICAL.
THERE ARE SOME POINTS THAT YOU
HAVE TO BE WORKED OUT.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE LOOKING AT
GENERAL FUND THAT.
WILL BE EXAMINING OTHER SOURCES
THIS BILL WILL GO TO THE
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY AS WELL.
AS WE'RE LOOKING AT SOME SICK
WHAT.
MOVEMENTS.
CORD TEMPERING IF YOU WILL.
AND WILL HAVE TO HAVE AN
APPROPRIATIONS CONSIDERATION OF
FOR THE MONEY.
WOULD COME FROM.
BUT THAT SAID.
THE WHOLE JOB.
GOAL HERE IS TO DO WHAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY. TO RESTORE THE SOILS
[inaudible]
THE VEGETATION [inaudible]
WILDLIFE.
ON THE FORCE IN A WHILE LANCE.
CLAIM THIS VERY.
VERY MUCH.
DESTROYED.
LAND IN CALIFORNIA.
THERE IS ANOTHER SIDE TO THIS TO
THAT AFFECTS.
OUR WATER WICKS.
WITH THE LAN DENUDED.
THEN WE HAVE.
GREAT PROBLEMS WITH EROSION
[inaudible]
SENATE SUBSTATION.
AND ALSO THEN WE HAVE.
TREES. TO COME DOWN.
AND PREVENT THE WATER FLOW.
AND CREATE AN EFFECT DANCE
[inaudible]
THE EMPTY.
NOW WE'RE NOT GONNA DEAL WITH
THE HALF FILLED.
IN THE RIVERS IN THE BY WAYS
RIGHT NOW.
THIS BILL WILL LOW.
CONTAIN THAT EROSION.
THAT DOES HAPPEN.
SO IT'S FAIRLY SIMPLE -- I DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK YOU'RE JUST
VOTING ON A CONCEPT HERE BECAUSE
WE'RE VERY RESOLVED IN WITH AS
MANY COUNTIES AS ARE AFFECTED I
AM CONFIDENT THAT WE'RE GOING TO
GAIN THE SUPPORT THAT WE NEED
FOR THE ONGOING AMOUNT OF MONEY.
TO BE PUT IN THE BUDGET EVERY
YEAR AND NO FRANKLY A FOR THE
AMOUNT OF DAMAGE THAT WE HAVE
BROUGHT THIS IS.
NOT EVEN GOING TO BE CLOSE TO
SUFFICIENT.
BUT WE COULD.
MAKE SOME PROGRESS AND I WOULD
ASK YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU BEGIN
THAT PROCESS.
THANK YOU A CENTER NIELSEN --
THERE IS APPARENTLY NO --
OPPOSITION ON THIS IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SEE TO HAVE WITNESSED
SAY A FEW WORDS.
PLEASE FEEL FREE.
A BRIEF CARE SINGLE BIGGIE WITH
A CALIFORNIA FORESTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL JUST A COUPLE OF STATISTICS
WITH REGARDS TO THE IMPACT THESE
WILDFIRES HAVE HAD ON OUR
WATERSHEDS.
IN ADDITION TO RELEASING TOXINS
INTO A WATER SUPPLY THESE FIRES
KILL HEALTHY TREE ROOTS WITHOUT
THE ROOTS CONTAMINATING --
SETTLEMENT AND ASHER FLUSH BY
RAIN INTO THE RESERVOIRS RIVERS
LAKES AND SUPPLY CITIES WITH
DRINKABLE WATER.
IN ADDITION A STUDY PREDICTED
THAT WILDFIRES COULD DOUBLE THE
AMOUNT OF SENTIMENT IN A THIRD
OF THE LARGEST WESTERN
WATERSHEDS BY.
TWENTY FIFTY A WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IF YOU'D
PLEASE STEP FORWARD.
GOOD MORNING ADAM CAN UNITS ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION THERE IS NONE NOTED
BUT IF THERE IS.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE BRING BACK
TO THE DIET SENATOR HUESO.
IS GENERALLY ARE ON THE
PROVISION THAT -- EXAM THESE
PROJECTS FROM C. C<c.cyan> I JUST</c>
WANNA MAKE SURE THERE'S NO ABUSE
AND PEOPLE.
CITING IN A A DEVELOPMENT
PROJECT OR IMPROVEMENT PROJECT
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE
MITIGATION PROJECT AND USE SEE
CA AND SAY THIS IS -- EXEMPT
FROM SICK WHEN THE REAL UNDER
THE LAW.
U. S. TWO S. SITE SPECIFIC.
OBJECTION PACIFIC CENTER HUESO.
YES WHEN WHEN ANY OF THESE
PROJECTS WILL BE UNDERTAKEN
THERE WILL BE KIND OF A LITTLE
SECTION THE SOMEBODY CHECKS OFF
ON THE BUT ON THE BOX AND AN
EXAM SEQUEL -- AND I I JUST A
THAT IS USUALLY DONE.
BY THE AGENCY THAT'S CONDUCT IN
THE AND I JUST.
THIS CAN BE ANY AGES AGO BE A
CITY IT COULD BE A COUNTY AND I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THIS THIS
IS NOT USED AND ABUSED GOING TO
GO FOR A LONG WAY THROUGH THE
PROCESS AND THIS WILL BE.
HI DEEPLY SCRUTINIZED -- SURE
YOU.
AND I I'M SYMPATHETIC WITH AND
THAT'S MICHAEL I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE SOMEBODY'S WATCHING AND
SOMEBODY IS IS GOING TO BE
LOOKING AT THIS SENATE HUESO I'M
I'M ADVICE AT THE BILL.
IT IS -- DO PASSED TO RULES WERE
WILL LIKELY BE.
REASSIGNED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY WHERE THE ISSUE WILL BE
OKAY THAT'S FINE -- WE WILL HAVE
THE PLENTY OF REVIEWS IN BOTH
HOUSES.
CENTER BOARD JUST SOME OF THE
BILL VERY GOOD THERE'S A MOTION
BY SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO MOTIONS
BUT WE'LL GO WITH THE FIRST ONE
CENTER HUESO YOU.
OBVIOUSLY HAVE SUPPORT OF TO
CLASS AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN MADAM SECRETARY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO RULES
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND IT IS STERN JONES.
JONES I ELLEN.
BURGESS BUSH'S AYE CABALLERO.
CABALLERO AYE HERTZBERG.
HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON JACKSON AYE
MONEY.
MONEY AND I IT HAS SIX POSIBLE
KUN CALL FOR THE MEMBER
CIRCULATE SIX VOTES BUT WE WILL
KEEP THE MATTER ON CALL FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU CENTER
MANAGER MEMBERS.
NEXT UP IS SENATOR FURTADO --
SHE HAS FILE ITEM ELEVEN SB.
FIVE FIFTY NINE GOOD AFTERNOON
PLEASE TAKE A SEAT IN.
IF YOU HAVE WITNESSES WHO ARE.
A TESTIFYING WE HAVE TWO
WITNESSES APPROXIMATELY TWO
MINUTES EACH.
AND ALL OTHER WITNESSES WILL
JUST BE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
GIVE THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
OR ANSWER QUESTIONS.
DURING THAT TIME FRAME.
GOOD MORNING SENATOR FURTADO THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY I AM HERE TO INTRODUCE SB.
FIVE FIVE NINE SB FIVE FIVE NINE
AIMS TO ADDRESS THE NEED TO
RESTORE WATER SUPPLY IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY.
TODAY MORE THAN A HUNDRED RURAL
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAN JOAQUIN
VALLEY HAVE CONTAMINATED TAP
WATER WHILE MANY OTHERS HAVE
SEEN THE WELLS GO DRY.
COMPLETED IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE
IT RUNS A HUNDRED FIFTY TWO
MILES FROM FRIGHT DOWN TO THE
KERN RIVER IN BAKERSFIELD.
IT IS A KEEP FACILITY FOR
DELIVERING CLEAN RUNOFF FROM THE
SAN JOAQUIN RIVER WATERSHED TO
RECHARGE GROUNDWATER AQUIFER'S.
SOME OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST
NOTABLE COMMUNITIES RELY ON THE
SYSTEM TO DELIVER CLEAN WATER
INCLUDING SEVEN CITIES AND
COUNTIES THAT SERVE NEARLY A
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND MUNICIPAL
CONNECTIONS AS WELL AS EIGHTEEN
THOUSAND INDIVIDUAL FAMILY FARMS.
TODAY PORTIONS OF THE CANAL HAS
DECLINED BY TWELVE FEET BELOW
ITS ORIGINAL DESIGN ONE THIRD OF
THE CANAL HAS SUFFERED THE LOSS
OF 60% OF ITS CARRYING CAPACITY.
MANY COMMUNITIES WITHIN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY INCLUDING FARMERS
FAMILIES BUSINESSES.
AND CHILDREN DON'T HAVE ACCESS
TO THE MOST BASIC HUMAN RIGHT
CLEAN WATER.
SB FIVE FIVE NINE WILL INVEST IN
THE IMPROVEMENT OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE -- TO ACT THE
CANAL WILL CONTINUE TO LOSE UP
TO THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER PER YEAR IN
DELIVERIES AND HAVE SEVERE
IMPACTS OUR LOCAL ECONOMY AND
BEYOND.
AND INVESTMENT FOR THE FRANK
KERN CANALS AND INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA FAMILIES. TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY DOUG THE FOOTAGE.
FROM A CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER
FOR THE FRONT WATER AUTHORITY.
AND BRYCE MARKETEER EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE EASTERN TROLL
GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABILITY
AGENCY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A TWO
WITNESSES TWO MINUTES EACH AND
THEN THEY'LL BE AN OPPORTUNITY
I'M SURE OF QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU COMMITTEE GOOD MORNING
MY NAME STUDY FLETCHER I AM THE
CHIEF OPERATING OFFICER FOR THE
FRONT WATER AUTHORITY I OVERSEE
THE FRANK KERN CANALS OPERATION
MAINTENANCE AND REPAIR.
WHICH INCLUDES -- OUR ON GOING
WORK. TO KEEP THE CONVEYANCE
CAPACITY OF THE FRANKLIN CAN NOW.
ALTHOUGH IT'S A GOVERNMENT OF
OLDER THE ALTHOUGH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT DOES HOLD THE TITLE
TO THE CANAL -- IT'S IN THE
CENTER IT'S ESSENTIALLY A LOCAL
WILL REGIONAL FACILITY FRANK
CONTRACTORS -- WHO USE THE CANAL
INCLUDE THREE LARGE CITIES IN
THE VALLEY AND DOZENS OF WATER
IN IRRIGATION DISTRICTS?
ALL OF WHOM OF PAY THE OWN M.
AND IF PAID OFF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR THE CANAL ITSELF
SO THE ORIGINAL CONSTRUCTION.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS
HANDED OVER THE RESPONSIBILITIES
THAT CAN OUT TO THE FRONT WATER
AUTHORITY IN.
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX FRANK KERN
CANALS A STATEWIDE IMPORTANCE
BECAUSE IT IT'S IS VERY
DIFFERENT THAN MOST OF THE OTHER
FACILITIES BECAUSE IT WAS
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED TO SUPPORT
SUPPORT GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY ON THE SIDE.
AND IT'S DONE THAT VERY
SUCCESSFULLY.
THOUSAND AND NINETEEN THAT MARKS
THE SEVENTIETH ANNIVERSARY THE
FRANK KERN CAN NOW SO WE HAVE A
PRETTY LARGE AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE ISSUE GOING ON
WHERE THE CANAL IS LOST SOME OF
ITS CONVEYANCE CAPACITY DUE TO
SUBSIDENCE.
WHEN THE TWO THOUSAND AND TEN
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DROUGHT
THERE IS A SEVERE CONSTRUCTION
ON THE LOWER TWO THIRDS OF THE
FRANK KERN CANAL NEAR THE TOWN
OF PORTER BILL DID OVER PUMPING
OF THE GROUNDWATER -- THAT HIS
THAT IS BECAUSE THIS PAGE POINT
TO DRAMATICALLY REDUCE THE
CANALS CONVEYANCE CAPACITY. TO
JUST ABOVE 40% OF ITS DESIGN MAX.
THIS REDUCTION MEANS THAT IN
WHAT YEARS LIKE TWENTY SEVENTEEN
AND THE YEAR THAT WE'RE
EXPERIENCING THIS YEAR AS MUCH
AS THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRE
FEET OF WATER.
AS NOT ABLE TO BE SUPPLIED --
DOWN THE CANAL AND PUT IN THE
GROUND.
IN TERMS OF A DOLLAR VALUE THAT
WOULD BE EQUIVALENT TO ABOUT
SEVEN HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
MILLION DOLLARS AVERAGE ANNUAL.
AND THE VALUE OF THE CANAL
HOWEVER IS IS MUCH GREATER THAN
THAT BECAUSE WITHOUT PUTTING
WATER IN A YEAR THAT'S A LARGE
YEAR WE DON'T HAVE WATER IN
DROUGHT YEARS.
SO THERE'S NO CARRY OVER TO BE
ABLE TO TO GO INTO FOR DRYER
YEARS.
WHEN WE DISCOVERED THIS PROBLEM
IN TWENTY SIXTEEN THE FRONT
WATER AUTHORITY IMMEDIATELY GOT
ON IT?
GOT MOVING AND AND SCOPE THE
PROBLEM THERE.
TOO NARROWED CORRECTIVE ACTIONS
THAT WE'RE LOOKING AT RIGHT NOW
ONE IS -- A RAISING OF THE BANKS
ON THE ON THE FRANK KERN CANAL
AND THE OTHER IS -- A PARALLEL
REALIGNMENT OF THE FRANK KERN
CANAL.
BOTH OF THOSE WE EXPECTED A
PLANNING DESIGNING NET AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING WE
DONE BY THE END OF THE YEAR.
AND FOR THE CURRENT COST OF
FIXING THE CAN NOW WE EXPECT TO
BE IN THE CAR ON THE ORDER OF
THREE HUNDRED AND NINE MILLION
DOLLARS THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS NUMBER THE
PUBLIC THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE YOU OF MY
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT FOR SB.
FIVE FIVE NINE BUT WE'VE
INTRODUCTION MY NAME IS BRYCE
MAC TIER UNDERGRADUATE OF DUKE
UNIVERSITY AND I CURRENTLY SERVE
AS THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE EASTERN TO LEE GSA. FIVE
YEARS AFTER THE PASSAGE OF SIGMA
I'M PROUD TO BE ON THE GROUND
IMPLEMENTING CENTER PATHWAYS
VISION FOR STABLE GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT AT THE LOCAL LEVEL.
HE'S INTO LEE IS A JOINT POWERS
AUTHORITY THAT WAS FORMED.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN BY SIX
LOCAL WATER DISTRICTS THE CITY
OF PORTABILITY AND COUNTY OF
TULARE IN ORDER O PROVIDE FOR
THE STABLE MANAGEMENT
GROUNDWATER RESOURCES WITHIN OUR
JURISDICTION.
HE'S GOING TO LEASE
RESPONSIBILITY IS VAST WE COVER
JURISDICTION OVER A HUNDRED SIX
ONE THOUSAND ACRES IN SIZE.
WITH OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
RESIDENTS ALL OF WHOM.
LIVE IN EITHER DISADVANTAGED OR
SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. FOR OVER FOR THE
HOME TO APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
FIVE THOUSAND ACRES OF
PRODUCTIVE YEAR GET LAND THAT
SERVES IN ONE WAY OR ANOTHER AS
THE PRIMARY SOURCE OF INCOME AND
JOBS IN OUR AREA OF THE WORLD.
SAFE SECURE RELIABLE AND QUALITY
SUPPLIES OF SURFACE WATER VITAL
TO OUR COMMUNITY DAY AND VITAL
TO OUR COMMUNITY TOMORROW AS WE
SEEK TO CREATE A SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE.
OVERLYING THE TO SUBBASIN MY
AGENCIES IN THE MIDST OF
PREPARING IT'S GROUND WATER
SUSTAINABILITY PLAN IN
COLLABORATION WITH LOCAL AGENCY
PARTNERS.
THAT WILL ADDRESS SEVERE
OVERDRAFT SUBSIDENCE AND GROUND
WATER QUALITY ISSUES PRESENT IN
THESE FROM JULIE GSA'S BOUNCE.
FORTUNATELY THE FRANKLIN CANAL
RUNS THROUGH AGENCY PROVIDES
PRISTINE SURFACE WATER SUPPLIES
THE MEETS DRINKING WATER NEEDS
OF OUR COMMUNITY SUCH AS TERRA
BELLA.
YOUR NATION NEEDS OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY THOUSAND
ACRES IN PROVIDE SIGNIFICANT
OPPORTUNITIES FOR GROUND
RECHARGED.
IN YEARS LIKE THIS WE CAN
ELEVATOR GROUND WATER LEVELS AND
CONJUNCTIVE LEADERSLEGALIZE
PLIES WITH AN EYE TOWARD THE
FUTURE.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S ALSO IN THESE
CAN TO ADDRESS A WITH FRANKLIN
CANALS BUCKLING DUE TO
SUBSIDENCE THREATENING THE LONG
TERM ECONOMIC VIABILITY.
AND THE DRINKING WATER LIABILITY
OF COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT THE
SOUTHERN SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AS
OUR SUPPLIES REDUCE BY UPWARDS
OF 60%.
WHILE OUR LOCAL COMMITMENT
WITHIN THE TRULY SUBBASIN IT'S
BECOME GROUNDWATER SUSTAINABLE
AND ARREST FUTURE SUBSIDENCE WE
ALSO BELIEVE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PROVIDE US
WITH A COMMITMENT TO HELP KEEP
OUR COMMUNITY SUSTAINABLE.
BY ENSURING THAT WE CAN MAINTAIN
OUR EXISTING INFRASTRUCTURE AND
HISTORICALLY AVAILABLE SURFACE
WATER SUPPLIES WITHOUT SUCH A
COMMITMENT WE FORESEE
DEVASTATING ECONOMIC IMPACTS
BEING VISIT UPON ARE ALREADY
DISADVANTAGED IN IMPOVERISHED
COMMUNITIES.
AS MANY LOSE THEIR SOURCES OF
INCOME AS A RESULT OF LAND
FOULING.
THE FUNDING GAP THAT ALREADY
EXIST FOR SOCIAL SERVICES AS A
RESULT OF LOCAL.
ARE SHRINKING LOCAL TAX REVENUES
GETS EVEN WIDER.
AND THE ALREADY PRESENT AFFECTS
OF LOS WATER SUPPLIES AND THE
OPPORTUNITY.
FURTHER DIMINISHES OUR
COMMUNITIES POTENTIAL FOR FIBER
FUTURE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY AND GAVE EACH TWO
AND A HALF MINUTES OF YOUR
OPPOSITION WILL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE OF THAT EXTRA TIME AS
WELL.
BUT OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
STEP FOUR DAME AFFILIATION
PLEASE ONLY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE LEARNED ON HATE
JACOB HOW HALF OF SOUTH VALLEY
WATER.
AUTHORITY AND CALIFORNIA CITRUS
MUTUAL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DAM ON BEHALF OF RURAL
COUNTIES ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GAIL DON'T HAVE WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
SO I GET US HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE COUNTIES OF FRESNO TULARE
AND KERN IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
M. CHOPPER CITY SINGER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHANE STRAWN CITY OF HANFORD
HERE FOR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'M KIANA SOME HAVE AQUA IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DANNY MARKLEY CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND CHAIR BY MAY CITY
PORTABLE MICHAEL REPUBLIC WORKS
DIRECTOR HERE IN SUPPORT.
MY APOLOGY SHOULD APPOINTED TO
FIRST SENIOR HERE FOR ANY
TECHNICALS TECHNICAL AND
COMMITMENTS THAT THE CITY
PORTABLE HAS IN THE DRINKING
WATER STANDARDS FOR OUR OUR
SMALL DRINKING WATER COMMUNITIES
AROUND PORTABLE THANK YOU.
ART BREANNA HANFORD CITY COUNCIL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ARE THE
WITNESSES HERE IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WOULD SOMEBODY
RELINQUISHES SEE TO THIS
GENTLEMAN MAY BE ABLE
[inaudible]
2%.
GOOD MORNING MORNING US GOOD
AFTER.
GOOD MORNING A BRAND ALSO WAS
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
VEHICLE CALIFORNIA OF
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES SB FIVE
FIVE NINE AS WRITTEN WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL WOULD UNDERCUT THE
PRINCIPAL BENEFICIARY PAYS AND
WILL OPEN UP THE STATE GENERAL
FUND. FOR REPAIRS WATER SUPPLY
PROJECTS THAT ARE FEDERALLY
OWNED AND LOCALLY MAINTAINED.
AS MANY OF YOU KNOW THE
BENEFICIARY PAYS PRINCIPLE IS
BASED ON THE CONCEPT THAT THOSE
BENEFITING FROM THE PROJECT
SHOULD FUND THE PROJECTS.
THE FRANKLIN CAN NOW USE ALMOST
ENTIRELY BY TWENTY AGRICULTURE
WATER AGENCIES WHICH
COLLECTIVELY IRRIGATE MORE THAN
EIGHT HUNDRED SEVEN NINE
THOUSAND ACRES OF FARMLAND.
WHAT WE ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THE
REBUILDING OF THE CANAL OR THE
REAR A RECONSTRUCTION OF THE COW
IT IS OUR POSITION THAT THE
SUBJECTS IN THE FRONT WATER
AUTHORITY?
SURE THE COST OF REPAIRING THE
CANAL NOT THE STATE TAXPAYERS.
MORE OVER THE QUESTION OF STATE
VERSUS FEDERAL JURISDICTION OVER
THE CANAL YOU'LL TO THE SAME
CONCLUSION.
THE FRANKLIN CANALS FAIRLY ON
PROJECT MAIN MANAGED BY THE U.
S. BUREAU OF RECLAMATION. FOR
WATER THIRTY HAS A CONTRACT WITH
RECLAMATION TO MAINTAIN THIS NOW
INCLUDING HEAVY MAINTENANCE IN
THE OF THE KIND YOU DID AND
PRESENTED TO YOU TODAY.
CURRENTLY CURRENT PRELIMINARY
ESTIMATES FOR THE FOR
RESTORATION OF THE CANAL ARE
ROUGHLY TWO MILLION DOLLARS WITH
THIS FRIEND DIVISION OF THE
CENTRAL VALLEY PROJECT AMOUNTING
TO MORE THAN MILLION ACRES WHICH
WOULD EQUATE TO MORE THAN UP
AROUND TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
ACRE.
THIS IS NOT A HEAVY BURDEN AND
WOULD ACTUALLY BE A LIGHT BURDEN
FOR THE REGION GROWING HIGH
VALUE ORCHARDS AND OTHER CROPS.
DURING THE DEBATE REGARDING
PROPOSITION THREE WEEKS HERE
BECAUSE CALIFORNIA -- ARGUED
THAT HOWEVER VIRTUES THE
RECONSTRUCTION OF A FEDERAL
CANAL IN A FEDERAL CVP DIVISION
SERVING FEDERAL WATER SERVICE
CONTRACTORS MIGHT BE.
THE RECONSTRUCTION WAS NOT THE
OBLIGATION OF STATE TAXPAYERS WE
RESURRECTED ARGUMENT TODAY.
THIS IS A FEDERALLY OWNED
FACILITY OF WHICH THE STATE HAS
HAD NO ROLE IN ITS DESIGN
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT OR
OPERATION.
NOR DOES THE STATE BEAR
RESPONSIBILITY FOR ANY OF THE
DAMAGE OF THE FACILITY.
IT IS MORE THAN REASONABLE IT IS
MORE THAN REASONABLE TO REQUEST
THAT BUREAU RECOGNITION OF FINAL
WORK TOGETHER TO RESTORE THE
FRANK CARRINGTON NOW.
IN ANY DELAY OR AVOIDANCE
UNDERTAKEN THE RECONSTRUCTION OF
THE COW UNTIL SOMEONE ELSE THE
STATE TAXPAYER PICKS UP THE TAB
CLEARLY ILLUSTRATE THAT MILLIE
ILLUSTRATES THAT IS NOT
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
TENDED TO WITH URGENCY.
WE THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BEING
WILLING TO HEAR OUR CONCERNS AND
SPEAK WITH US ABOUT THOSE
CONCERNS WE UNDERSTAND WHY
SOMEONE IN HER POSITION BRING
FORTH THIS LEGISLATION.
UNFORTUNATELY WE DISAGREE ON THE
PHILOSOPHY OF THE LEGISLATION
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
WITH THE SENATOR AND OTHER
ANOTHER SHOES BUT TODAY WE MUST
URGE YOU TO VOTE NO ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU Q. OF ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR MONNING AND
THEN CENTER BORCHERS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN.
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD ON BEHALF OF HER
DISTRICT I WOULD INVITE EITHER
THE AUTHOR OR YOUR WITNESSES IF
YOU COULD JUST RESPOND TO THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THIS YEAR
CLUB.
WHY A FEDERAL PROJECT ARE WE
SEEKING STATE GENERAL FUND MONEY?
SO I CAN ANSWER THAT QUESTION IT
REALLY IS THE THE FEDERAL
PROJECTS BENEFICIARIES WHO ARE
GOING TO PAY FOR THE FRANK KERN
CANAL.
INCLUDES GROUNDWATER RECHARGE IN
GROUND WATER IS PART OF THE
STAND WILL GROUND WATER
MANAGEMENT ACT.
AND THAT GROUNDWATER RECHARGE
GOES TO A WHOLE HOST OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES IN
OTHER VILLAGE.
THIS IS WHY THE EASTERN TRULY
GSA IS WITH US TODAY THAT TO
HELP BOLSTER BOTH THE SURFACE
WATER IN THE GROUND WATER ASPECT.
THANK YOU AND THEN.
WITH RESPECT TO THE PROPOSED
INVESTMENT OF FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION YOU REFERENCE SOME OF
THE WHOLE STRING OF EXISTING CAN
NOW ON I THINK YOU SUGGESTED
SOME PARALLEL NEW CAN NOW.
PART OF THE NEED FOR REPAIR IS
SUBSIDENCE.
HOW DO YOU?
HOW DO YOU PREVENT FURTHER
SUBSIDENCE FROM ACQUIRING
[inaudible]
FUTURE.
INVESTMENT IN REPAIR.
THAT'S AN ISSUE THAT THE TULE
SUBBASIN GSA'S TAKE VERY
SERIOUSLY I REPRESENT ONE OF
SEVEN GSA THAT OVERLIES THE TO
LISA BASIN.
AND AS A PART OF PREPARING AND
IMPLEMENTING RGS PLEASE OUR GOAL
AND OUR STATE MANDATED
COMMITMENT IS TO ENSURE THAT WE
ARREST FEATURES BESIDES LONG
FRANK OR CANAL WE ACTUALLY OF
INITIATED AN ONGOING STUDY RIGHT
NOW THAT'S INVESTIGATING.
THE PRIMARY CAUSES OF THAT
SUBSIDES AND HELPING A SCOPE AND
SIZE THE PARTICULAR AND TYPES OF
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS THAT ARE
NECESSARY TO REST FEATURES
BESIDES.
SO.
I'M NOT AN EXPERT BUT IN MY
CORRECT IN ASSUMING THAT SOME OF
THE PROMISE OF SCIENCE A
COMBINATION OF DROUGHT OVER
DRAFTING OF OF GROUNDWATER YES
AND IT GENERALLY SPEAKING IT'S A
RESULT OF GROUND WATER
OVERDRAFTS.
WE'RE INVESTIGATING WHETHER OR
NOT THAT IS A RESULT OF TO LISA
BASIN WIDE OVER DRAFTER WHETHER
OR NOT THERE ARE LOCAL FACTORS
ACHE A PUMPING IN CLOSE
PROXIMITY TO THE FRONT CURRENT
NOW.
AND ONCE WE HAVE.
NEXT THAT STUDY WE'RE HOPING
THAN TO SIZE THE APPROPRIATE
TYPES OF MANAGEMENT ACTIONS AND
PROJECTS TO ADDRESS THAT CAN
WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH THE
LOCAL AGENCIES IN FRONT WATER
AUTHORITY. TO WORK TOGETHER TO
MAKE SURE WE DON'T HAVE FUTURE
SCIENCE THANK YOU AND THEN.
I'M HAS THERE BEEN ANY EFFORT TO
SECURE FEDERAL FUNDING TO BE AT
LEAST PART OF A SOLUTION HERE
WE'VE HEARD A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AT A WASHINGTON OF INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WE HAVEN'T
SEEN ANY ACTION.
TOWARDS -- DIRECTING.
CONGRESS -- WITH THE WHITE HOUSE.
TO MOVE FORWARD ON
INFRASTRUCTURE SUPPORT ARE THERE
ANY EXISTING ALLOCATIONS THAT
COULD BE SUPPORTED BY THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE ANSWER TO THAT IS YES SO AS
PART OF THE WORLD NGUYEN ACT
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE FOR THE
NATION ACT WE'VE -- SECURED BOTH
FUNDING IN TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN AND TWO THOUSAND AND
NINETEEN THESE WERE ALL FOR PRE
CONSTRUCTION ACTIVITIES TO THE
ORDER OF ABOUT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS.
OUR OUR STAKEHOLDERS ARE
CONSTITUENCIES OF PUT UP THE
MATCH FOR THAT RIGHT NOW SO WITH
ABOUT SEVEN POINT FOUR MILLION
DOLLARS FROM THE FEDS IN ABOUT
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS FROM OUR
CONSTITUENCIES THAT'S HOW THE
INITIAL PLANNING WORK IS GETTING
DONE THANK YOU THAT CELL PHONE
NO SIR ANY.
PROSPECT OF ANY.
FURTHER FUNDING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WE CERTAINLY ARE
LOOKING AT APPROPRIATIONS AND IN
IN THE COMING YEARS YES WITH
REQUEST IN.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BOTH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU OF CENTER BOARD JUST
THAN SENATOR HUESO.
THE TEACHER WOMAN I WANTED THINK --
SENATOR -- HER TAUGHT -- FOR
BRING IN THIS -- THIS ITEM FORD
I AM PROUD TO BE A PRINCIPAL CO
AUTHOR WITH YOU ON THIS.
AND I THINK THE MERITS OF THIS
PROJECT -- FOR ANYONE WHO HAS
SPENT ANY TIME.
IN THE VALLEY -- OR IN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS WOULD
APPRECIATE AND UNDERSTAND.
THE DESPERATE NEED WE HAVE FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE -- THIS FRYING
CURRENT CANAL FUNDING IS GOING
TO TRANSFORM.
COMMUNITIES WE'VE TALKED ARM AT
GREAT LENGTH ABOUT THE NEED FOR
SAFE DRINKING WATER IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE TALKED AT LENGTH ABOUT
SURFACE WATER RELIABILITY.
AND OUR GROUNDWATER RECHARGE.
THIS IS WHAT WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT FOR DECADES.
AND THIS IS A PROJECT THAT
BRINGS IT ALL TOGETHER.
IT DOES SO ON THE MERITS.
AND I AM CERTAINLY PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS -- AND I I WOULD
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO TO DO THE SAME.
IF THERE IS FEDERAL FUNDING AND
I'M HOPEFUL THAT -- OF SOME OF
THE WISER VOICES IN WASHINGTON
IT WOULD AGREE -- THAT THIS
MERITS -- FEDERAL ALLOCATION AS
WELL -- THAT WOULD HELP WITH THE
THE COSTS.
AND IF THE COSTS GO DOWN --
DEPENDING ON THE OVERALL --
PRICE PER SQUARE FOOT.
OF A OF INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
THEN I IMAGINE THE BUDGET WILL
REFLECT THAT ACCORDINGLY -- BUT
I THINK THIS IS JUST ONE OF
THOSE MOMENTS WHERE I'M JUST
PROUD TO BE A PART.
OF HELPING THE VALLEY HELPING --
UNDERPERFORMING IN
DISENFRANCHISED COMMUNITIES I
HAVE ACCESS TO CLEAN DRINKING
WATER THIS IS A TRANSFORM AN
EVENT AND ONCE AGAIN I I
APPRECIATE -- ALL THE
CONSIDERATION MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD GIVE TO A CASTING AN AYE
VOTE.
REPORTER SAID ASSEMBLY CENTER
HUESO WAS UP NEXT.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANNA --
ALSO -- THANK SENATOR OTELLO FOR
BRINGING THIS ISSUE FORWARD THIS
IS A BIG PROBLEM.
A RUNS ALONG KIND OF THE
BACKBONE OF OUR STATE THAT MAKES
OF THE CONVEYANCE OF WATER MUCH
MORE COMPLICATED.
AND MUCH MORE COSTLY THIS IS A
BIG PROBLEM -- I'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH A SIMILAR MATTER WHERE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAS A
RESPONSIBILITY.
SALTON SEA AND THEY'VE THROWN IN
A FEW. TWO THREE MILLION -- IT'S
LIKE.
THROWING A PENNY INTO THE WELL
IN WISHING FOR MONEY.
AND THE THE STATE HAS TAKEN THE
THE THE BIGGEST ROLE IN TRYING
TO FUND THOSE IMPROVEMENTS AND
REALLY WE HAVE ALSO.
PUT UP A FEW HUNDRED MILLION. TO
A MASSIVE MULTIBILLION DOLLAR
PROJECT THIS IS A MUCH SMALLER
[inaudible]
ONE IMPORTANT.
BUT AGAIN THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HERE COMPLETELY.
WALKING AWAY FROM THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES WITH OUR
FORESTS WITH OUR WATER WAYS
EVERYTHING ELSE BUT A WALL.
THEY WANT TO BUILD A WALL AND
THEY WANT TO BUILD A FIVE POINT
SEVEN BILLION DOLLAR WALL THAT
WILL ACTUALLY TO ABSOLUTELY.
NOTHING ZERO THAT'S JUST SEEMS
TO BE THE PRIORITY WHILE
EVERYTHING ELSE IS FALLING APART
SALTON SEA NEW RIVER TIJUANA
RIVER VALLEY.
FRANK CANAL.
THEY WANT TO BUILD A WALL.
THERE WAS A HE APPOINTED -- A
WATER CZAR.
TRUMP DID TO LOOK OVER ALL THE
WATER WAYS IN THE COUNTRY AND
THERE ARE SIMILAR PROBLEMS LIKE
THIS RECROSS COUNTRY.
DEALING WITH THE MISSISSIPPI IN
THE HALL AT A HIGHER RIVER AND
IT'S IT DEALS WITH THE ABILITY
TO MOVE GOODS FROM IMPORTANT
PARTS OUR STATE INTERNATIONALLY
AND THIS PRESIDENT BASICALLY
MADE THE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT HE
WILL.
NOT BE ADDRESSING THE STATION
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS.
SO THAT'S WHAT'S WHAT WE'RE
DEALING WITH.
BUT THEY WILL BE WILL BUILDING A
WALL.
N. AND MY MESSAGE IS NOT ONLY TO
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION BUT THE
CALIFORNIANS AND THEN
CALIFORNIANS OF OF TRUMP'S PARTY.
THAT CONTINUE TO URGE.
THE PRESIDENT TO BUILD A WALL
AND SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT TO
BUILD BUILD A WALL THAT WILL DO
NOTHING TO HELP THE PEOPLE OF
THEIR COMMUNITY.
BUT IT WILL HURT.
PROJECTS LIKE THIS THAT WOULD
THEY REFUSE TO FUND THAT NEED TO
FUND THAT ARE 100% IN THEIR
JURISDICTION.
JUST BECAUSE IT'S A 100% THEIR
JURISDICTION I DON'T THINK THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD WALK
AWAY AND SAY WE'RE NOT GOING
BEFORE THE SOLUTIONS WHEN WHEN A
SPORT WILL TODAY.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME LET'S BE
CONSISTENT AND LET'S GET OUR
PRIORITIES STRAIGHT.
LET'S STAND FOR WHAT'S MOST.
URGENT AND IF YOU'RE A FISCAL
CONSERVATIVE SO SUPPORT.
GOOD FISCAL SOLUTIONS THIS IS.
ONE THAT DESERVES ATTENTION OF
OUR FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AND AND BUILDING A BORDER WALLS
WHEN THAT DOESN'T.
IT'S JUST NOT GOOD FISCAL
[inaudible]
PRUDENT [inaudible]
GOVERNMENT.
AND AND I HATE TO KIND OF
COMBINE THEM BUT HERE THIS YEAR
THERE'S BEEN A CONSISTENT
SUBJECT AND THEN THIS HEARING.
AND WE NEED REPRESENTATION AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL TO ADDRESS OUR
NEEDS AND SOMETIMES OUR NEEDS
ARE JUST PROVIDING.
CLEAN DRINKING WATER TO OUR
POPULATION.
SOMETIMES OUR NEEDS ARE KEEPING
OUR BOARD FOR IS FROM BURNING.
SOMETIMES OUR NEEDS OF PROPRIETY
WATER FOR AGRICULTURAL USE I
MEAN THESE ARE ESSENTIAL THINGS.
AND THEN LET'S LET'S BE
CONSISTENT LET'S NOT STAND FOR
SOMETHING HERE AND LET'S FIGHT
FOR IT CONSISTENTLY.
THANK YOU THERE IS SOME OF THE
SENATE JACKSON BACK TO CENTER
COPIER.
YES SIDE I TO APPRECIATE IT WITH
HOW HARD YOU'RE FIGHTING FOR
YOUR COMMUNITY.
I'M A LITTLE CONCERNED THOUGH
I'M WONDERING HAVE THERE BEEN
OTHER PROJECTS SIMILAR TO THIS
WHERE WE'VE GONE INTO THE
GENERAL FUND.
BECAUSE WHAT YOU WHAT WE USUALLY
DO IS WE BOND WHAT THE PUBLIC
VOTE.
THIS IS AN ASK OF THE GENERAL
FUND WHICH ARGUABLY IT WOULD BE
TAKING MONEY AWAY FROM OTHER
AREAS.
AND I JUST WONDER A HAVE THERE
BEEN INCIDENCES BUT WE CAN
ALWAYS THIS -- THE SORT OF THE
PROVERBIAL CAMEL'S NOSE UNDER
THE TENT TYPE OF THING IS THIS
THE FIRST OF ITS KIND WHERE WE
WOULD BE.
ASKING FOR A RATHER SUBSTANTIAL
AMOUNT -- TO ADDRESS A PROBLEM
THAT REALLY IS A FEDERAL ISSUE --
AND AND TO ARE WE ARE WE LOOKING
AT NOW WILL OPENING THAT DOOR
FOR OTHERS TO COME IN BECAUSE OF
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
FOR WHATEVER REASONS I WON'T I
WON'T ACCUSE HIM OF BEING
RIDICULOUS BUT WHATEVER REASONS
MONEY IS BEING.
RE DIRECTED -- WE FIND OURSELVES
HAVING TO DO THE JOB THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD BE DOING.
CAN SOMEBODY ANSWER THAT ARE
THERE ANY OTHER EXAMPLES OF THIS
HAVING HAPPENED PREVIOUSLY.
THE NUMBERS TO SITE.
NO THE FOUR HUNDRED MILK FOR
EXAMPLE THE FOUR HUNDRED MILLION
YOU'RE ASKING THIS COME FROM THE
GENERAL FUND IS THAT.
IS THIS A IS THIS UNIQUE A
UNIQUE ASK OR DO WE DO THIS ON
OCCASION -- FOR VARIOUS REASONS.
IF I MAY.
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS NO
PRECEDENT FOR THIS TYPE OF
ACTION AND THAT WAS ONE OF THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE USED.
TO A CAMPAIGN AGAINST PROP THREE
OF THAT THAT WAS A OBVIOUSLY
SEVEN AND FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR.
ALLOCATION FRANK KERN THAT WE
THOUGHT WAS -- FOR PRESIDENTIAL --
AND WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THIS
WILL BE A PRESIDENT AS WELL.
SO A DEAL THANK YOU ANOTHER
RESPOND AS WELL CERTAINLY.
I'M JUST LOOKING FOR NOW YEAH NO
WORRIES I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER
ISN'T IT IS COMES FROM THE
GENERAL FUND OR IF IT COMES FROM
THE DROUGHT FUNDING BUT AS PART
OF THE FRANK CURRENT CANAL PUMP
BACK PROGRAM.
WE HAVE A FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE
AGREEMENT THROUGH THE DEPARTMENT
OF WATER RESOURCES CURRENTLY.
FOR THE FRANK KERN CANAL PUMP
BACK PROJECT ON THE FRONT KERN
CANAL SO WE ARE EXISTING.
THERE IS EXISTING FUNDS BEING --
I PUT THOUGHT THAT WORD BACK AND
FORTH BUT THAT WASN'T A FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS YES
MA'AM SO REST MUCH SMALLER SO --
SO THE SO THE REALLY ISN'T A
PRECEDENT FOR THIS -- HAS THERE
BEEN ANY DISCUSSION.
ABOUT THE THE USERS WHO USUALLY
ARE.
YOU KNOW THE THE RIVER THE
REPAIR.
REPAIRS BEING DONE BY THOSE WHO
USE THE THE WATER SHOULD THE
CANALS AND SO FORTH I MEAN OR
ARE WE TALKING ABOUT SOME OF THE
BIGGER FARMERS YOU KNOW SOME OF
THE INDUSTRIAL FARMERS LIKE
ARCHER DANIELS MIDLAND WITH WHO
MAKE AN ENORMOUS AMOUNTS OF
MONEY.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA HAVE THEY%
BEEN INCLUDED IN THE ASK FOR
SOME OF THIS MONEY OR IS THIS
BASICALLY JUST AN ASK OF THE
GENERAL FUND.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE ONLY WAY
THIS PROJECT IS GOING TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IS IF WE GET STATE
FUNDING LOCAL FUNDING AND
FEDERAL FUNDING.
THAT WAS MY QUESTION MY QUESTION
IS HOW ABOUT THE USERS HOW ABOUT
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE BENEFITING
FROM.
THIS RESOURCE -- ARE THEY ARE
THEY PARTICIPATING ARE THE BIG
AGRICULTURAL INDUSTRIES WITCHER
BENEFITING SOUL FINANCIALLY ARE
THEY BEING ASKED TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS EFFORT AS WELL YES MA'AM
AND AND AND THE AXE RIGHT NOW IS
BEEN JUST FOR THE PRE
CONSTRUCTION FUNDING TO WHICH
THEY PUT FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
BOARD -- I THINK THAT.
IS THE END OF MY TERM.
QUESTION YOU ARE A LAST QUESTION --
WHAT?
IF IF WE HAD A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THERE WAS --
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS -- TO
REPAIR AND MAINTAIN AND IMPROVE
ITS INFRASTRUCTURE THE
INFRASTRUCTURE WHICH IT HAS.
RESPONSIBILITY.
IS THEIR MONEY WOULD THERE BE
MONEY AVAILABLE FROM ANY
EXISTING FEDERAL FUNDS. TO TO
COMPENSATE OR TO PAY FOR THIS
FOR THIS PROJECT.
RATHER THAN BE DEFAULTING TO THE
STATE.
MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IS
FUNDS NEED TO BE APPROPRIATED
THROUGH CONGRESS BUT THEY BUT
THEY HAVE BEEN IN THE PAST
ANOTHER -- EFFORTS SO I ASSUME
MAYBE NOT IN THIS SIZE AND AND
AND NATURE AGAIN SIMILAR SIMILAR
TO YOUR COMMENTS EARLIER -- THE
SIZE OF THIS PROJECT IS VERY
LARGE.
OKAY.
WELL I APPRECIATED.
I'M HAVING A LITTLE PROBLEM WITH
THE PRECEDENT IT SETS BUT I
UNDERSTAND THAT THERE'S A
DESPERATE NEED AND I I WOULD IT
WAS THROUGH THE CHAIR.
OF THE INVITE YOUR COMMENT
THAT'S ALL I I HEALTH IS OF A
CASE AND I WANT TO REITERATE I
THINK -- WHAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRONT WATER THIRTY STATE EARLIER
THIS HAS BEEN LOCALLY FUNDED
LOCALLY OPERATED LOCALLY
MAINTAINED?
BY FRONT WATER AUTHORITY USERS
BY THE LEADERS AND BY THE
FARMERS IN THOSE AREAS SINCE
ABOUT -- NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGACY ISSUE
SUBSIDENCE AS A RESULT OF STATE
AN ACTION THAT THE ISSUE OF
SUBSIDENCE AS A RESULT OF A
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN
THERE WAS NO SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT ACT.
AND SO THAT THE LACK OF PUBLIC
POLICY THAT PUBLIC POLICY
FAILURE HAS EFFECTIVELY
UNDERMINED THE ABILITY.
OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE LOCALLY
FINANCED AND PAID FOR THE
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE THE
REGULAR OPERATIONS AND
MAINTENANCE OF THIS AREA -- TO
TO SEE A RETURN ON THEIR
INVESTMENT AND SO IT'S AT LEAST
THE THE OPINION THE EASTERN TO
THE GSA THAT THE STATE SHOULD
PARTICIPATE IN AND COLLABORATE
WITH US AS WE WORK.
TO CREATE SUSTAINABLE GROUND
WATER MANAGEMENT THE STATE IS
ALREADY COMMITTED TO DOING SO
WITH PROPOSITION ONE FUNDS IN
PROPOSITION SIXTY FUNDS. TO WORK
TO IMPLEMENT PROJECTS IN
MANAGEMENT ACTIONS TO ARREST
FUTURE SUBSIDENCE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEGACY ISSUE.
THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH TODAY.
AS A RESULT OF THE LACK OF
AFFECTED PUBLIC POLICY THAT'S
LED TO THIS ISSUE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR CAREER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- I WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD I THINK --
IT'S REALLY DESPERATELY NEEDED
AND THE BACKGROUND ON WHAT THE
STUDIES THAT HAVE BEEN TO
DETERMINE WHAT THE SUBSIDE WHAT.
WHAT ARE THE SOLUTIONS TO THE
FIXING THE SUBSTANCE SUBSIDENCE
ISSUE -- I THINK THIS IS A
PRACTICAL SOLUTION ORIENTED BILL
AND I I AM THE QUESTION I HAVE
IS -- BUT I'D LIKE TO MOVE THE
BILL WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE BUT
HOW LONG.
THERE'S A WHOLE DEVELOPMENT
PROCESS THAT YOU HAVE TO UNDER
UNDER GO HOW LONG UNTIL YOU HAVE
PLANNING DOCUMENTS IT'LL TELL
YOU EXACTLY WHAT YOU NEED TO DO.
YEAH SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS PLANNING DOCUMENTS FOR THE
BETTER PART OF EIGHTEEN MONTHS
NOW WE THINK IT'S PROBABLY ABOUT
ANOTHER EIGHTEEN MONTHS TO WERE
FINALIZED WITH THE ENGINEERING
DESIGN AN ENVIRONMENTAL WORK
NECESSARY. TO DO A CONSTRUCTION
PROJECT WE EXPECT TO WE EXPECTED
TO BE ABLE TO DO BAD AND GO INTO
CONSTRUCTION.
IN THE FEDERAL FISCAL YEAR.
TWENTY TWENTY AND SO YOU HAVE
THE RESOURCES TO FINISH COMPLETE
THAT.
YES MA'AM YES MA'AM THOSE ARE
THE RESOURCES THAT THE LOCAL
AGENCY OUR WATER USERS OF FOOT
UP AS WELL AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU SENATE CAREER ANY
OTHER MEMBERS -- THERE'S A
MOTION.
COMPETE COMPETING MOTIONS
ACTUALLY I HEARD CENTER BOARD
JUSTANSWER COVER YOUR BUT I JUST
WANNA MAKE A COMMENT THE GUY.
THE SOCIETY THROUGHOUT THE
CENTRAL VALLEY IS A MAJOR ISSUE.
OF ALL KINDS OF CONVEYANCE
CHALLENGES WE NEED TO INVEST OUR
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE I SOME
SERIOUS CHALLENGES WITH THE
MEASURE IN TERMS OF PARITY.
TIMING RESPONSIBILITY -- LOT OF
OTHER BILL ABOUT A BILLION
DOLLARS OUTSTANDING NEED AROUND
SUBSIDENCE WRIT LARGE MATTER CAN
CONVEYANCE SYSTEMS.
TRYING TO FIND SOME WAY TO
COMPREHENSIVELY ADDRESS THAT IN
A WAY THAT.
I'M PRIORITIZE THE MOST
IMPORTANT PROJECT BUT ALSO THOSE
THAT ARE REALLY WITHIN OUR
PURVIEW.
DOESN'T RIGHT.
DOESN'T SIT RIGHT WITH ME I
GUESS TO SUBSIDIZE FEDERAL
RESPONSIBILITY -- WHILE THEY SIT
ON THEIR HANDS.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S OCCURRING IN
THE FARM BILL DO YOU GUYS HAVE
ANY IDEAS OR ANYTHING.
MOVING RIGHT NOW IN CONGRESS
THAT MIGHT HAVE.
MANY KNOWLEDGE MINUTES.
RESPONSIBILITY THERE ANYTHING
YOU'RE AWARE OF NO THEY HAVE
SOME LOW INTEREST LOANS THAT MAY
APPLY.
RIGHT AS AS THE AS THE LOCAL
SHARE NEEDS TO TO FIGURE OUT HOW
TO FUND IS PORTION RIGHT AND
SOME LOCAL LOANS.
SO YOU KNOW I I I SINCERELY
APPRECIATE YOU GOING TO FIND FOR
YOU DISTRICT CENTER TO AUTO AND
I HAVE FAMILY OUT THERE TOO SO.
SUCH AS EVEN SAID LIKE TEAPOT
DOME -- WATER DISTRICT IN HERE
SOMEWHERE AND BUNCH OF FAMILIAR --
FOLKS FROM THE PORT OF BILL AREA
BUT AS A MATTER PRESIDENT I DO
HAVE SERIOUS CONCERNS -- I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION AND SHOULD
THE BILL NEED A COURTESY VOTE
TODAY I'M PREPARED TO OFFER THAT.
BUT AS A MATTER PRESIDENT AS A
MATTER PARITY AND RESPONSIBILITY
I THINK.
SOME SERIOUS QUESTIONS REMAIN
AND I I KNOW YOU WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK HARD ON THE MEASURE
WE'VE HAD MANY CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THIS AND I KNOW THERE'S
THERE'S OPENNESS TO SOLVING MANY
PROBLEMS HERE BUT WE HAVE
ANOTHER GENERAL FUND
APPROPRIATION BEING PROPOSED RAN
CLEAN SAFE DRINKING WATER.
THINK OF A SIMILAR NUMBER FROM
THE GENERAL FUND THAT STARTS DID
ALMOST GET TOWARD TO BILLION --
THERE ARE THERE ARE -- BONDS
ACTUALLY BEING PROPOSED RIGHT
NOW AND LEGISLATURE SO THERE'S
SOME OTHER OPTIONS AS WELL --
BUT AS WE KNOW YOU KNOW WITH
PROP.
THREE THIS WAS THE THIS WAS THE
ALBATROSS SO -- I'M RETICENT TO
REVISIT IT BUT IF THE IF MY VOTE
IS NEEDED HERE TODAY I'M
PREPARED TO OFFER THAT -- SO --
I WOULD JUST ALLOW YOU TO CLOSE
WE'LL SEE WHERE WE LAND I WANT
TO LET YOU CONTINUE TO WORK THIS
PROCESS -- AND I'D APPRECIATE
WHERE YOU'RE COMING FROM SO --
WITH THAT [inaudible]
THESE QUOTES.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THE MOTION IS T PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR STERN.
JONES JONES I ALLEN FORGES.
I CABALLERO CABALLERO AYE
HERTZBERG HUESO.
JACKSON MONEY. FIVE EIGHT IN
EXPRESSING SOME OF THE SAME
CONCERNS VOICED BY THE CHAIR BUT
RECORD AN AYE VOTE TODAY.
WE NEED CLEAN SAFE DRINKING
WATER THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU.
MONIES IN EITHER BILLS ON CALL
FOR VOTES OKAY SAID GOES.
FOR OR CALL AND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANIMAL.
ALL RIGHT.
OPEN RIGHT ALONG -- THE MOST
PATIENT SENATOR FROM.
THE MAN FROM MONTEBELLO HIMSELF.
RIVERA MONTEBELLO NOT MONTEBELLO
PICO RIVERA.
FIGURE OF THERE IS.
FEARLESS CHAMPION.
A GREAT VETERAN I KNOW I KNOW
IT'S CLOSE.
MY FAVORITE BILL THE DAY WHEN IT
WELCOME CENTER [inaudible]
AND WE'RE THANK YOU.
YES THANK YOU.
THERE [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY FELLOW SENATORS AND AND I'D
LIKE TO BEGIN BY SAYING IN THANK
YOU THANK YOU -- TO THE CHAIR
AND AND THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WOULD LIKE TO START.
THIS CONVERSATION ON POSITIVE
THAT -- THE COMMITTEE IS HAS
WORKED WITH MY STAFF AND AND
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS BILL.
I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS REFLECTED IN THE
ANALYSIS.
THIS BILL SENATE BILL THREE
NINETY FIVE HAS BEEN A CENTER OF
OBVIOUSLY BENNY JOKES HERE IN
THE CAPITAL.
AND EVEN EVEN IN MY OWN HOME
DOWN.
BUT SERIOUSLY THIS GET DOWN TO
REALLY WHAT THIS BILL IS ALL
ABOUT.
THIS BILL IS DEALING DEALING
WITH VERY VERY SERIOUS ISSUES IN
A VERY SERIOUS MATTER.
EACH YEAR IT IS ESTIMATED THAT
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND DEAR ALONE
OR KILLED.
EVEN MORE ALARMING ACCORDING TO
DATA GATHERED BY THE CALIFORNIA
HIGHWAY PATROL OVERALL I SIX
YEARS APPROXIMATELY EIGHTY
THOUSAND LARGE GAME AND AT LARGE
GAME ANIMALS.
HAD COLLISIONS AT THAT RESULTS
IN OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED INJURIES.
AND AT LEAST TWENTY FOUR
FATALITIES TO MOTORISTS AND
PASSENGERS ALIKE.
THIS IS A SERIOUS ISSUE AND MORE
DATA IS NEEDED TO CREATE SAFER
CORRIDOR FOR BOTH THE MOTORIST
AND THE AND WILDLIFE.
LARGE GAME ANIMALS.
COLLISION TO AND CALIFORNIA ARE
A MULTI FACETED PROBLEM AND
CURRENTLY CALIFORNIA HAS NO --
PROGRAMMATIC AB RESPONSE TO
MITIGATE THESE OF AFFORDABLE
THREATS TO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY.
THE ISSUE IS ONCE AGAIN PUBLIC
SAFETY. FOR ONE THERE IS NO
MECHANISM TRACTOR MAP
HISTORICALLY DANGEROUS AREAS.
WE KNOW THERE ARE AREAS IN THE
STATE WERE MOTORIST AND LARGE
GAME ANIMALS SPECIFICALLY DEER
AND ELK ANIMAL.
A MORE LIKELY. TO COME INTO
CONTACT.
BUT WE DO NOT HAVE ACTIONABLE
DATA IN THIS IS THE BIG ISSUE
THIS WE CAN CHANGE.
AND WE NEED TO KNOW THE OUTCOMES
OF THAT DATA SECONDLY IN
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME SECTION
CODE TWO ZERO ZERO THREE POINT
FIVE PROHIBITS INDIVIDUALS.
FROM REMOVING ANIMALS OUT OF THE
ROADWAY BECAUSE OF THIS.
ANIMALS ARE USUALLY LEFT IN THE
ROADWAY AFTER THE COLLISION THIS
IN TURN LEADS TO SECONDARY
HAZARDS AND EVEN MORE COLLISIONS.
NOT TO MENTION THE ADDED COST OF
CALTRANS TO EVENTUALLY CLEAN UP
THE ROAD.
BY MAYOR IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
IS ALREADY IN PLACE IN MANY
STATES INCLUDING IDAHO MONTANA
OREGON WASHINGTON AND ALASKA.
SB THREE NINETY FIVE WILL
ADDRESS THESE PROBLEMS.
SENTE STATE BILL. NINETY FIVE
WILL REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE.
TO CREATE AN APP THAT WOULD
ALLOW USERS TO LOG INFORMATION
IN REGARDS TO LARGE GAME ANIMAL
COLLISIONS.
AT THE SAME TIME DELIVER PERMITS
FOR THE TAKE THESE LARGE GAMES.
THE REPORTING ASPECTS IT IS
FUNDAMENTAL. TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
ACHIEVING THE INTENT OF THIS
BILL.
THREE NINETY FIVE AND THIS BILL
AGAIN WILL PROVIDE CALTRANS AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND WILDLIFE.
AND OTHER STATE AGENCIES WITH A
MEANS OF TRACKING VEHICLE
WILDLIFE COLLISIONS SO THEY CAN
ACCESS WHERE WILDLIFE HIGHWAY
CROSSINGS ARE NEEDED. TO INCLUDE
SIGN IS LIGHTING AND ANYTHING WE
CAN DO TO MAKE THE ROADS SAFER.
THIS BILL WILL IMPROVE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND OUR HIGHWAYS SAVE
THOUSANDS OF DEER AND WILDLIFE.
FROM ROAD RELATED DEATHS IN THE
FUTURE AND PUT OTHERWISE WASTED
Là OUT -- WILDLIFE TO
APPROPRIATE USE.
FEEDING THOSE IN NEED.
WITH NO OPPOSITION ON THIS BILL.
N. THIS IS TRULY A WIN WIN BILL.
FOR THESE REASONS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR BIBLE.
A SENATOR -- WE WIN ASSISTANCE
OF YES AND I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO
ADD WITH ME THAT I HAVE SENATOR
BILL HANSEL.
WHO CARRIED THE SAME BILL IN HIS
HOME STATE OF OREGON AND DOCTOR
FRAZIER SHELLING FROM OUR OWN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
ENVIRONMENTAL SCIENCE AT?
AND AND POLICY HERE AT UC DAVIS
VERY GOOD THANK YOU SIR PLEASE
PROCEED SENATOR WELCOME.
YOUR STERN ARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
RECORD MY NAME IS BILL HANSEL.
OREGON STATE CENTER REPRESENTING
DISTRICT TWENTY NINE LOCATED IN
EASTERN OREGON.
I'M HONORED TO BE HERE TODAY
TESTIFYING ON SENATE BILL.
THREE NINETY FIVE THERE ARE AS
YOU AWARE TWO MAJOR COMPONENTS
THE SENATE BILL THREE NINETY
FIVE MY TESTIMONY WILL FOCUS ON
ONE OF THOSE COMPONENTS.
I WAS CHIEF SPONSOR OF A SUMMER
BILL SENATE BILL.
THREE SEVEN TWO IN THE TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN OREGON
LEGISLATURE WHICH WENT INTO
EFFECT ON JANUARY FIRST.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN SENATE
BILL THREE SEVENTY TWO HAS BEEN
AN ENORMOUS SUCCESS CONCERNING
THE SALVAGING OF DEER AND ELK
KILLED ON OREGON ROADWAYS.
BECAUSE MY FIRST NAME IS BILL.
WHEN SENATE BILL THREE SEVENTY
TWO WAS WORKING ITS WAY THROUGH
THE OREGON LEGISLATURE?
I WAS KNOWING KNOWN AS ROAD KILL
BILL.
IF THIS STAYED WITH ME AS I'VE
BEEN INVOLVED IN HELPING WAS
SENATE BILL.
THREE NINETY FIVE WE ALSO HAD A
NUMBER VERY CREATIVE NEWS
ARTICLES ON THE BILL SEARCHES
GRILL THE GRILL OR MEALS ON
WHEELS.
BUT BUT THE BILL WAS ABSOLUTELY
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY.
IN A PASSED OUT OF BOTH OREGON
CHAMBERS UNANIMOUSLY.
WE DID OUR HOMEWORK AND WORKED
OUT THE DIFFERENT ISSUES SUCH AS
LIABILITY SAFETY TIMELINESS DATA
COLLECTION FOR THE OREGON
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
ANTLERS ROAD RIGHT AWAY HUMANE
DISPATCH OF WOUNDED ANIMALS.
APPS FOR THE PERMIT RULES FOR
HARVESTING AND OTHER ISSUES.
SINCE THE PROGRAM BEGAN IN
JANUARY OF THIS YEAR THROUGH
MARCH TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
PERMITS A HUNDRED AND SIXTY ONE
DEER.
AND FORTY NINE NOW CAD BEEN
ISSUED AVERAGING OVER TO PERMITS
A DAY.
ALL THESE GAME ANIMALS WOULD
HAVE BEEN LEFT TO ROT ALONGSIDE
THE OREGON HIGHWAY PREVIOUSLY.
ONE VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT OF
WHAT WE DID IN OREGON WAS.
WE DIDN'T REINVENT THE WHEEL.
AS WE BEGIN OUR RESEARCH WE
DISCOVERED TWENTY STATES ALREADY
HAD PASS ROAD KILL BILLS.
THEY SPAN THE POLITICAL SPECTRUM
FROM LIBERAL VERMONT. TO
CONSERVATIVE WYOMING.
IN CRAFTING SENATE BILL THREE
SEVENTY TWO WE WERE ABLE TO LOOK
AT OUR THREE NORTHWEST NEIGHBORS
WASHINGTON IDAHO AND MONTANA.
WITHOUT APOLOGY WE INCORPORATED
MUCH OF WHAT THE STATE'S ALREADY
HAD ON THE BOOKS.
SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT SENATE BILL
THREE SEVENTY TWO YOU ARE IN
ESSENCE LOOKING AT WHAT OTHER
WESTERN STATES HAVE FOUND
SUCCESSFUL.
IT IS FOR THAT REASON I'VE FLOWN
HERE AT MY OWN EXPENSE.
MISSING TWO DAYS OF THE OREGON
LEGISLATIVE SESSION. TO TESTIFY
FOR TWO MINUTES.
BECAUSE I WANT TO BE OF HELP AS
OTHER STATES WERE TO ME.
IN CRAFTING GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
ON THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
IT IS MY BEEN MY PLEASURE AND
HONOR TO MEET WITH CENTER
ARCHULETA AND HIS STAFF.
AND ALL IN MY STAFF WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AVAILABLE AS
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY FIVE
WORKS ITS WAY THROUGH THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE HERE AND I URGE AN AYE VOTE
AND I WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU CENTER
HANSEL AND AND HOW TO RESPECT
THE AB THREE MINUTES TO MAKE.
YOU MADE YOU MADE THE TREK SOUTH.
THANK YOU SIR.
DR.
THIS AUTOMATIC YEAH YOU'RE ON A
DOCTOR PHASES SELLING UC DAVIS
DIRECTS THE ROAD APOLOGY CENTER
AND IN THAT -- CAPACITY WE
ENGAGE.
ROAD ECOLOGICAL RESEARCH RIGHT
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE WORLD --
WE ACTUALLY HAVE A ROAD KILL
MONITORING SYSTEM FOR CALIFORNIA
IT'S IN ITS TENTH YEAR AND WE
ARE THE MAJOR SUPPLIER OF THAT
KIND OF DATA TO CALTRANS
DEPARTMENT FISH AND WILDLIFE AND
OTHER CLIENTS -- SO THERE'S
ALREADY AN APP THERE THAT WE
COULD USE FOR THIS KIND OF
REPORTING -- JUST TO KEEP US ALL
ON THE SAME PAGE THE STATISTICS
THAT WERE MENTIONED EARLIER AT
LEAST TWENTY THOUSAND DEER
KILLED HERE ON CALIFORNIA
ROADWAYS THAT'S BASED ONLY ON
CLAIMS TO INSURANCE COMPANIES.
FOR THOSE WHO CAN THINK THAT
WENT THROUGH THERE A LOT OF DEER
THAT ALSO HAD THAT AREN'T
THERE'S NO CLAIM ASSOCIATED AND
IN OTHER STATES THAT CAN BE UP
TO FOUR TIMES AS MANY.
DEER OR LARGE ANIMALS ARE HIT
THAT ARE ACTUALLY REPORTED WHICH
MEANS THAT TWENTY THOUSAND IS
OUR BASE LINE AND WE CAN GO UP
TO EIGHTY THOUSAND POSSIBLE.
THAT IS NOT PART OF ANY STATE
MODELING OF DEER POPULATIONS AND
COULD BE PART OF THE REASON WHY
IN A LOT OF AREAS WE'VE SEEN
DECLINES IN THIS VERY COMMON
SPECIES.
CALTRANS PICKS UP A TOP
PROXIMALLY HUNDRED THOUSAND
CARCASSES OF MEDIUM AND LARGE
SIZE ANIMALS A YEAR FROM
CALIFORNIA STATE HIGHWAYS.
IN THE ESTIMATES FOR ROAD KILL
IN THE UNITED STATES ARE ABOUT
ONE MILLION ANIMALS PER DAY OR
HIT.
A CALIFORNIA USUALLY HAS ABOUT
10% OF EVERYTHING SO IT'S A
HUNDRED THOUSAND PER DAY.
AS WAS NOTED WE DON'T HAVE ANY
FORMAL STATE PROGRAM TO TREAT
THIS PROBLEM.
IT DOES COST US ABOUT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
IN PROPERTY DAMAGE LOSS OF
WILDLIFE INJURY AND DEATH --
JUST IN CALIFORNIA -- SO ANY
PROGRAM THAT CAN HELP US REDUCE
THIS COST IS GOING TO BE
BENEFICIAL THE PRIMARY BENEFIT I
SEE OUT OF SB THREE NINETY FIVE
IS IN THE DATA COLLECTION -- WE
ARE AS I SAID WE ARE THE PRIMARY
DATA PROVIDER FOR THE STATE.
FOR WHILE THE VEHICLE COLLISION
DATA ROAD KILL DATA.
AND WE COULD ALWAYS USE MORE OF
IT.
IN OTHER STATES FOR EXAMPLE
IDAHO WHERE THEY HAVE A VERY
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM -- AND THEIR
ROAD KILL MONITORING PROGRAM IS
MODELED AFTER HOURS -- THEY HAD
ABOUT A 25% INCREASE IN THEIR
DATA COLLECTION IN THE FIRST
YEAR -- AND THEY HAVE NOT FACED
ANY LAW ENFORCEMENT ISSUES IN
THE USE THOSE DATA TO HELP MAKE
DECISIONS -- I THINK THAT IF WE
HAD A SIMILAR KIND OF DATA
INGESTION DATA COLLECTION
PROCESS HERE -- IT WOULD GO A
LONG WAY TO HELPING MITIGATE
THIS CRITICAL IMPACT THAT AND I
SAY CRITICAL BECAUSE FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO DRIVE.
IT'S MY TO IN A MINUTE I KNOW
THAT IT'S IT'S A VERY DANGEROUS
WHEN YOU HAD A LARGE ANIMAL ON A
HIGHWAY -- BUT IT'S ALSO PREFER
CRITICAL FOR WILDLIFE IN OUR
STATE AGENCIES AND OTHER STATES
HAVE RECOGNIZED THIS IS ONE OF
THE PRIMARY SOURCES OF DEATH FOR
WILDLIFE -- IS -- BEING HIT BY
CARS THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NAME AND AFFILIATION IF YOU
COULD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF YOU DON'T MIND.
STERN WE'VE ALREADY HAD MULTIPLE
DOES MONEY IF YOU DON'T MIND
JUST KEEP IT SURE OKAY.
MY NEIGHBOR IN THE CLEVELAND I'M
A RETIRED GAME WARDEN WITH
THIRTY POINT FIVE YEARS OF
SERVICE FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
FISH AND GAME.
AND IN SISKIYOU COUNTY JUST
BRING ATTENTION TO WHAT ORGAN IS
DOING AND WHAT THE DOCTOR'S
DOING THE UC DAVIS.
OF FROM 1-988-292-2000 ELEVEN I
MONITORED AND THE SOCIAL
COORDINATOR TO SALVAGE ME
PROGRAM IN SISKIYOU COUNTY ON
HIGHWAY.
NINETY SEVEN AND IF I CAN JUST
SYNOPSIS THING. FOR TWENTY THREE
YEARS FROM 1-988-220-0011.
WE RESPONDED TO MORE THAN A
THOUSAND CALLS FROM HIGHWAY
PATROL DISPATCH.
AND OTHER REPORTS WE SHOP WHICH
SIX HUNDRED AND SEVENTY EIGHT
ANIMALS AND DELIVERED ALMOST.
THIRTY SEVEN THOUSAND POUNDS OF
PERFECTLY EDIBLE MEAT TO MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED NEEDED MEMBERS
OF MY RURAL COMMUNITY.
OF THE RECIPIENTS WERE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND PERSONS OF
SPORT WAS SPECIAL DIETARY
MEDICAL NEEDS.
I'D LIVE THIS JOB -- FOR TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR SEVEN IT WAS A
GAME WARDEN.
AND AFTER THAT THREE YEARS --
AFTER THAT. TWENTY THREE YEARS
OF OF THIS SALVAGE ME PROGRAM.
THE DEPARTMENT CUT IT OFF.
CHAU.
FROM TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN TELL
OPPRESSION.
CHP CALTRANS THEY'VE BEEN
MONITORING NEVER ONE OF THOSE
HOT SPOTS DR SHILLINGS BEEN
INVOLVED OF MOST RECENTLY BUT IT
IS BECAUSE IT IS A CRITICAL.
THING FOR US.
TO CONTINUE TO COLLECT THIS DATA.
THANK YOU SIR.
JUST SO YOU KNOW I HAVE.
BUT WE GOT WE GOT THE GIST AND
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE YES SIR.
MISTER CHAIR BILL GAINES ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL'S SPONSOR
CALIFORNIA DEAR ASSOCIATION
ROCKY MOUNTAIN ELK FOUNDATION
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER OF WILD SHEEP.
AND ALSO THE CONGRESSIONAL
SPORTS AND FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SIR BIG DAY
FOR YG.
YEAH.
HI MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARK KELLY WITH
CALIFORNIA WATER FOUND IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SHE'S BEEN HERE.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RIGHT
GRIFFITH ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA RIFLE PISTOL
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS GO TO VINE
FOR PLAN VISORS ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA FISH AND GAME WARDENS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE DATA COLLECTION ASPECTS OF
THE BILL WE DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS -- IN REGARDS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY BUT WE HAVE A TALK WITH
AUTHORS OFFICE HE'S COMMITTED TO
WORK WITH US AS WE MOVE FORWARD
SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SEEN OTHERS IN SUPPORT ANY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE COME FORWARD
[inaudible]
WELCOME.
HI JUDY MAN -- SO SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION FROM
LAGUNA BEACH THIS IS JUST BEEN
PUT ON OUR RADAR WE'RE GOING TO
BE WATCHING THIS REAL CLOSELY.
DATA COLLECTION IS A GOOD THING
BUT WE SHOULD BE PROTECTING THE
ANIMALS NOT WORRIED ABOUT
HITTING -- IN ET NAM IT SEEMS
INSANE I'M SORRY.
THANK YOU -- ANY OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
SEEING NONE [inaudible]
COMMENTS QUESTIONS [inaudible]
QUIPS AND EASE UP ON THE QUIPS
THE QUESTIONS ARE A CENTER ON
OKAY SO I GUESS MY I WAS TRYING
TO MAKE MY WAY THROUGH THE
AMENDMENT SO I CAN REALLY
UNDERSTAND -- HOW THEY
SIGNIFICANTLY CHANGE THE BILL
BUT I GUESS?
MY MY A ONLY HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS AS THE FIRST OF ALL
HOW CAN WE MAKE SURE THE BILL
DOESN'T LEAD TO POACHING.
I THINK THAT WAS AT THE HEART OF
THE GAME WARDENS CONCERNS.
YOU KNOW HAVING AB HUNTER
SHOOTING ELK IN WE INTIMATES
MENTIONS IN THE IN HOUSE IS THAT
IT'S ACTUALLY HARD TO GET THOSE
TAGS.
MAYBE THE SCENE ANIMAL THAT THEY
HAVE BEEN MEANING TO THEY WANT.
TO HI AND N. H. SHOOT IT MANY
SAY WAS A BY A CAR.
HOW DO WE MAKE SURE -- THAT
THAT'S NOT GOING TO BE HAPPENING
ON TO THIS BILL.
WELL THE CENTER DR TALKED WITH
THE GAME WARDENS AND AND I'LL
LET -- THE SENATOR TALK AS WELL.
BUT IN MY CONVERSATION WITH THEM
THEY'RE SAYING IS THAT IF AND
WHEN THE ANIMALS IS HIT.
IT IS OF OF PULLED TO THE SIDE
AND THEY CAN TELL IF IT WAS
POACHERS INVOLVED.
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THE THE
WAY THE ANIMALS HIT WAS KILLED
WHATEVER BUT DEADLY GAME WARDENS.
ARE RIGHT ON IT AND SO THEY'VE
TOLD ME THAT -- THAT IS
SOMETHING THEY'RE LOOKING AT
EVERY SINGLE DAY AND THEIR THEIR
VERY MUCH IN TUNE WHICH TAKEN
PLACE.
AND THEY KNOW THAT THIS BILL
WILL TAKE CARE OF AS SOMEONE
OPPOSED IT -- BUT WE HAVE TO
UNDERSTAND THAT THE POSSIBILITY
OF KNOWING EXACTLY WHERE THEY'RE
COMING FROM.
THE CROSSING THERE ARE HAVING
THERE IS FEDERAL MONEY AND I
DIDN'T GET A CHANCE TO MENTION
THAT BUT FOR MONEY FOR OAK
OVERPASSES SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
ANIMALS AND THIS WILL PREVENT.
ADDITIONAL -- COLLISIONS BUT AS
FAR AS THE POACHING.
THAT'S FOR THE GAME WORDS OF
COMMAND THEY'RE THEY'RE ON IT SO
THAT THEY CENTER L. IF I MAY
WHAT WE DID IN OREGON IS THAT WE
CAN FIND THE SALVAGE OPPORTUNITY.
TO THE ROAD RIGHT AWAY.
SO -- IF SOMEBODY WENT IN THE
HIGH COUNTRY AND AND KILL AN
ANIMAL OR POSTED -- AND DRUG IT
ALL THE WAY BACK TO A ROAD AND
THEN WENT ON THE APP TO GET IT --
IT SEEM LIKE A POACHERS DON'T
WANT TO HAVE THAT EXT.
MORE LIKELY JUST TO TAKE IT HOME
WE WE WORKED WITH -- THE F. AND
W. R. DEPARTMENT FISH WILDLIFE
REALIZE THAT -- YOU DO
EVERYTHING YOU CAN TO KEEP
POACHING FROM HAPPENING.
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY --
NOTHING IS GOING TO BE A FOOL
PROOF ON THAT WHAT DOES IT BUT
IT RAISES THE PROBLEM HERE.
THAT I'M.
YOU CAN GO YOU CAN CHANGE THE
ANIMAL IF IT'S HIT BY THE CAR
AND I MEAN YOU.
YOU KNOW.
BUT ONE OF MY QUESTIONS IS WHERE
WHAT HAPPENS AT THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD IS PRIVATE PROPERTY.
WHAT IF THE ANIMAL WALKS FIFTY
FEET ON THE PRIVATE PROPERTY
BEFORE FALLING?
WHICH DID YOU WANTED BLOOD
UNTRAINED UNLICENSED PERSON TO
GO OUT AND YOU KNOW.
FIRE GUN ON THAT PRIVATE
PROPERTY IN.
IN ARBIL IN OREGON YOU COULD NOT
SELL HE SAID IF -- GET OFF THE
ROAD RIGHT AWAY YOU CAN SALVAGE.
BUT IN THIS BILL IT SEEMS TO BE
STILL PERMITTED NOW.
NO THE IDEA IS THAT IF AGAIN IF
THE COLLISION HERS IN AN AT THE
ANIMAL KEEPS GOING.
THE IDEAS WITH THE APT TO RECORD
EXACTLY WHAT WOULD HAPPEN WE'RE
LOOKING FOR THE DATA. TO ENSURE
WE KNOW OR THE THE ANIMALS COME
TOGETHER AND EVENTUALLY THAT THE
ROVER PAST COULD BE BUILT THAT'S
THE IDEA.
AND AGAIN THAT FOR THE FISH
WILDLIFE THE GAME WARDENS THEY
KNOW THEY'RE THEY'RE EXPERTS AT
THIS AND IF AND IF SOMEONE POACH
THEY CAN TELL AS AN ANIMAL WAS --
BROUGHT ON TO THE ROADSIDE THEY
KNOW THAT SHOW -- EVERY
EVERYTHING BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN
LOOKED AT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
FOLLOW THE REST OF THE STATE'S
THE THINGS THAT THAT WE'RE DOING
AND THAT'S WHY.
SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'RE PUTTING INTO THE BILL TO
GO TAKE IT FURTHER DOWN THE ROAD --
HAVE ALREADY BEEN LOOKED AT JOE
AND THE OTHER THING ABOUT -- YOU
HAD MENTIONED ABOUT SHOOTING.
THE THE FACT THAT IT DOESN'T
TAKE AWAY FROM THE LOSS OF THAT
ARE ON THE BOOKS RIGHT NOW
PERTAINING TO SOMEONE.
CARRYING A HANDGUN OR CARRYING A
RIFLE WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE --
PEOPLE STILL HAVE TO BE LICENSED
TO CARRY HAND GOT.
SO THAT THAT IS NOT AN ISSUE.
GOOD DOESN'T DEVIATE FROM THAT
DATA.
OF THE LAWS THAT WE HAVE ON THE
BOOKS.
I ASKED THE CASHIER THE
COMMITTEE DID UST.
GIVE ME A SENSE OF OF HOW THE
I'M AMENDMENTS MAY HAVE ADDRESS
TO GO TO THE FIFTH AMENDMENT GO
TO PAGE TEN OF THE ANALYSIS OKAY
THIS IS WHAT SENATOR ARCHULETA I
BELIEVE WAS REFERRING
[inaudible]
TO SO.
ON PAGE FOR A MINUTE UNTIL PAGE
TEN THE NOW SYSTEM AND FIVE ALL
STATE AND LOCAL LAWS OF A AND
AND REGULATIONS APPLY WITH THE
EXCEPTION.
OF THE REQUIREMENT TO POSSESS A
VALID HUNTING LICENSE IN
APPLICABLE TAG SO IN OTHER WORDS.
A LOG -- BARRING DISCHARGE A
FIRE ARM ON THE ON A STATE ROAD --
TRESPASSING ON PRIVATE PROPERTY --
SO SO THE THE CHAIN THE REAL
SUBSTANTIVE CHANGE IN LAW THAT.
I CAN SPEAK FOR CENTER ARCHER
LETTER THE SEEKING IS THAT.
THAT HUNTING LICENSE AND TAG
REQUIREMENTS FOR ANIMALS STRUCK
ON THE ROADS -- BUT BEYOND THAT --
I DON'T THINK THAT THERE ANY
FURTHER CHANGES BEING MADE I I
WILL SAY I DO I DO SHARE YOUR
TREPIDATION ABOUT.
YOU KNOW SOME OPEN DOOR -- TO
POACHING THAT WE MIGHT NOT HAVE
ANTICIPATED HERE AND I I KNOW
WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY HARD ON
TRYING -- TO IT IS TIED UP ANY
POTENTIAL LOOPHOLES IN THIS THAT
THAT MIGHT LEAD TO THOSE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES BECAUSE
YOU KNOW.
WE DON'T WE WE WANT TO BE FULL
PROOF WITH ALL DUE RESPECT WE
THAT'S WHAT WE ENDEAVOR TO DO
HERE.
THAT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WITH THE AMEND WE'VE ADDED UP
MUCH MORE DISCRETION ALSO TO I
BELIEVE THE FISHING GAME.
COMMISSION -- TO PUT UP UP UP
PROGRAM TOGETHER THAT WOULD
DETER THAT KIND OF IMPACT BUT IF
THE CENTERS UP FOR WILL WE CAN
CONTINUE WORKING TOGETHER AND
AND MAKE SURE THAT -- THIS
DOESN'T HIT THE FLOOR IN SOME
FORM THAT'S GOING TO HAVE --
SOME OPEN BACKED OR BECAUSE I I
SHARE YOUR CONCERNS IN THAT
THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO WAIT
IN LINE BY THE WAY TO DO THIS
RIGHT THAT IT'S VERY HARD TO GET.
SOME OF THESE TAGS AND YOU KNOW
WE DON'T WANT ANY -- NO FALSE
POSITIVES BEING REPORTED BUT I
MEAN IF YOU WITH YOUR WITH YOUR
APPS IS THERE A WAY TO CAPTURE
AT LEAST.
THE IMAGE IN THE DATA SUCH THAT
YOU COULD DISTINGUISH FROM.
A ROAD KILL VERSES A GUNSHOT IS
THE IT OR IS THAT YOUR TO BE ON
THE SCOPE OF THE APPS RIGHT NOW
ABSOLUTELY AND THE FIRST
REQUIREMENT IS THAT YOU HAVE AN
IMAGE AND YOU COULD PUT IN LAW
THAT THE PART OF THE PERMIT
REQUIREMENT IS THAT IT'S AN
IDENTIFIABLE.
ANIMAL ANIMAL AND YOU CAN TELL
THAT IT WAS NOT SHOT.
I MEAN THAT'S HARD TO PROVE AND
YOU WOULD IF IN THE CASE OF AN
ELK HAVING DFW ON HAND TO CHECK
IT OUT OR HAVE SOME KIND OF
FORENSIC ANALYSIS OF IT TO MAKE
SURE IT WAS A COLLISION NOT
APPROACHING EVENT WOULD BE.
PROBABLY CRITICAL IN THE CASE OF
DEAR THOSE A VERY CALM AND AND
THAT WOULD BE A LOT OF DFW
EFFORT -- BUT SURE IMAGERY IS
THE BEST WAY TO TO DO THAT IT'S
HARD TO BE HARD TO HIDE -- THAT
NOT IMPOSSIBLE BUT AT WET IDAHO
FOUND BECAUSE THEY HAD SIMILAR
KINDS OF CONCERNS TEN YEARS AGO
WAS THAT THERE WAS NO EVIDENCE
OF POACHING OR ADDITIONAL
PROTEIN BECAUSE WE ALREADY HAVE
A LOT OF POACHING IN CALIFORNIA --
AND THEY DID NOT FIND EVIDENCE
OF PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO COVER UP
PUSHING EVENTS USING THIS.
THIS.
NEW LAW WHICH IS ESSENTIALLY
REPORTING -- AND ANYBODY WHO
REPORTS HAS TO BE IDENTIFIED
WHICH THEN KIND OF BREAKS THE
FIRST RULE OF COMMITTING A CRIME
IS THAT YOU DON'T IDENTIFY
YOURSELF.
SO YOU KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
WAYS THAT IT JUST DOESN'T LEAD
TO THAT HAPPENING AT LEAST THAT
WAS IDAHO'S FINDING OVER THE
LAST TEN YEARS.
BUT I THINK EMPIRE REPORTED TO
THIS AND YOU TALK.
TO THE IDAHO DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND GAME PERSON ABOUT THIS.
VERY GOOD OTHER QUESTIONS.
WELL I AM I GUESS I'M I'M JUST
YOU KNOW TRUSTING THAT THE TO
THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE STAFF
HAVE -- REALLY YEAH VETTED THESE
ISSUES IN OUR ARE GONNA BE
MONITORING THEM YEAH BUT AS THE
KICK OFF AS THE NOW SAYS NO TO
TO WORK IN PROGRESS SOME OF THE
FISHING GAME WARDEN CONCERNS
RAISED -- LATE NOT AS IN
OPPOSITION BUT AS SOME ISSUES TO
WORK THROUGH.
I HEAR FROM THE AUTHOR A
WILLINGNESS TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THEM.
AS WELL AS WITH THE COMMITTEE IN
MY RIGHT AND THAT IS AFTER RIGHT
MISTER CHAIR REMEMBER WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND HERE IS HOW TO
SAVE LIVES TWENTY FOUR FOR
COUNTIES.
AND YOU CAN IMAGINE A FAMILY IN
A VAN AND THEY HIT THAT ANIMAL
AND FROM WHAT I UNDERSTAND FROM
FISHING GAME INTO IN THE WARDENS
AND SO ON THAT ANIMAL WILL GO
RIGHT THROUGH THAT WINDSHIELD
AND KIDS IN THE BACKSEAT.
A DAMAGE WE'VE HAD AS I SAID
FIFTEEN HUNDRED INJURIES AND
TWENTY FOUR PEOPLE HAVE DIED AND
WE'VE WE'VE GOT TO FIND A WAY.
TO TO RECORD WHAT IS HAPPENING
WHERE THE ANIMALS ARE COMING AND
THAT'S THE IDEA.
THE THOUGHT IS IF WE GIVE PEOPLE
THIS RATE.
THEY'RE GONNA BE MORE LIKELY.
TO REMOVE THE ANIMAL FROM THE
ROAD IN.
THAT'S KIND OF THE CORE GOAL
HERE THE THE THE IDEA IS GOD
FORBID SOMETHING HAPPEN AND THEY
HIT THE ANIMAL AND AND CORRECT
ME IF I'M WRONG HERE. 99% OF THE
TIME THE AND WILL SIT IN THE
FALLS TO THE SIDE IT DOESN'T
NORMALLY STAY IN THE MIDDLE OF
THE ROAD FALL TO THE SIDE.
AND IF PEOPLE GET OUT WHEN
NORMALLY THEY SHOULD AND REPORT
THE ACCIDENT IMMEDIATELY IN A
MEETING HE GOES TO TO TO THE
HIGHWAY PATROL TO CALTRANS.
AND THE THE FISH AND GAME AND SO
IT WAS TO DO THAT THAT THAT'S
PART OF YOUR THAT'S THAT'S IT'S
IN THERE SO THAT'S THE IDEA
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE APP.
SO EVERYBODY KNOWS THAT IT'S
HAPPENED WHERE IT'S HAPPENED AND
WHEN WE HAVE THE DATA FOR THE
FUTURE AND THEN STARRED GATOR
GETTING THIS DATA TOGETHER SO WE
CAN TAKE THE NEXT COURSE OF
ACTION IS.
TO IF IT'S IT CONCENTRATED IN
ONE AREA DAN THIS IS WHERE THE
OVER PAST COULD BE BUILT.
WHEN SOMEBODY HAD JUST?
MENTIONED ABOUT THE ANIMALS
THAT'S THE WAY TO ALSO SAY THE
ANIMAL AND TO SAVE LIVES SO
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO BE
LIKE A WILDLIFE COURT THE THE
WILDLIFE TO WE'VE GOT TO BRING
OVER WHAT'LL HAPPEN.
IT IT'S THEY CREATE THIS FISHING
I'M SORRY THIS FRENCH IN THAT
KIND OF A V. SHAPE AND IT JUST
HURDLE JUMP INTO.
THE OVER PASS AND THAT THE IDEA.
SO SUCCESSFUL OF LOCATION THE
THE THE YOU WOULD SEE THE FENCES
IN A V. SHAPE AND YOU WOULD SEE
AT THE OVER PASS TO THE ANIMALS
WILL GO RIGHT OVER THE TOP.
ANOTHER WAY TO DO IT WOULD JUST
BE TO REQUIRE DRIVERS.
TO REPORT.
ANIMAL RELATED ACCIDENTS JUST
LIKE THEY WERE REQUIRED TO
REPORT.
EXCELLENT AND SOME PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY IF THE DAMAGES IS SO
SEVERE THEY'RE GONNA THEY'RE
GONNA OBVIOUSLY CALL THE HIVE
JOYS THAT MENTION AND CALTRANS
EVERYBODY ELSE THE AMBULANCES
ROLL.
THEY'LL TAKE YOUR THE THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED LIKE THE FIFTEEN
HUNDRED INJURIES IT'S HAPPENING
SO WE'VE GOT O FIND A WAY OF
RECORDING IT THIS IS THE FIRST
STEP.
AND THAT'S WHY I'M OPEN TO
AMENDMENTS AND AND AND AND
FUTURE -- CONVERSATIONS TO MAKE
IT -- A VIABLE WAY OF SAVING
LIVES IN PREVENTING INJURIES AND
WE CAN DO IT IN A IN A
SYSTEMATIC WAY.
THAT EVERYONE KNOWS THAT THEY
COULD JUST HIT THAT APP.
EVERYONE WILL KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED AND PEOPLE COULD ROLL
ON THIS THING WHICH IS I WILL
CONTROL.
AND YOU WANTED TO YES SO THE
CURRENTLY IS VERY DISCRETIONARY
I MEAN YOU COULD PUT THAT
REQUIREMENT IN BUT MOST OF THESE
INCIDENTS ARE OCCURRING WITHOUT
ANYBODY NEARBY.
AND SO REQUIRING PEOPLE TO
REPORT IS MAY BE LESS LIKELY TO
SUCCEED IN GIVING THEM AN
INCENTIVE NOT NOT TO INTERRUPT
THE DOCTOR WE DID.
PUT THAT REQUIREMENT FOR THEM TO
REPORT YES FOR ANYBODY'S REPORT
TO IT'S AN ANIMAL.
OUT THAT'S THAT'S NOW GOING TO
BE PART ITS KEEPER THE DRIVER'S
EDUCATION PROCESS OKAY.
BUT RIGHT I MEAN THAT'S THE
RIVER AND THROUGH THIS APP
PROCESS YEAH.
BUT I'VE GOT FREE REQUIRED TO
HAVE THIS APP [inaudible]
THE RIGHT SO ANY AGENCY IN OTHER
WORDS THAT I BELIEVE IT'S
AMENDMENTS.
SORRY C. THROUGH ORIGIN AND YEAH.
RIGHT SO IT'S NOT A MANDATE TO
DOWNLOAD AN APP BUT IT'S A
MANDATE FOR ANY STATE AGENCY
DOING THE REMOVAL TO DOCUMENT
THAT ON THE APP SO THE
DEPARTMENT OF RIGHT BUT IS THE
DEPARTMENT FISHING HAVE IN FISH
AND WILDLIFE RESPONSIBLE FOR
DEVELOPING THE APP.
THAN CALTRANS OR ANY OTHER STATE
AGENCY THIS TO REMOVAL REQUIRED
TO USE IT BUT AS FAR AS A
CITIZEN REQUIREMENT -- THAT IS
STILL.
SOMEBODY WHO'S I'M IT SEEMS TO
ME IF THE IF THE KEY ISSUE IS
DATA COLLECTOR SO FOR
CONSUMPTION IT'S MANDATORY IF
ANYONE CAN ACTUALLY CONSUME IT
BUT FOR THOSE WHO MAY NOT BE
CONSUMING IT THERE'S STILL A
DISCRETION AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
IT IS REPORTED.
YES THAT'S HOW THE LAW WOULD
ORK IF THIS WERE ENACTED IF WE
GOT A A MAJOR DATA COLLECTION
ISSUE SHOULD WE MAKE IT
MANDATORY.
REPORTING I'M IS A IS THAT IT
DID YOU YOU HAVE TO REPORT OF A
ANY KIND OF TRAFFIC ACCIDENT IN.
WE REQUIRE PEOPLE TO REPORT TO
PUT ON PUT ON THEIR NGUYEN
SCREAM WHEN THEY'VE.
GAINED ANOTHER CAR EVEN THOUGH
WE HAVE EVERY INCENTIVE TO NOT
DO SO BUT WE WE MAKE THAT THE
LAN WHAT MOST PEOPLE COMPLY --
IS.
IT THAT THE OTHER JEWISH
URINATED YEAH BUT THAT'S PART OF
IT THE OTHER PART IS THAT IS
WASTE -- TO HIT AN ANIMAL AND
NOT DO ANYTHING WITH IT AND ALL
OF US TAKE FOR GRANTED THE
DRIVING AROUND AND MOST OF US
HAVE HAD PROBABLY HIT SOMETHING.
IT'S THE WASTE AFTER THE FACT
YEAH IT'S A WASTED OPPORTUNITY
TO REPORT YOU KNOWN LOCATE THOSE
SO THAT WE CAN MITIGATE THE THE
IMPACT.
BUT IS ALSO YOU'VE STILL GOT A
DEAD ANIMAL YOU ARE GONNA HAVE
SECONDARY EFFECTS IS GONNA BE
SCAVENGERS THAT SHOW UP THEY
COULD ALSO GET KILLED THAT'S A
VERY COMMON THING -- SO IT'S
BOTH PREVENTING FUTURE ACCIDENTS
IS PREVENTING ACCIDENTS RIGHT
AFTERWARDS DUE TO THE SCAVENGERS --
THIS OFFER AND FAMILY MEMBERS
THIS IS I MEAN DEAR WILL HANG
OUT NEAR ONE DEAR THEY GOT
KILLED.
STAY RIGHT NEXT TO THE ROAD --
SOMETIMES ON THE ROAD THERE'S A
LOT OF BY A LOT OF I GET DOWN TO
GO WITH IT BUT SO IT'S NOT JUST
THE REPORTING IT'S ALSO THE WAY
SAYS THE ANIMALS INDICT YOU KNOW.
WE HAVE THE BETTER FOR TO YOU
KNOW FOR TO BE EATEN -- BUT I I
SO I I I I I SEE THAT YOU'RE THE
TENTS IN THE MIDEAST KIND OF
DELVING INTO SOME OF THE STUFF I
YEAH THE AUTHORS HEARING IT.
I DO THINK THERE ARE SOME.
WE WE REALLY DON'T WANT TO DO
ANYTHING THAT WOULD INCREASE
COACHING I UNDERSTAND THE DATE
IS GOOD OUT OF IDAHO BUT YOU WE
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
DON'T.
ALLOW FOR AN OPENING THERE AND I
I DO THINK THAT THIS DOES
CONTINUE TO RAISE SOME QUESTIONS
ABOUT.
I YOU KNOW WE ALL I THINK YOU
ALL IN YOUR MIND TO HAVE THIS.
CLEAN SITUATION OF OF WHERE WORD
THIS CLEARLY ON THE SIDE OF THE
ROAD NOT CLEAN.
BUT BUT YOU KNOW WHAT HAPPENS.
I IF IF YOU'RE ALLOWING PEOPLE
TO GIVE CHASE WHAT HAPPENS IF
YOU'RE ENDING UP ON PRIVATE
PROPERTY.
WHAT ABOUT TWENTY FIVE FEET OFF
OF THE ROAD I MEAN WE KNOW WHAT
WHERE DO WE WHERE WE MAKE SURE
THAT WERE?
ARE NOT OPENING UP A WHOLE BUNCH
OF PANDORA'S BOX HERE IS.
TO WELL HERE COMMITMENT TODAY TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE.
YES VENN TO ANY POTENTIAL BACK
DOORS ON POACHING.
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO PUSH
MORE DETAILS IN THE DEPARTMENT
ABOUT HOW THE MECHANICS IS
SHOULD ACTUALLY WORK.
AND I WOULD ENTERTAIN A MOTION
FROM SENATOR MONEY -- LASTLY I
WOULD JUST SAY.
THE THE BROADER POINT YOU MADE
ABOUT WILDLIFE CORRIDORS BE AN
IMPORTANT PART OF PREVENTION IS
CRITICAL SO WE'RE LOOKING FOR TO
PARTNERING WITH YOU NOT JUST ON
DEALING WITH THINGS AFTER THE
BAD.
AT THE ACCIDENT HAPPENS WHICH WE
WANT TO PREVENT MORE OF BUT
UNTIL THAT ROOT CAUSE TO IN
HELPING GET THESE WILDLIFE.
OUT OF OUR ROADWAYS IN INTO SAFE.
I'D SAY FOR LIFE SO THERE'S A
MOTION -- I'VE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED.
TO APPROPRIATIONS ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE SENATOR.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AS I MENTIONED WILL CONTINUE
WORKING AND BECAUSE OF THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THIS BILL I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I BOUGHT.
THIS CALL THE ROLL CENTERS STERN
STERN HI JONES ALLEN ALLEN HI
BURGESS.
CABALLERO.
HI HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONNING.
MONEY HI.
A VERY GOOD WE WILL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL IT AS FIVE VOTES --
EVEN PATIENTS SENATOR UMBERG
YOU'RE GOOD CENTER ARCHULETA
THANK YOU BOTH DOCTOR AND
SENATOR FOR MAKING A LONG TRIP
SAY HEY.
TO CENTER BUYER FOR ME -- AND DO
APPRECIATE THE TRIP WENT TRY TO
SQUEEZE THIS IN BEFORE CAUCUS A
OKAY -- MAYBE WE CAN EVEN.
MAYBE IF WE GET LUCKY CENTER
GLAZER IN SOME -- A TREE.
I DON'T THINK WE'LL BE LEVEL I
WILL TRY TO LIMIT WITNESSES.
TO THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REAL.
I HAVE A BILL THAT HELPS
CALIFORNIA CREATED INTEGRATED AT
LEAST -- PLANNED TO ADDRESS.
CLIMATE CHANGE WITH RESPECT TO
RISING SEA LEVELS OCEAN S. OF
EDUCATION AND THE CHANGING OF
CALIFORNIA'S COASTALECOSYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA'S CODE OCEAN ECONOMY
IS GENERATING FORTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
WE AS CALIFORNIANS NEED TO AT
LEAST BEGIN TO ADDRESS IN A
UNIFIED COHERENT WAY THE ISSUE
OF COASTAL EROSION -- I HAVE
WITH ME TODAY AS WITH THIS IS
GEORGE LETTER CHIEF SCIENTIST
OCEAN CONSERVANCY AND JIM.
EDGAR MEYER DIRECTOR OF THE
OFFICE OF SUSTAINABILITY FOR THE
COUNTY OF SAN MATTEO -- AND JUST
TO CLARIFY AMENDMENTS ACCEPTABLE
FOR YES OKAY VERY GOOD -- IF
YOU'RE WILLING TO BE SOMEWHAT
TRUNCATED KNOW YOU'VE COME A
LONG WAYS BUT WE WE APPRECIATE
YOUR TESTIMONY.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN -- STERN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I CAN BE
VERY SHORT AND JUST SAY WE FULLY
SUPPORT THE BILL OR I CAN GIVE
YOU A LITTLE MORE.
SPECIFICITY AHMED ME TWENTY
SECONDS.
PASSION TWENTY SECOND SO CLIMATE
CHANGE IS REAL IT'S CRITICAL --
KNOWLEDGE EXCHANGE AND KNOWLEDGE
GENERATION.
IS GOING TO BE REALLY CRITICAL
OF THIS WE HAVE TO STAY OUT
AHEAD OF THE SCIENCE AND HOW.
QUICKLY THIS IS MOVING AND WE
THINK THAT THE STRUCTURES IN
THIS BILL HELP US DO THAT VERY
GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JAMAICA MYRON THE DIRECTOR WITH
THE OFFICE OF SUSTAINABILITY WAS
SAN MATTEO COUNTY HAVE THREE
MAIN POINTS TO SHARE WITH YOU
THE THIS AFTERNOON.
FIRST -- SEVENTY COUNTY IS
ESPECIALLY VULNERABLE TO CLIMATE
CHANGE IMPACTS INCLUDING SEA
LEVEL RISE EXTREME PARTICIPATION
HE'D WILDFIRE WITH REGARDS TO
SEA LEVEL RISE THE COUNTY IS
OVER ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
AT RISK FROM THREE FEET OF SEA
LEVEL RISE.
MAJOR INFRASTRUCTURE SUCH AS
HIGHWAY ONE A ONE CALTRAIN BART
SFO ENERGY DISTRIBUTION LINES IN
WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANTS ARE
ALSO VULNERABLE.
WE ALSO HAVE MANY LOW LYING
COMMUNITIES AT RISK ON THE BAY
SHORE FROM FLOODING A BLUFF TOP
COMMUNITIES AT RISK FROM EROSION.
ON THE CSIDE.
SECOND POINT INFORMATION
PLANNING AND DESIGN NEEDS AT
CEMETERY -- COUNTY WE NEED THE
BEST AND THE MOST UP TO DATE
CLIMATE SCIENCE.
AROUND SEA LEVEL RISE THE
CLIMATE CHANGE ESPECIALLY AROUND
PLANNING AND PROJECT DESIGN.
THIS IS TRUE FOR MANY CALLS TO
COMMUNITIES THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA THE PACIFIC RIM IS
THE MOST IMPORTANT FOR
INFORMATION BE CONSISTENT
THROUGHOUT THE REGION.
THIRD POINT YES.
THE CONSERVANCY HAS BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN OUR WORK ON
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN WE RECEIVED A
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
GRANT FROM THE CONSERVANCY TO
COMPLETE A SEA LEVEL RISE
VULNERABILITY ASSESSMENT. FOR
THE COUNTY.
IN ADDITION TO THE FUNDING THE
CULTURE CONSERVANCY PROVIDED
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE CONNECTED
US TO OTHERS IN THE REGION DOING
SOME MORE WORK.
THEY CONTINUED TO PROVIDE KEY
COORDINATION SUPPORT THROUGHOUT
THE REGION.
A GOOD THEY ARE PERFECT ENTITY
TO BE THE MANAGING THE COASTAL
CLIMATE CHANGE ADAPTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND READINESS
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN FOR YOUR
TIME THIS AFTERNOON.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS READ AT US ON
BEHALF OF SAVE THE REDWOODS
LEAGUE IN SUPPORT THANKS SO MUCH.
SUTHERLAND SALAS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
NATALIE KNOCKED ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT IN SUPPORT
THANKS SO MUCH.
AND ALSO HAS HERE COME IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
RESTRICTED TO HEAL THE BAY IN
THE CLAIMS HE'S LOVING COALITION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY OTHERS
IN SUPPORT SEEING NONE ANY IN
OPPOSITION SEEING NONE BRING IT
BACK TO THE DíAS MEMBERS.
MOTION FROM SENATOR HUESO.
GREAT BILL REGIONAL VOTE.
ALL THE ROLE THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SOME JUST STERN
HI STERN I'D JONES ALLEN.
FORGES CABALLERO CAREER HIGH
HERTZBERG HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY IN MONEY
AND I THE BILL HAS FOR ITS OKAY
FOR GOODS WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL AND THANK YOU SANDBURG AND
THANK YOU FOR YOUR INDULGENCE.
OR LACK THERE OF THERE GLAZER.
YOU'RE GOOD YOU'RE GOOD THANK
YOU SIR YEAH.
THANK YOU THAT -- MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS I DO OF WITNESSES THAT
HAD TO LEAVE SO I APPRECIATE THE
COURTESY VERY GOOD BOTH SIDES
AGREED TO BE BRIEF.
THEY ANALYSIS BY YOUR STAFF WAS
TERRIFIC RIGHT ON POINT AND FLOW
AND FULLY COMPREHENSIVE.
THIS BILL HAS AN OPTIONAL SALE
OF UP A PARCEL IN MY DISTRICT
IT'S AN OPTIONAL SALE.
THAT'S THE KEY PART THERE.
IT'S AN ISSUE THE COMMITTEE
HEARD LAST YEAR AND PASSED OUT
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER FOR THE
QUESTIONS AS THEY COME UP I HAVE
ONE WITNESS IN FAVOR.
YES BRAIN AND ALSO SEE A
CALIFORNIA WE STRONGLY SUPPORT --
SB SEVEN SIX SEVEN BUT WE
BELIEVE THAT THE GEOGRAPHY
ENVIRONMENT OF TESLA PARK WHICH
IS THE BILL SUBJECT.
CULTIVATES A HABITAT THE WE
BELIEVE IT'S VITAL TO CALIFORNIA --
IN THIS BILL TO RESOLVE A LONG
STANDING CONTROVERSY IN A MANNER
THAT IS BOTH LIES FOR THE PUBLIC
AND ENVIRONMENT AND FAIR TO
STATE PARKS AND PARTS PARTS
DEPARTMENT AS WELL AS HVR
DIVISION -- SO WITH THAT WE
SUPPORT AND STRONGLY OR DRIVE
THE SUPPORT.
HE SAID ELEVEN SALAS WITH ANY
COULD NATURE CONSERVANCY AND
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THANK YOU.
YOU.
OTHERS.
TRY TO RESCUE ALONG HERE.
YOU GUYS CAN LINE UP THOUGH IF
YOU WANT TO Q. HOWEVER THE
SERGEANTS ONE SHEET.
RODRIGUE FRIENDS ATTESA PARK.
A FOR URGE YOU TO SUPPORT TO SAY
HAVE YOU.
SIX SEVEN DAVID HAMMER ON BEHALF
OF THE SPRAWLED F.
SUSTAINABILITY.
PARKS RECYCLING AND WILDLIFE
LEGAL DEFENSE FUND SUPPORTING
SENATOR GLAZERS BILL.
THANK YOU SIR.
TELL ME HOW I FEEL ON BEHALF OF
THE CASTLE ROAD RESIDENTS
ALLIANCE AND TRY FELLOW TRAIL
BLAZERS AND A QUESTION GROUP.
THANK YOU MA'AM.
CHARLIE MENTAL NOT ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF THE ARROYOS AND I
URGE YOUR SUPPORT BUT YES.
MARK PROJECT SU LIVERMORE --
DON'T JOBLO AUDUBON SOCIETY.
TAMERA ROYCE ON BEHALF OF
FRIENDS OF OPEN SPACE AND
VINEYARDS AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANKS.
YES THEY CRY AND I'M
REPRESENTING FRIENDS OF
LIVERMORE IN THE LIVER MORE KILL
HIKERS AND WE ARE.
FERRIES GLAD TO HAVE THE SENATOR
GLAZERS -- SUPPORT OF THIS.
TOPIC SO WE URGE YOU.
TO AS A LONG THANK YOU.
WILL BOLTON FROM THE LIVE MY
HERITAGE GUILD SPORTY -- THE
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI CORN FROM HAYWARD
REPRESENTING ALONI AUDUBON
SOCIETY WHICH IS SOUTHERN AND
EASTERN ALAMEDA COUNTY WEIRD
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
AND PHIL GORDON.
ARE REPRESENTING ON BEHALF OF
THE CITIZENS OF TO CITIZENS TO
COMPLETE THE REFUGE AND APART.
SEVEN SIX SEVEN PLEASE PASS THIS
THANKS FOR MAKING A TRIP. ONE
PROBLEM ELEVONS REPRESENTING TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS OF SAY AMOUNT
DOUBLE PLEASE SUPPORT OUR GOOD
THANK YOU.
I JENNIFER SPENCE REPRESENTING
SITE SOCIETY OF AMERICAN INDIANS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN
SIX SEVEN THANK THANK YOU MA'AM.
DOORS BURKE OF THE CALIFORNIA
NATIVE PLANT SOCIETY AND ALSO
TODAY FOR THE CALIFORNIA NATIVE
GRASSLAND SOCIETY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CELESTE GARAMENDI
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
GREENBELT ALLIANCE AND THE
REGIONAL PARK ASSOCIATION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN SIX
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST I THOUGHT I
THINK SOMEONE JUST SPOKE ON MY
BEHALF I DUG HOUSTON REPRESENTED
THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
REALLY CONSTRUCTIVE OPTION. TO
PROJECT THAT HAS BEEN EMBROILED
IN IN DECADES OF CONTROVERSY IN
THE TO SEE THIS BILL BEFORE.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
THE SCENE NO OTHERS IN SUPPOT.
IS THAT RIGHT NORTHERN SUPPORT
ANY OPPOSITION.
OR TRAINERS.
ARE WELCOME.
OKAY MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TERRY MAKAYLA
THERE AND READ NECESSITY THAT'S
REPRESENTING A CONSORTIUM OF OFF
HIGHWAY VEHICLE RECREATION STE.
WE OPPOSE THIS BILL A VERY
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR.
PERHAPS A LITTLE MORE RESOLUTELY
THAN I INTENDED.
I THINK THAT -- WE'RE OPPOSED TO
THIS BILL FOR THREE REASONS ONE
IS THAT IT CREATES A NEW LEVEL.
OF SCRUTINY BY.
STATE PARKS WHICH COULD IMPACT
ANY KIND OF LAND PURCHASES THAT
THEY HAVE. TO THAT THE BILL IS
REALLY ONLY HALF WRITTEN.
IT GIVES A PRESCRIPTION AS TO
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN IF THE
DEPARTMENT DOES THIS -- HEARING
THAT THEY SHOULD SELL THE
PROPERTY AND WHAT THE PROPERTY
COULD BE SOLD.
FOR HAVING SAID ALL OF THAT.
I THINK THAT THE SENATORS A VERY
CONSCIENTIOUS AND PRAGMATIC
PERSON.
AND IF WE DON'T DO SOMETHING WE
ARE GOING TO HEAR THIS BILL
EVERY SINGLE YEAR UNTIL I DIE.
ND SO.
MY SUGGESTION AND THIS IS A
SUGGESTION AND I I RAN IT BY.
MISTER CRAVEN JUST BRIEFLY.
IS THE IDEA THAT WE DO SOMETHING
WE'RE BOTH PARTIES HAVE SKIN IN
THE GAME.
CLEARLY [inaudible]
PARKS.
I WAS VERY CAREFUL IN SETTING
THIS PARK ASIDE THERE WERE THE
PUBLIC HEARINGS THERE'S A
HISTORY OF MOTORCYCLE RIDING
HERE.
THERE'S A NECESSITY FOR A PARK
IN THIS AREA.
HOWEVER IF THEY DIDN'T DO
EVERYTHING AS THEY WERE SUPPOSED.
TO MY SUGGESTION IS.
IT HAS NO VESTED INTEREST IN
THIS.
IF WE DO IT WITH PARKS WHICH IS
KIND OF THE SAME HEARINGS OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET ANYWHERE.
AN ARBITRATOR TO LOOK AT AT WHAT
HAS HAPPENED IN TERMS OF PUTTING
THIS PROJECT TOGETHER.
IF THEY DECIDE THAT PARKS DID
EVERYTHING CORRECTLY THAT THERE
IS A NEED.
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE
NEARBY EITHER SIGNED OFF OR WERE
GIVEN EASEMENTS IN THE PROCESS
IN THE PROCESS.
OF THE PROJECT GOES FORWARD.
IF IT TURNS OUT THAT IT IS NEVER
GOING TO HAPPEN AND THAT THERE
ARE REASONS ENVIRONMENTAL OR FOR
WHATEVER BUT IT'S NOT GOING TO
HAPPEN.
THEN THE PROPERTY SHOULD BE SOLD.
THEN IT SHOULD BE SOLD AT THE
PRICE BUT IT'S WORTH RIGHT NOW
WE WOULDN'T WANT TO GET ANYBODY
INTO TROUBLE BY MAKING THIS A
GIFT OF PROPERTY FROM THE STATE
SO WE COULD.
GET UP AN APPROPRIATE PRICE AND
AND GET RID OF IT THAT WAY.
I WILL CLOSE JUST BY SAYING THIS
I WANTED TO CONGRATULATE THE
COMMITTEE SECRETARY AND WELCOME
HER INTO THE WINDOW THE
GRANDMOTHER RANKS.
AND THERE'S A NEW GRANDFATHER
ACTUALLY TELL YOU IT'S IT'S THE
GREATEST AND IT'S IT IS THE BEST
JOB IN THE WORLD SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN FOR A WHEN
WE SPEAK THANK YOU.
DIANA MEAD WITH CALIFORNIA OFF
ROAD VEHICLE ASSOCIATION.
SENATORS AND STAFF OF THE
NATURAL RESOURCES AND WATER
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
AND THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME
THIS MOMENT IN TIME TO TALK WITH
YOU ABOUT SB.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN I AM A PROUD
DEMOCRAT.
I SERVE ON THE BOARD OF A
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION.
AND I ADVOCATE FOR ACCESS -- FOR
A TO BE RECREATION.
SENATOR GLAZER IS MY SENATOR.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN IS VERY
SIMILAR TO LAST YEAR'S SB
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN A BILL I ALSO
OPPOSED.
ONCE AGAIN.
OUR LEGISLATIVE RESOURCES ARE
BEING USED. TO INTERCEDE IN A
LOCAL ISSUE.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN ATTEMPTS TO
CREATE AN AVENUE FOR THE SALE OF
A PARTICULAR PARCEL OF STATE
PARKS OWN PROPERTY.
IT ALSO SINGLES OUT.
A PARTICULAR RECREATION AND
THOSE WHO ENJOY IT.
OFF HIGHWAY MOTORIZED RECREATION.
WHEN ASKED WHY HE INTRODUCED
THIRTEEN SIXTEEN MY SENATOR
VOLUNTEERED?
THE PROPERTY WILL NEVER HAVE A
WAY TO BE.
THE LAWSUITS WILL KEEP COMING.
AND THEY'RE COSTLY WE CAN'T
AFFORD THIS.
WELL THOSE ARE NOT HIS EXACT
WORDS THAT IS THE GIST.
NOW ALL LAWMAKERS RECOGNIZE THE
LAWSUITS ARE AN UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCE OF SYKORA.
WHAT MY SENATOR IS NOT
UNDERSTANDING?
IS MANY OF THE GROUPS TO SUPPORT
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN WILL NOT
STOP ATTACKING O. H. B. IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD.
IF THIS PROPERTY IS SOLD.
THERE'S A LENGTHY DOCUMENTED
HISTORY OF EFFORTS TO SHUT DOWN
CARNEGIE AS WE ARE A SB SEVEN
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
SALE OF PROPERTY PURCHASED OVER
TWENTY YEARS AGO.
THE PURPOSE OF THIS PURCHASE WAS
FOR EXPANDING CARNEGIE S. V. R.
A..
ENHANCING BOTH MOTOR I IS AN END
NON MOTORIZED RECREATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES IN THIS PARK.
THIS PURCHASE WAS NOT A SECRET.
ADJACENT LANDOWNERS WERE THE
BENEFICIARIES OF DISCLOSURE.
OF COURSE THE BILL WILL NOT
FORCE THE STATE PARKS TO SELL
THE PROPERTY [inaudible]
BUT SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
UNDERMINES THE STATE PARKS.
AND THE LEVEL OF STEWARDSHIP
THIS DEPARTMENT BRINGS TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS.
STATE PARKS ARE REQUIRED TO MEET
A HIGHER STANDARD THAN REGIONAL
COUNTY OR CITY PARKS.
SB.
TWO FORTY NINE THE OFF HIGHWAY
MOTOR VEHICLE RECREATION BILL
PASSED INTO LAW IN THE FALL OF
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN DEFINES
REQUIREMENTS FOR S. V. R. A.'S
TO MEET EVEN MORE RIGOROUS
ENVIRONMENTAL STANDARDS.
INCLUDING THOSE APPLIED TO
HABITAT.
AND SOIL EROSION [inaudible]
SO.
SB.
SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN POSES TO SAVE
THIS PARCEL.
FROM THE VERY DIVISION OF STATE
PARKS THAT WILL OFFER THE
GREATEST.
PROTECTION [inaudible]
IRONIC. TO DATE STATE PARKS IS
INVESTED SIGNIFICANT DOLLARS TO
MITIGATE IMPROVE AND PROTECT THE
EXPANSION PROPERTY.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN DOES NOT
CREDIT STATE PARKS FOR THE
TWENTY YEARS OF LAND PREPARATION
FOR PUBLIC USE.
SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN DOES NOT
INDICATE.
THAT A FUTURE OWNER WILL EVEN
ALLOW PUBLIC ACCESS.
BUT IF THEY DO.
MONEY WILL NEED TO BE MITIGATED
NEED TO BE A ALLOCATED FOR
MITIGATION ON AN EARLY NINETEEN
HUNDREDS MINING OPERATION.
IF THEY DON'T PLAN FOR PUBLIC
ACCESS OR FIND THEY CAN'T AFFORD
IT.
AND INSTEAD PLACE THE PROPERTY
INTO CONSERVATOSHIP.
ALLOWING GRAZING PERHAPS THERE
ARE NO REQUIRED PROTECTIONS FOR
NATURAL AND CULTURAL RESOURCES
AS MANDATED BY STATE PARKS.
IGN'S HERE TO WRAP UP WHEN YOU
GET HERE OKAY THANKS AND OUR
LOCAL COMMUNITY WILL HAVE LOST
ACCESS FOR MANY.
WELL THE SUPPORTERS OF SB SEVEN
SIX SEVEN AN ISSUE OF LOCAL
CONCERN IS TAKEN ON THE PROFILE
OF PRECEDENT SETTING STATEWIDE
BILL.
IT COULD BE YOUR PARK.
AND THEY WILL HAVE PRESIDENT
NEXT TIME NOT JUST THE OPTIONS
ONE LINE.
THIS PARTICULAR OFF ROADER URGES
YOU NOT TO ENDORSE EVEN AS A
COURTESY A DEVICE OF LOCAL
MATTER WITH ROOTS IN THEM BE ISM.
VERY OBVIOUS BIAS AGAINST -- HV.
SHOULD NOT CARRY THE DAY.
ALLOW SB TWO FORTY NINE TO WORK
AS THIS BODY LEGISLATED IN
APPROVED.
LESS THAN TWO YEARS AGO.
RESPECT AND SUPPORT STATE PARKS.
IN PERFORMING THE JOB WE HAVE
ENTRUSTED THEM TO DO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MA'AM.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION GOOD
AFTERNOON SENATORS HARD THIS
AFTERNOON GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
STERN MEMBERS COMMITTEE CAPULETS
REPRESENTING THE OFF ROAD
VEHICLE LEGISLATIVE POLLUTION
IT'S A STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION
WERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU.
IN ORDER FOR MODESTO RUN ABOUT
SCORE RIVER IN THE EAST BAY HIGH
TAYLOR'S OPPOSE.
YES SIR THANK YOU.
REPRESENTATIVE OF ELEVATOR
ACTION SPORTS OURS HE TIRED YOU
CAN AND THE THOUSANDS OF OFFERS
ENJOY CARNEGIE SB ARE A EVERY
SINGLE WEEKEND.
YOUNG FAMILIES SENATORS STEVE
GLAZER IS MY LOCAL SENATOR SO --
I OPPOSE IT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M CAN CLARK I LIVE IN
CASTRO VALLEY CALIFORNIA.
I AM ALSO PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA OFF OF ROAD VEHICLE
ASSOCIATION PRESIDENT OF THE
WANDERING WHEELERS CHEAP CLUB OF
HEY WORK THIS IS A LOCAL ISSUE
AND DEJA VU HERE WE ARE AGAIN.
MISTER ALAN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND THANK ALL OF YOU FOR PASSING
SB. TWO FORTY NINE WHICH MADE
THIS A STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL.
JOB I OPPOSE THANK IF YOU'RE.
I SEE NO THERE'S AN OPPOSITION
WILL BRING IT BACK TO THE DíAS
COMMENTS QUESTIONS.
CONCERNS CENTER CARRIER.
YEAH I GUESS I'M I'M JUST
CONCERNED WITH THEM.
I AND I KNOW SENATOR GLACIER AND
I KNOW -- DBM PRETTY REASONABLE
AND PRAGMATIC TYPE OF PERSON --
AS THE AS WAS STATED -- BUT THIS
IS A A LOCAL ISSUE AND IT
DISTURBS ME TO HAVE.
TO DO THE PROVERBIAL SOLOMON
SPLITTING UP THE BABY -- DON'T
MIND TAKING TOUGH VOTES I JUST --
I'M JUST NOT SURE IT MAKES SENSE.
TO TAKE RESOURCES.
THAT WERE GENERATED BY -- ONE
ACTIVITY.
ALLOW THEM TO MAKE THE PURCHASE
[inaudible]
AND THEN.
NUMBER OF YEARS DOWN THE ROAD
DECIDE THAT.
THAT PURCHASE WAS.
NOT IN THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AFTER THE FACT AND THEN.
TAKE AWAY THAT RESOURCE SO I'M
I'M WONDERING IF YOU CAN ADDRESS
ALL OF THEM I'M LOOKING FOR A
COMPROMISE I GUESS IS WHAT IT
AMOUNTS TO AND I'M NOT SURE
THERE'S ONE TODAY.
BUT BUT I AM CONCERNED.
THE CHAIR.
THANK YOU SENATOR FOR YEARS YOUR
QUESTION.
FIRST TO BE CLEAR NOTHING IN
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE LAND TO
BE SOLD.
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS AND
RECREATION IS GOING TO THE
PROCESS OF TRYING TO A BILL TO
AN EXTENSION OF AN EXISTING OFF
HIGHWAY THAT OUGHT THAT EXISTING
OFF HIGHWAY.
CONTINUES ON NO MATTER WHAT THIS
BILL THAT HAPPENS OR DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
THERE'S AN AREA VAST AREA THAT
HAS THIS ACTIVITY AND THIS
DOESN'T AFFECT IT ONCE
WHATSOEVER ALL THIS SAYS IS THAT
THE ADDITIONAL EXPANSION THAT
THEY ACQUIRED.
IF THEY DECIDE THAT IT'S IN THE
INTEREST OF THE STATE AND OF THE
OFF ROADERS TO SAY THAT WE'VE
HAD ENOUGH IT'S IT'S GOING TO BE
IN LITIGATION FOREVER.
THIS GIVES THEM THE OPTION TO
SELL AND GET ALL THE MONEY BACK
INTO THE OFF ROAD FUND.
RIGHT BACK INTO THE OFFERED SO
THEY CAN FIND OTHER USES OF IT
THAT CAN A EXPAND THAT ACTIVITY
IN OTHER PLACES -- THAT THEY
DEEM FIT THAT'S ALL IT REALLY
DOES CREATES AN OPTION STATE
PARKS DEPARTMENT SAID WE CAN'T
DO THAT AS AN OPTION UNLESS YOU
PASS THIS BILL THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS HERE.
WAS NOT MEANT TO SAY YOU LOVE IT
OR YOU HATE IT YOU LIKE THIS
LOCATION YOU DOWN IT GIVES THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
OF PARKS AND OPTION THEY DON'T
HAVE TODAY THAT'S ALL REALLY
DOES.
THERE WAS A RECOMMENDATION OF
FINDING AN NEUTRAL THIRD PARTY.
MEDIATOR ARBITRATOR HAVE CERNEY
CURRENCY TO THAT IDEA.
I HAD NOT HEARD THE SPECIFICS OF
THAT IDEA UNTIL TODAY I'M AYE.
AS I AM ON ANY ANY PIECE OF
LEGISLATION ALWAYS OPEN TO FIND
COMMON GROUND.
AS A CERTAINLY WOULD WELCOME I
THE CONVERSATION TO CONTINUE ON
THAT SUBJECT BUT I GUESS THE
QUESTION IF THERE WERE AN
ARBITRATION [inaudible]
THE REACH SUPPORT FOR THE IDEA
THE BILL PROPOSES IT MIGHT STILL
TAKE.
THE LEGISLATION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT AN ARBITRATOR
CONVINCE THE POWER IN DEPARTMENT
OF PARKS.
NOT THAT I'M AWARE OF AT PARKS
EVEN IF PARKS WANTED TO SELL
TODAY AND THAT WAS THE CHOICE OF
AN ARBITRATOR OR ANY -- ANYBODY
ELSE INCLUDING THE COMMISSION --
THEY WOULDN'T HAVE THE POWER TO
DO IT UNDER THE ADVICE FROM THE
PARKS DEPARTMENT THIS SIMPLY
GIVES IN THAT CHOICE.
YOU COULD HAVE THIS BILL ENACTED
AND THEY COULD ALSO IN A BRING
AND OTHER THIRD PARTIES TO KIND
OF WORK OUT THE CONCERNS AND
PROBLEMS IN THAT.
THAT'S THAT WOULD ALL BE GOOD
THIS BILL WOULD AFFECT THAT IN
ANY WAY IT WOULD SIMPLY GIVE
THEM THE IN AN OPTION IF THEY
CHOSE TO GO.
IN THE DIRECTION TRYING TO GET
THE MONEY BACK.
THANK YOU AN ARM I AM TO BE
SUPPOTIVE TODAY BUT I WOULD
ENCOURAGE EXPLORATION OF THAT
PATH FOR THE LOCAL.
ENGAGEMENT OF STAKEHOLDERS
THANKS VERY GOOD.
THANK YOU -- OTHERS THE PRO TEM
IS ALSO NOTIFIED US THAT WE NEED
TO RECESS IMMEDIATELY HERE SO --
ANY FURTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS SENATE JACKSON.
SO I JUST -- I I AGREE I'D LIKE
TO HEAR MORE.
HI THIS IS WHAT IS IT LIKE --
GROUNDHOG DAY.
SO MAYBE WE CAN.
WORK WITH THAT I APPRECIATE THE
THE WILLINGNESS OF THIS AUTHORED
ALWAYS LOOK TO FIND OTHER COMMON
GROUND SO.
WITH THAT -- IT DO WE HAVE A
MOTION NO WE DON'T ALL MOVES
ABOUT A GOOD SET TO MOTIONS
SENATE JACKSON -- REITERATES
CALL FOR MY COLLEAGUES -- COME
BACK TO THIS COMMITTEE THIS KEEP
WORK AND WITH US SEE IF YOU CAN
FIND SOME COMMON GROUND PRECIADO
BRINGS FORD AND THANK YOU FOR
MAKING THE TRIP AND STICKING
YOUR GROUND -- TO LIGHT A CLOSE
IS THE IN SUMMARY SIXTEEN AS
SANDERS AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
FROM THE AREA SIGNED A LETTER.
LAST YEAR ON THIS SUBJECT --
ASKING. FOR THESE OPTIONS TO BE
CONSIDERED IN THIS LEGISLATION
ADVANCES THAT AIM OF MY
COLLEAGUES AND AND THOSE IN THE
AREA THANK YOU GOOD
CONSIDERATION CENTER -- MOTION
IS TO PASS. TWO TWO GEO.
YES SENATOR STERN AYE STERN I'D
JONES ALLEN [inaudible]
BURGESS -- HERTZBERG HUESO.
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE MONNING MONEY AND I
WAS ON CALL WITH OUR WILL LEAVE
THAT MEASURE ON CALL.
AND WE WILL RECESS AND WE WILL
BE RECONVENED AFTER CAUCUS ONE
THIRTY IN ONE THIRTEEN AND THE
ROOM WILL BE [inaudible]
FOURTEEN ONE SORRY.
ONE THIRTEEN ONE THIRTEEN ALL
OVER IT.
WE ARE ALL. ONE THIRTEEN AT ONE
THIRTY SEE THIS
THE SENATE AS RESEARCH AND WATER
COMMITTEE WITH ARE VERY VERY
PATIENT MEMBER SENATOR HUESO.
I'M SORRY WITH FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SB THREE THIRTEEN IF
YOU'RE READY SIR.
THANK OU THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PLEASURE BE
HERE THANK YOU. FOR GIVING ME
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT
PRESENT A VERY IMPORTANT MEASURE
A MEASURE THAT GETS.
TO THE KIND OF COMMUNITY THAT WE
WANT TO LIVE HERE IN CALIFORNIA
IN THE FUTURE AND ANNA AND A
MESSAGE OF OF YOU KNOW HOW WE
EDUCATE HOW WE INTEGRATE WITH
WITH WITH NATURE.
AND HOW WE EDUCATE OUR KIDS ON
ON HOW TO INTEGRATE WITH NATURE.
THIS BILL IS IS A BILL THAT --
TRY TO PROTECT WILD ANIMALS.
IN OUR STATE.
ARE THOSE BEARS TIGERS ELEPHANTS
THAT ARE SUBJECTED TO HAVING TO
RIDE BICYCLES AND JUMP JUMP
THROUGH FIFTH BLAMING HOOPS.
AND TO RIDE TRAPEZE EN TO
BALANCE ON PEDESTALS AND
WHATEVER ELSE THEY MAKE THEM DO
THAT IS JUST NOT NOT.
DOES NOT COME NATURAL TO THEM
AND COMES AT ENORMOUS COST. TO
THEIR WELL BEING.
THEY PERFORM THESE THESE AMAZING
TRICKS BECAUSE THEY ARE
INTELLIGENT.
BUT MOSTLY BECAUSE THEY ARE
AFRAID OF WHAT THEY WHAT WHAT
WILL HAPPEN TO THEM IF THEY
DON'T.
HOW TO FORCE ANIMALS TO PERFORM
THESE TRICKS CIRCUS TRAINERS
ABUSE THEM WITH WHIPS MUSCLES
ELECTRIC HOT?
RODS BULL HOOKS [inaudible]
AND OTHER INSTRUMENTS THAT CAUSE
THEM PAIN AND CAUSE THEM --
EMOTIONAL ABUSE.
THIS IS NOT ONLY A ON AN OF
ANIMAL WELFARE ISSUE BUT IT'S
ALSO A PUBLIC SAFETY ISSUE WHEN.
ANIMALS ARE OFTEN WILD ANIMALS
ARE OFTEN PUSHED TO THE LIMIT.
THE A. H. IT AFFECTS THEIR
BEHAVIOR -- ELEPHANTS HAVE BEEN
IN PREVIOUS INSTANCES OUT
ELEPHANTS HAVE BOLTED FROM
CIRCUSES THEY'VE RUN AMOK TO THE
STREETS.
CRASHED INTO BUILDINGS ATTACK
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC AN INJURED
AND KILLED HANDLERS WITHOUT
OSTRICHES.
RUNNING LOOSE LIONS AND TIGERS
BEARS.
ANIMALS THAT ARE JUST SIMPLY
FLEEING FOR THEIR WORK SAFETY.
THIS MEASURE RECOGNIZES BOTH THE
ON WELL ANIMAL WELFARE CONCERNS
IT'S PUBLIC SAFETY CONCERNS.
OF CIRCUSES ANOTHER TRAVELING
SHOWS OF FORCE WILD OR EXOTIC
ANIMALS. TO PERFORM.
WE HAVE WITH US TODAY A JURY MAN
CRUISER WITH A SOCIAL COMPASSION
AND LEGISLATION.
AND UP DEL SIENNA WINDER IS FROM
A PIZZA.
AND I'D LIKE TO HAVE THEM MAKE
SOME COMMENTS AS TO WHY THIS
BILL IS NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA WHY
IT'S IMPORTANT.
IF YOU ALLOW THAT MISTER CHAIR.
GLADLY THANK YOU CENTER WELCOME.
THESE.
THANK YOU.
I AM DEL SANTA WINTERS I AM VICE
PRESIDENT AND DEPUTY GENERAL
COUNSEL FOR THE PIZZA FOUNDATION
AND I AM ALSO ADJUNCT FACULTY OF
VERMONT LAW SCHOOL EIGHTIES
ANIMAL WELFARE LAW.
AS SENATOR HUESO INDICATED
ANIMALS DON'T PERFORM TRICKS ON
COMMAND IN CIRCUSES BECAUSE THEY
WANT TO THEY DO SO BECAUSE THEY
ARE TERRIFIED OF THE
CONSEQUENCES IF THEY DON'T.
PETER HAS DOCUMENTED REPEATEDLY
THAT THESE ANIMALS HAVE BEEN
TAUGHT THROUGH VICIOUS BEATINGS
BEHIND THE SCENES WHAT WILL
HAPPEN IF THEY DON'T OBEY.
AND THEY SPEND MUCH OF THEIR
LIVES MANY CONSECUTIVE HOURS AND
SOMETIMES DAYS ON END CONFINED
IN CRAMPS FERRON TRAILERS.
AS A RESULT OF THIS TREATMENT
THEY CAN LASH OUT AND ANIMALS
HAVE.
ANIMALS ISN'T SERVICES HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED IN NUMEROUS HUMAN
INJURIES AND EVEN HUMAN DEATH.
OVER MY PAST DECADE A PRACTICING
AND TEACHING ANIMAL LAW.
THE TOTAL FAILURE OF OUR
EXISTING LAWS BOTH STATE AND
FEDERAL TO PROTECT ANIMALS IN
CIRCUSES AND PROTECT THE PUBLIC
FROM THEM HAS BEEN A CONSTANT
THEME.
THE FEDERAL ANIMAL WELFARE FAIR
ACT WHICH IS SUPPOSED TO BE
ENFORCED BY THE US DEPARTMENT OF
AGRICULTURE IS A TOTAL FARCE
IT'S THAT'S ONLY BARE MINIMUM
STANDARDS BUT TOTALLY FAILED TO
ADDRESS THE UNIQUE.
NEEDS OF WILD ANIMALS AND OTHER
ANIMALS IN CIRCUSES.
AND FAIL TO ADDRESS UNIQUE
SUFFERING POSED BY THE CONSTANT
CONFINEMENT AND PHYSICAL
PUNISHMENT IS ANIMALS SPACE.
IN ADDITION THE ANIMAL FACT IS
WOEFULLY UNDER AND FORCE THE
USDA'S OWN OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL HAS REPEATEDLY
DOCUMENTED THESE ENFORCEMENT
FAILINGS.
EVEN WITH CIRCUS EXHIBITORS
NEGLECT AND ABUSE RESULTS IN
DEATH TO HUMANS AND ANIMALS.
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO STAY IN
BUSINESS THIRD LICENSES ARE
AUTOMATICALLY RENEWED AT BEST
THEY'RE GIVEN A TINY SLAP ON THE
WRIST IN THE FORM OF A MONETARY
PENALTY THAT'S TREATED AS A COST
OF DOING BUSINESS.
CALIFORNIA'S PERMITTING PROCESS
DOES NOTHING TO ADDRESS THESE
PROBLEMS EITHER AT THE
GUIDELINES FAILED TO ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS THE COMPLEX NEEDS OF
THESE ANIMALS AND HOLY FELL TO
ADDRESS PUBLIC SAFETY. FOR THESE
REASONS I ASK YOU TO VOTE YES ON
SB THREE THIRTEEN TO PROVIDE
MUCH NEEDED PROTECTION FOR
ANIMALS USED IN CIRCUSES AS WELL
AS THE PUBLIC THANK YOU.
Q. IF I GET TO ADD DOES OF FINES
AND PENALTIES ARE TAX DEDUCTIBLE
TO THE THE FOUR WHEREAS LEAVE
FINANCING OUR THEIR PENALTIES
CRUELTY.
GOOD MORNING OR GOOD AFTERNOON
NOW SORRY JUDY MAN -- SO SOCIAL
COMPASSION AND LEGISLATION
CALIFORNIA HAS REPEATEDLY
WITNESSED THE FAILURE OF OUR
EXISTING LAWS TO PROTECT ANIMALS
IN CIRCUSES CLYDE THE LION BAKED
TO DEATH IN A CIRCUS BOX CAR
TRAVELING THROUGH THE MOJAVE
DESERT TO FRESNO.
THE DAYS TEMPERATURES EXCEEDED
ONE HUNDRED DEGREES BUT THE
CIRCUS COULDN'T BOTHER TO STOP
AND HELP THE CELL FOR SUFFERING
LION AND HUNTINGTON PARK A TIGER
WAS FOUND.
DEAD AND NEARLY DECAPITATED
AFTER A CIRCUS CRAMMED HER INTO
A CAGE WITH FIVE OTHER BIG CATS.
HAITI THE ELEPHANT WAS FORCED TO
PERFORMING GIVE RIDES AT A
CIRCUS IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
WHILE VISIBLY MACA.
THE NEXT DAY SHE DROPPED DEAD
ANOTHER ELEPHANT WITH THE CIRCUS
JOYCE HAD DIED JUST DAYS BEFORE.
THIS CIRCUS CALIFORNIA BASED
CIRCUS VARGAS DID THE RIGHT
THING AND JOIN THE EVER GROWING
LIST OF ANIMAL FREE CIRCUSES AND
IS NOW THRIVING.
IN FACT THERE ARE NO CIRCUSES
BASED IN CALIFORNIA THAT USE
ANIMALS BUT THAT DOESN'T STOP
THE ARE THE STATE I'LL FITS WITH
THE EXPENSE OF RAPSHEETS.
FROM COMING HERE AND ENDANGERING
THE PUBLIC CAN IMBUE ABUSING
ANIMALS.
THE GARDEN BROTHERS CIRCUS IS
KNOWN AS THE WORST CIRCUS INAMERICA AND IS PERFORMING TEN
DAY AND ANNIE ARE CALIFORNIA
TOMORROW IN SANTA ROSA.
DESPITE A DOCUMENT IT RECORD OF
ABUSE AND ESCAPES INCLUDING
RECENT CITATIONS FOR WITH BEING
A LLAMA WHO REFUSED TO PERFORM A
TRICK ON STAGE AND THE
COLLECTING A CAMEL'S BLOODY
PUNCTURE WOUNDS.
A FEW YEARS AGO ZEBRAS ESCAPE
FROM THE UNIVERSAL CIRCUS IN
OAKLAND A ZEBRA CAM BREAK A
LION'S DRAW YOU CAN IMAGINE WHAT
IT COULD DO TO A HUMAN.
POLLING SHOWS THAT THE MAJORITY
OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT BANNING
ANIMALS IN CIRCUSES THIS GROWING
PUBLIC DISDAIN IS FOR ARCHAIC
ANIMAL CIRCUSES AND INCIDENTS
LIKE THE ONES I JUST DISCUSSED
ARE WHY SO MANY JURISDICTIONS.
AROUND THE WORLD ARE BANNING
ANIMALS IN CIRCUSES I URGE
CALIFORNIA TO JOIN THEM AND VOTE
YES ON SB THREE ONE THREE THANK
YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
NOW BE THE TIME TO LINE UP AND
YOU'RE GONNA STATE YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION WITH YOU
SUPPORT THE MEASURE.
OKAY.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
WE'RE SO CLOSE ON BEHALF OF
ANIMAL OUT WELL FOR ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
ASHLEY LEWIS ON BEHALF OF PIZZA
AND ARE SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIA MEMBERS STRONGLY
SUPPORTS THANK YOU.
CHARLIE SAM IT MODERATE TO A
LOGICAL WE SUPPORT THE EFFORT
AND WE WANT TO THANK SENATOR
HUESO IS OFFICES STAFF FOR
TAKING THE TIME THEY TOOK TO
MODIFY THE BILL.
AND ACCOMMODATE THE SMALL ZOOS.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
JACK IN OF RO EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
OF WILD WONDERS WILDLIFE
CONSERVATION AN ACCREDITED
INSTITUTION WITH THETO A
LOGICAL ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU SENATOR HUESO.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU.
SEASON TEASING I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT WITH PETER AND ANIMALS
ARE NOT OURS FOR TORTURING THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
LEAD ON BEHALF ZOOLOGICAL CHOICE
ASIAN AMERICAN SUPPORT A GOOD.
HELLO LISA SAMMET FROM THE
MONTEREY ZERO I'M HERE SUPPORT
SB THREE THIRTEEN I'M HERE TO
THANK SENATOR HUESO AND HIS
STAFF RATHER SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'M CARE GARCIA I'M A LOCAL
RESIDENT OF SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA AND I SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU.
GALEN HAZEL OFFER FROM
SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK
YOU THANKS SO MUCH.
HI MY NAME IS SHARON ACRES I
LIVE IN HALF MOON BAY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT AND ALSO MY
FIVE YEARS OLD.
GRANDDAUGHTER AND THAT HER
CLASSMATE ALSO SUPPORT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU.
HI THERE I'M PAUL HAN -- A
BIOLOGIST FROM WILDLIFE LEARNING
CENTER DONE LOS ANGELES AND
WE'RE HERE TO SUPPORT AND THANK
US SENATOR HUESO FOR MAKING THE
CHANGES.
AND THANK YOU GUYS FOR LOOKING
INTO CONTEMPORARY PRACTICES
WHAT'S ACTUALLY GOING ON NOW
WITHIN THE INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME'S ERIC WELL THE FROM
HOLLYWOOD ANIMALS AND SUPPORTING
THIS BILL ALONG WITH -- BIRDS
ANIMALS UNLIMITED BOB DUNN'S
ANIMAL SERVICES GENTLE JUNGLE
GOOD DOG ANIMALS LOCKWOOD ANIMAL
RESCUE CENTRE STUDIO ANIMAL
SERVICES AND ANIMALS FOR
HOLLYWOOD.
I'D LIKE TO STE I THANK SENATOR
WAY SAYS OFFICE FOR TAKING THE
TIME TO AMEND THIS TO INCLUDE --
REAL ANIMAL CARE CARE GIVERS
LIKE A GOOD THANK YOU SIR.
CHRIS POLLARD FROM HOLLYWOOD
ANIMALS I'M HERE TO SUPPORT SB
THREE THIRTEEN AND I'D LIKE TO
THANK SENATOR WHO ALSO FOR
AMENDING.
THIS THANKS.
I THANK CAROLYN DIRTY I AM.
HERE REPRESENTING STUDIO AND
ALMOST SERVICES AND THE NAYS
BIRDS AND ANIMALS AND I'D LIKE
TO COME IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
WITH.
AND THANK SENATE HUESO FOR THE
AMENDMENTS AS WRITTEN AND THE
BILL PASSED AND I'M HARD AFTER.
HELLO MY NAME IS DAVID RIGHT
HEARD AND I AM THE DIRECTOR OF
WILDLIFE LEARNING CENTER I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS MY APPRECIATION
TO SENDER.
HUESOS FOR AMENDING THE BILL.
ON TO PROTECT THE VALUABLE WORK
THAT WE BELIEVE WE DO.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KIMBERLY
RIGHT AT CO DIRECTOR OF WILD
WONDERS WILDLIFE EDUCATION AND
CONSERVATION ORGANIZATION.
IN OUR BONDS OF CALIFORNIA AND I
DO SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I WANT
TO THINK A SENATOR HUESO AND ALL
THE LEGISLATURE'S FOR REALLY
WORKING WITH US IN REALIZING
THAT THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
SERIOUS.
COLLATERAL DAMAGE HAD IT BEEN
WRITTEN AS A CHARGE SO I
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT AND
SUPPORTING IT AS WRITTEN RIGHT
NOW THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HI I'M LAURIE KERN AND I ALSO
WANT TO THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO
AND IVANA -- FOR AMENDING THE
BILL IT WOULD HAVE DONE A LOT OF
DAMAGE OTHER WAYS AND SO I
SUPPORT THE BILL.
AND THAT'S IT.
I'M MICHELLE DRAPER CONSERVATION
EARTH -- ALSO CALLED WILD MIND
FOR AN OUT REACH FACILITY HERE
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA -- WE
APPRECIATE THE WORK YOU DID AND
AMENDING IT SO WE CAN CONTINUE
TO TEACH.
AND ALL OUR DEFENSES ALL AGES
ABOUT WILDLIFE EDUCATION
CONSERVATION WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MY NAME IS ROB NICELY I
REPRESENT THE WILDCAT EDUCATION
AND CONSERVATION FUN.
LIKE YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
AMENDING THE BILL TO ALLOW ME TO
CONTINUE MY THIRTY FIVE YEARS OF
WORK AND EDUCATION ABOUT WILD
CATS IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND ALSO TO ALLOW ME TO CONTINUE
WITH MY REPRESENTATION AT FUND
RAISERS FOR OUR CONSERVATION
PARTNERS WHO WERE DOING WORK ALL
OVER THE WORLD.
IN ORDER TO SAVE THESE ANIMALS
SO I DO SUPPORT THIS BILL IS
IT'S BEEN AMENDED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
MY NAME IS CHRISTINE WELL IN I
REPRESENT WILDCAT EDUCATION
CONSERVATION FUND AND I SUPPORT --
SB THREE ONE THREE AND
APPRECIATE CENTER HUESO FOR MANY
THE BILL TO CHEAP AFFAIR ANIMAL
LEGISLATION WHILE PROTECTING
RESPONSIBLE PRIVATE ANIMAL
EFFORTS AND CONSERVATION.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MA'AM.
SUSAN COOPER TO CAN I SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
MARGARET KIRKPATRICK FROM TURKEY
CALIFORNIA AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL LOOKS THAT
MIGHT BE YOUR SISTER.
ALL RIGHT I'M A COULDN'T GET.
SOME ANDREAS SOCIAL COMPASSION
LEGISLATION ANIMALS ARE NOT OURS
FOR ENTERTAINMENT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI I LET'S SEE MCCABE WITH
ANIMAL DEFENDERS INTERNATIONAL
ON BEHALF OF EIGHTY AYE AYE NOW
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIA
SUPPORTERS WE'D LIKE TO AND
STATE I SUPPOSE THE BELL.
AND ALSO -- I I WANTED TO
MENTION THAT WE SENT OUR
EXTENSIVE DATA -- BACKGROUND
INFORMATION TO THE COMMITTEE IN
THE PULSE AND WE'RE VERY LITTLE
FOR ANY QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE
THANKS.
MY NAME IS ROBERT BLOCK ISLAND
CRITTERS OF THE CINEMA OF WE DO
ANIMALS FOR FILM WE DON'T DEAL
MUCH WAS EXOTICS BUT WHEN WE DO
IT'S A JUST INCREDIBLE WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE TO BE AROUND THESE
AMAZING ANIMALS.
ON A SUGGEST BEFORE YOU START
BANNING.
ANIMALS OTHER THAN CIRCUS
ANIMALS HE WOULD GO UP TO ONE
THESE PLACES AND JUST SHE WAS
LIKE TO BE WITHIN A FEW FEET.
OF A LINER TIGER AND YOU'LL KNOW
WHY WE DO WHAT WE DO THANK YOU.
HI LAURA BRIDGMAN ON BEHALF OF
IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AND OR TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND MEMBERS FULL
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO
[inaudible]
THANKS.
LISA CARLIN THOUSAND OAKS
CALIFORNIA WITH SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION AND SHANE
AND SHANE NEWS I STRONG SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU. FOR STACEY SANDERS
GRASS VALLEY PLEASE HAVE
COMPASSION FOR ANIMALS IN SPORTS
BILL THANK YOU.
SO MUCH.
MARIE O'DONNELL GRASS VALLEY
CALIFORNIA MY FAMILY AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
TERRI BARNATO COLFAX CALIFORNIA
STRONGER SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
MA'AM.
JANE VELEZ MITCHELL JANA AND
SHANE NEWS NETWORK AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL IN AN
EDITORIAL THANK YOU.
JACOBY RIGHT NOW SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
WHEN THE BRAMBLE AND ON BEHALF
OF IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AND
MYSELF STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL?
IN THE MIDDLE SOURCE I'M HERE
FOR IN DEFENSE OF ANIMALS AND
PIZZA THANK YOU.
HI HANNAH SHINE REPRESENTED
PETER WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
EXT.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- JASON DAVIS --
PART OF THE DOG GUY CONSULTING --
STRONG SUPPORT THIS BILL GOOD
THANK YOU SIR.
CATHERINE TWELVE FOR THE
PERFORMING ANIMAL WELFARE
SOCIETY AND SAN ANDREAS AND ALSO
ON BEHALF OF THE COALITION OF
NINETEEN ANIMAL PROTECTION
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING MARIN
HUMANE AND THE BIG CATS CENTURY
ALLIANCE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
BILL.
THANK YOU.
JULIE CAPPIELLO ON BEHALF OF
WORLD NUMBER CHECHENS MILLIONS
OF SUPPORTERS IN CALIFORNIA AND
AROUND THE WORLD I AM ALSO A
RELATIVE OF CIRCUS OWNERS
PERFORMERS AND MANAGERS WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH BASK IN SOME WE HAVE FOR
THE WESTERN FAIRS ASSOCIATION
WITH THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN REMOVE
OPPOSITION THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANKS SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT SO SEEING NO OTHERS IN
SUPPORT TO HAVE ANY OPPOSED
[inaudible]
WHILE.
A LOT OF SUPPORT -- BRING IT
BACK TO THE DYESS SENATOR MINING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I TO WANT
TO THINK THE AUTHOR EARNED YOUR
TEAM FOR WORKING WITH US TO
ADDRESS.
CONCERNS SADDAM AS YOU KNOW I
BROUGHT CONCERNS OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS WHO ARE HERE TODAY
THE SALMON TO OPERATE THE
MODERATES WHO A LOGICAL IS A NON
PROFIT.
IT PROVIDES ACCESS FOR CHILDREN
OF FARMWORKERS AND OTHER
MONTEREY COUNTY AND REGIONAL
RESIDENTS.
AND PROVIDES OPEN SPACE MANY OF
THEIR ANIMALS HAVE BEEN RESCUED
AND THEY'REPROVIDING.
SAFE SUPPORTIVE AND LOVING CARE
SO AGAIN.
AS I'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW YOU
SENATOR HUESO.
THIS IS CONSISTENT WITH YOUR
APPROACH TO HAVE AN OPEN DOOR
AND BEING SENSITIVE TO THE
CONCERNS AND REFINING THIS BILL.
TO ESTABLISH THE SUPPORT
pYOU AND MISTER CHAIR THE
APPROPRIATE TIME I'D LIKE TO
MOVE THE BILL VERY GOOD THANK
YOU CENTER MONEY.
SEEN OTHER QUESTIONS I SAID ONE
COMMENT FREE AYE.
THANK YOU FOR BEING MY ATTENTION
THIS.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU CALL IT A
SHOW.
TONIGHT WHAT'S GOING ON IN
ANTIOCH.
BUT TO GO TO TRY TO PROCURE MY
TICKET AS WE'RE SITTING HERE
LOOKING AT THE FAMILY PACKS.
THE NUMBER KIDS THAT ARE BEING
TAKEN TO WATCH.
ELEPHANTS SIT ON CHAIRS AND
ELECTRIC LIGHT SHOWS WITH THEM
IN A LEATHER CLAD IN DANCERS
CLIMBING ALL OVER THAT MANAGE.
IT REALLY DEPENDS HOW YOU LOOK
AT ANIMALS AND WHETHER THEY'RE
OURS TO POSSESS AND THERE TO
ENTERTAIN US OR EVEN ABUSE.
OR WHETHER THEY HAVE THEIR OWN
DESTINY IN SPIRIT ON THEIR OWN I
THINK SENATOR.
I APPRECIATE YOUR BRINGING THIS
FORD BECAUSE IT'S TIME WE MOVE
PAST THIS BARBARIC PRACTICE AND
YEAH WE NEED TO EVOLVE AND NOT
JUST AS A STATE BUT TO SEND A
SIGNAL IN THIS COUNTRY SO.
HOPEFULLY WHATEVER'S ABOUT TO
TRANSPIRE TONIGHT IS THE LAST OF
ITS KIND.
SO THANK YOU.
ARM AND THE WITHOUT ANY OTHER.
FURTHER COMMENTS FROM THE DICE
THAT ALLOW YOU TO CLOSER.
ASSEMBLY -- THANK YOU FOR THE
TENSION YOU'VE GIVEN THE SPILL
THANK YOU -- FOR YOUR STAFF AND
WORKING WITH US ON THIS AS WELL
[inaudible]
AND LIKE I SAID I HOPE WE GET TO
A A BETTER THIS BILL GETS DISSED
A BETTER PLACE IN THE FUTURE.
ABSOLUTELY AND NINE AS FOR ALL
OF YOUR SUPPORT VERY GOOD --
MOTIONS FROM SENATOR MONNING THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY -- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL CENTERS STERN ALL RIGHT.
HI JONES.
ALLEN ORANGES CABALLERO
HERTZBERG HUESO HI HUESO AYE
JACKSON MONEY.
MONNING AYE VERY GOOD.
WE WILL LEAVE THAT MEASURE ON
CALL YOU THREE VOTES.
VERY GOOD.
AND THANK YOU THANKS FOR MAKING
A TRIP EVERYBODY REALLY
APPRECIATE SHALL BE IN HERE
[inaudible]
YEAH YEAH [inaudible]
ONLY.
THERE'S CERTAINLY SURE AYE
CARRETERA.
FILE ITEM -- TEN SENATOR STERN
IS SENATE BILL -- FOUR SIXTY
THREE CENTER STERN YOU HAVE THE
FLOOR AND INNER MUNNINGS IN MINE
UNDIVIDED ATTENTION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER.
WE'RE BRINGING IN THIS MEASURE
BACK LAST YEAR DUE TO SOME
TECHNICAL ISSUES DOWN THE
STRETCH -- WE DIDN'T END UP
MOVING THIS MEASURE OFF THE
FLOOR AT THE END OF SESSION.
WE'VE MADE IT ALL THE WAY TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR -- WITH
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT BUT TO REMIND
YOU ALL WHO WERE HERE TO VOTE ON
IT -- THERE ARE SOME GAPS IN OUR
OIL AND GAS -- DISCLOSURE LAWS
THAT.
CURRENTLY.
SUBJECT ONLY A CERTAIN SECTOR OF
OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS A CERTAIN
DISCLOSURES SO IF YOU ARE SAY --
FRACKING IN AN OIL FIELD UNDER
AN OLD BILL WE PASS AS BEFORE
YOU STILL HAVE TO DISCLOSE THE
CHEMICAL CONSTITUENTS.
OF THAT FRACKING FLUID YOU'RE
INJECTING BUT UNDER CURRENT LAW --
THOSE ASSESSMENTS -- ARE ARE NOT.
ARE NOT NOTICED IN THE SAME --
THE SAME MANNER -- AS AS IT IS.
FOR NATURAL GAS STORAGE SO WE'RE
SEEKING IMPROVE THE ASSESSMENT
THE RISK TO PUBLIC HEALTH FROM
GAS STORAGE WELL LEAKS IN THE
FUTURE LIKE THE ONE WE HAD IN.
MY DISTRICT IN A LEASE SO CANYON
ABOUT REQUIRING MORE THOROUGH
DISCLOSURE SO IN THE EVENT OF A
LEAK ENHANCE REPORTING
MONITORING.
ARE ALSO REQUIRED SO WHEN
IMPLEMENTED IDEALLY A MORE
COMPLETE PUBLIC HEALTH
ASSESSMENT WOULD BE AVAILABLE.
WHAT WE LEARNED FROM LEE SO
CANYON IS THAT IT WASN'T JUST
GAS THAT?
CAME OUT OF THAT FEEL DURING THE
EXPLOSION BUT IN FACT THERE WAS
OIL IN VARIOUS HEAVY METALS
BARIUM.
BENZENE THAT HAVE MADE MANY
PEOPLE SICK AND THEY SIMPLY
DON'T KNOW WHY SO IF YOU MADE
SICK BY ONE OF THESE INCIDENTS
THE FIRST THING YOU WANT TO KNOW.
WHEN YOU'RE TALKING YOUR DOCTOR
WHAT ACTUALLY MIGHT HAVE MADE ME
SICK OPEN IS SIMPLE DISCLOSURE
MEASURE -- BRINGS SHED SOME
LIGHT ON THIS MYSTERY THAT'S
BEEN AFFECTING OUR COMMUNITY FOR
YEARS AND HOPEFULLY I WON'T
AFFECT OTHER COMMITTEES IN THE
FUTURE BUT THIS IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT PUBLIC SAFETY
BACKSTOPS SO WITH THAT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SINCE YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CENTER MIND GIVE ANY QUESTIONS
[inaudible]
HI -- A SINNER MINING MOVES THE
BILL WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
NAME AND WHERE YOU'RE.
DISTANCE MAYBE FOR CAME DOWN
FROM FOR FLYING BILL ALLEY WITH
ENVIRONMENT WORKING GROUP WE
DON'T WORK IN THE OIL AND GAS
ISSUES FOR EIGHT YEARS NOW.
AND THIS IS ONE IMPORTANT ONES
TO CHARACTERIZE.
THE A CONSTITUENTS IN THE
UNDERGROUND NATURAL GAS STORAGE
IS IN CASE THERE IS A DISASTER
EVEN.
SMALL LEAKAGES SO WE APPRECIATE
THAT WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
AS IT MOVES FORWARD THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN MUCH AND RESPECT FASTER
I'VE.
THANK YOU AFRICAN CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
OVER MIDDLE QUALITY COMMITTEE
SENATOR STERN.
STERN I'D JONES JONES I ALLEN
WAGES COVER GYRO HERTZBERG.
HUESO JACKSON MONNING.
MONEY NINE THOSE THREE BIT OF
VOTES IT'S ON CALL. THREE VOTES
CENTERS JOURNAL THAT ON CALL I
SUPPOSE [inaudible]
ALRIGHT
[inaudible]
WHICH WILL [inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
YEAH
.
THE HOMELESS ONES AS ANA OKAY SO
ON CONSENT TODAY WE HAVE.
FILE IN FIVE SB ONE NINETY AND
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN SB SEVEN
NINETEEN HUESO MOTION FOR CENTER
HUESO PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SENATOR STERN AYE STERN AYE
JONES JONES I ALLEN FORGES. ZERO
HERTZBERG HUESO HUESO AYE
JACKSON MONEY MONEY.
NINE OKAY SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT
MEASURE ON CALL NO JUST ROLL
THROUGH THE THE REMAINING BILLS
SO.
WHEN YOU ARE READY?
WITH ONE TOLL FLEW SERVICE FILE
ITEM NUMBER ONE IS B. ONE
CURRENT FOR HIS THREE TO CHAIR
VOTING I'D PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SENATE.
MIRO HERTZBERG JACKSON MONEY
MONEY.
NINE OKAY LEAVE THAT ON CALL
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO SB -- SIXTY
NINE EVERYONE IS HERE OKAY WE'LL
SKIP THAT YOU GUYS OF ALL VOTED
ON THAT [inaudible]
NOT.
HANG ON A SECOND THE EVERYBODY'S
ON ONE SIXTY ONE SIXTY EIGHT
SORRY I GOT YOU ON YOU CAN OPEN
THE CALL ON SIX ACTUALLY.
YEAH YOU'VE GOT YOUR WATER BILL --
ROLL THROUGH YOU WANTED TO LIVE
THE ROLE ON FIVE FIVE NINE WILL
SPECIAL.
OF FILE ITEM ELEVEN WILL LIFT
THE CALL IN SB FIVE FIVE NINE
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
OCCURRED VOTERS FOUR ZERO CHAIR
NOT VOTING.
SENATOR STERN [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE.
JACKSON SO IT'S SIX SIX ZERO WE
WILL CLOSE THE ROLE ON ALLEN IN
JACKSON -- REMEMBER.
YOUR NUMBER WE WILL.
HOLD WE WILL WITH.
WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL BUT YOUR
VOTED.
FOR OKAY -- SEARCH FOR YOUR
PRESENT.
WELL -- WE ARE ON NUMBER.
THREE THIS IS THE ONE THIRTY
FOUR ONE OF HI.
HI SO -- LAST YEAR [inaudible]
FROM.
AUGUST TO JUNE.
MY STAFF TOGETHER WITH.
DENNIS O'CONNOR HERE THIS STAFF.
WE'RE INVOLVED IN A EXPAND A A
PROTRACTED NEGOTIATION. TO TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE AS
CONSERVATION IS A WAY OF LIFE.
CONVENING AS MANY AS I THINK
SEVENTY PEOPLE AT TIMES IN THE
ROOM TRYING TO COME UP WITH AN
AGREEMENT TO DEAL WITH
CONSERVATION IS YOU KNOW.
A COMMITTEE MEMBERS THE GOVERNOR
HAD AN EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THE
EXECUTIVE ORDER ASK FOR CERTAIN
LEVELS OF CONSERVATION WAS
PRETTY SUCCESSFUL.
THAT'S THE CHALLENGE WAS IN THE
LARGER ARCHITECTURE OF WATER
POLICY TO BE ABLE.
TO DEAL WITH THE OTHER ISSUES
CERTAINLY HAVE TO DEAL WITH THE
QUALITY OF DRINKING WATER A
REMAINING ISSUE IS PART OF THE
ARCHITECTURE OF WHAT WE'VE GOT
TO DEAL WITH.
BUT THIS HAD TO DO WITH
CONSERVATION.
AND SO ON AND THAT WAS A YOU A
TWO BILLS SIX OH SIX WHICH WAS
OUR BILL IN THE SENATE.
AND THE ASSEMBLY BILL I DON'T
REMEMBER THE NUMBERS HERE BUT IT
HAD TO DO WAS A SUMMER FRIEDMAN
TO THEY WERE PART OF THE PACKAGE
AT THE GOVERNOR SIGNED.
AND I'M OUR SOLUTION THAT WAS TO
COME UP WITH AN INDIVIDUAL AS
WATER USE OBJECTIVE DETERMINING
BY THE SUM OF MULTIPLE FACTORS
THAT MEANS THAT WATER SUPPLIERS
WERE TO FIND SAVINGS ACROSS THE
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL
INDUSTRIAL.
WATER LOSS AND OUTDOOR USE A ONE
OF THE GREAT CRITICISMS THAT
WITH AFTER THIS THING CAME ABOUT
GROUPS ARE SAYING -- I CAN'T
FLUSH MY TOILET AND TAKE A
SHOWER AT THE SAME TIME AND WHAT
WE WERE LOOKING AT WAS WATER
LOSS ACROSS THE THE AGENCY SO
AND AND CONSERVATION ACROSS THE
AGES IT WASN'T APPLIED TO THE
INDIVIDUAL.
BUT APPLY TRYING AS AN AGENCY TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY WERE
CONSERVING WATER IS CONSISTENT
WITH THIS APPROACH.
AND SO -- IT LOUD WATER AGENCIES
TO MEET THEIR STANDARDS THAT
ACCUMULATED APPROACH A WOMAN
ACCUSED THIS MEASURE. TO UPHOLD
THE SPIRIT OF THE NEGOTIATIONS
FROM LAST YEAR TO ENSURE THAT
WATER SUPPLIERS ARE GIVEN THE
FLEXIBILITY THEY NEED -- TO
PRACTICALLY REACH THEIR
EFFICIENCY GOALS IN THAT REGARD
SPECIFICALLY THIS MEASURE.
DETERMINES THAT THIS -- THE
TERMS OF STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD WILL ENFORCE AND
ACCUMULATED PERFORMANCE STANDARD.
ENSURING THAT THE VOLUME AT
VOLUME OF WATER LOSS IS NOT
ENFORCED SEPARATELY FROM OTHER
FACTORS NOW THERE IS.
A OF THE ANALYSIS WHICH IS
ALWAYS BRILLIANTLY WRITTEN BY
THIS COMMITTEE STAFF.
WHICH IDENTIFIES A A A A A
ATTENTION THAT EXIST WHERE
THERE'S A QUESTION ABOUT THE
PEOPLE THAT WERE IN THE ROOM AND
WHAT THEY MEANT.
AND SO WE LOOK AT SOME OPTIONS
OF BY YOUR COMMITTEE -- WHICH
WE'LL TALK ABOUT HERE BUT I WANT
THE REST OF THE BILL TO BE
PRESENTED SO WE'RE REALLY TRYING
TO FOR YOU FOR THE FOLLOW UP.
ON THE WHOLE ISSUE OF YOU KNOW
WATER CONSERVATION IS A WAY OF
LIFE AND HOW DO WE MEET THOSE
STANDARDS TO OFTEN ARE QUITE
TICKLISH IN THE PROCESS.
THANK YOU CENTER RIGHT NOW MY
NAME IS DANIEL BLOSSOM HIDING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL
UTILITIES ASSOCIATION ARE FORTY
PLUS MEMBERS SERVE ABOUT 70% OF
THE WATER.
IN CALIFORNIA I'M SENATE
MAJORITY LEADER HERTZBERG DID A
GREAT JOB EXPLAINING THE INTENT
OF THE MEASURE BUT WE REALLY
FEEL SO THIS APPROACH -- ALLOWS
WATER SUPPLIERS OF FLEXIBILITY
TO DECIDE ON ON WHAT AREAS ARE
GOING TO FOCUS ON BASED ON
WHAT'S BEST FOR THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
LEVERS THE PUSH AND PULL IF YOU
WILL -- WE BELIEVE THAT ONE OF
THE COMPONENTS WATER LOSS IS
BEING HELD TO A HIGHER STANDARD
AND IT IS CONTRARY TO THE SPIRIT
OF THE LEGISLATION AGREE TO LAST
YEAR.
AS A LITTLE BIT OF BACKGROUND.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN SB FIVE FIVE
FIVE DIRECTED YOU TO BE YOU ARE
IN THE STATE FOR TO PROMULGATE
REGULATIONS RELATED TO THE
VOLUME OF WATER LOSS.
WHEN THE STATE BOARD ADOPTS THE
REGULATIONS THE VOLUMETRIC
STANDARD WILL BE ENFORCEABLE THE
STANDALONE TARGET?
AND THIS IS UNLIKE ANY OTHER --
PART OF THE OVERALL OBJECTIVE
AND COULD SUBJECT WATER
SUPPLIERS TO SIMULTANEOUS
ENFORCEMENT ACTIONS.
I DON'T WANT TO BE CLEAR WATER
AGENCIES ARE COMMITTED TO
MEETING THE OBJECTIVES OUTLINED
IN THE LEGISLATION FROM LAST
YEAR THAT WE WERE PROUD TO
SUPPORT.
AND WE WANT TO ACTIVELY REDUCE
WATER LAWCENTER SYSTEMS IT MAKES
OPERATIONAL AND FINANCIAL SENSE
TO DO SO -- WE BELIEVE THAT
WATER LOSS IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT IN THE OBJECTIVE BUT
IT'S NOT APPROPRIATE TO HOLD
THAT ELEMENT TO A HIGHER
STANDARD.
THAN EVERY OTHER ELEMENT NOR IS
IT APPROPRIATE TO START YOU KNOW
IN FORCING OR ENSURING THAT --
WATER SUPPLIER NEEDS EACH
INDIVIDUAL PART OF THE OVERALL
OBJECTIVE -- WE BELIEVE THAT ONE
THIRTY FOUR IS A COMMON SENSE
MEASURE COMPLIMENTS THE EFFORTS
OF WATER SUPPLIERS BY PROVIDING
CLARITY THAT THE VOLUMETRIC
WATER LOSS PERFORMANCE STANDARDS.
ARE ONLY ENFORCEABLE PART OF THE
OVERALL AND WATER USE OBJECTIVE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THOSE VERY GOOD THANK YOU OTHERS
IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISS CHAIR
MEMBERS ADAM KIANA SOME BEHALF
OF THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL -- LAST YEAR AKA
WORKED WITH THE SENATOR CMU A
AND AND MANY OTHERS IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OF SB.
SIX OH SIX AS PART OF THAT
PROCESS ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
AQUA ADVOCATE FOR HIS
FLEXIBILITY FOR OUR WATER
AGENCIES.
IN MEETING THIS NEW URBAN WATER
USE OBJECTIVE -- I AM GONNA GIVE
ME MUCH OF THE COMMENTS THAT I
MADE DANIELLE COVER MOST OF IT --
REALLY WHEN WE LOOK AT THIS --
THESE OBJECTIVES TOTAL THE WAY
THEY WERE CONSTRUCTED WAS REALLY
IN THE AGGREGATE LOOKING AT A
NUMBER OF WAYS TO MEET THESE
CONSERVATION STANDARD AND FOR US
MAKING SURE THAT THERE IS THAT
FLEXIBILITY FOR EACH AGENCY TO
DECIDE HOW.
TO MEET THOSE CONSERVATION
STANDARDS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
US.
EACH AGENCY IS VERY DIFFERENT WE
REPRESENT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
PLUS WATER AGENCIES -- AND SO
THE WAY TO GO ABOUT MEETING THIS
OBJECTIVE IS IS CAN BE VERY
DIFFERENT ACROSS THE BOARD.
IF I COULD JUST DRAW A QUICK
COMPARISON -- TO THE R. P. S.
PROGRAM IT WAS ESTABLISHED
OBVIOUSLY BACK IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWO YOUR PS IS
MEANT TO REDUCE THE USE OF
FOSSIL FUELS AND PROMOTE THE USE
OF RENEWABLES.
SIMILARLY THE KIND CONSERVATION
BILLS PASSED LAST YEAR SEEK TO
REDUCE WATER USE AND PROMOTE
CONSERVATION.
THERE ARE FEARS PROGRAM PROVIDES
A VARIETY OF OPTIONS FOR
UTILITIES TO PROCURE RENEWABLE
ENERGY AND REDUCE THEIR RELIANCE
ON FOSSIL FUELS IT DOESN'T SET A
STANDARD FOR EACH TYPE OF ALSO
FEEL.
I THINK WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
HERE IS SOMETHING SIMILAR WHERE
WE'RE SETTING A CONSERVATION
STANDARD AND MAKING SURE THAT
EACH AGENCY HAS THE ABILITY TO
MEET THAT STANDARD IN A VARIETY
OF WAYS IS REALLY IMPORTANT TO
US.
SO -- BY BY PRIORITIZING WATER
LOSS OVER.
OTHER WAYS TO MEET THAT STANDARD
INDOOR OUTDOOR EFFICIENCIES.
AND YOU'RE TAKING AWAY THAT
FLEXIBILITY SO WHAT WE ARE
ASKING FOR IS TO MAINTAIN THAT
FLEXIBILITY THAT WE UNDERSTOOD
WAS A PART OF THE LAW -- AND AND
SO WE ARE SUPPORTIVE OF THE BILL
TODAY.
THANK YOU SIR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
THERE'S DIVERSE I'M HEALTHY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT OF
ORANGE CALIFORNIA.
UP OR MODOC MODOC BECAUSE ONE OF
THE FIRST WATER INDUSTRIES --
AGENCIES TO GO UP IN SUPPORT OF
SIXTEEN SIXTY EIGHT SIX OF SIX
WAS EXTREMELY CONTROVERSIAL THE
WAY WE GOT A LOT OF PEOPLE
COMFORTABLE WITH IT WAS SAYING.
YEAH THIS IS A BIG CHANGE BUT
YOU WON'T BE MICROMANAGE IT'LL
BE UP TO YOU TO HOW TO MEET THIS
IF WITH A TOLD THEM AT THAT TIME
THAT WE'RE GONNA PULL SOMETHING
OUT IN YOUR SOMETHING NOT
INCLUDED WHEN A MICRO MANAGE ON
THAT I WOULD NEVER HAVE GOTTEN.
THEM OVER THE HUMP ON THIS NO
WAS PERSONALLY INVOLVED IN
CONVERSATIONS WHERE I WAS TOLD
THIS WILL BE ADDRESSED IN QUORUM
COOK CLEAN UP LEGISLATION.
OF COURSE WE ALL KNOW THAT CLEAN
UP IS POSTING ON CONTROVERSIAL
SO WE THANK SENATOR HERTZBERG
FOR BRINGING THIS PART THANK YOU.
ISN'T IT FUN TO NEGOTIATE THE
BIG DEALS WITH HIS CONFUSION AT
THE END.
THAT'S WHAT I SAID.
REINER JACKING OF REGIONAL WATER
AUTHORITY DON'T HAVE ANYTHING TO
ADD DO YOU THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THE DEAL THE
DEAL THE DEAL.
AND WITH THAT SUPPORT.
GOOD THANK YOU.
NO I MAC ON BEHALF OF THE CITY
OF ROSEVILLE NIVAL ASSOCIATE MY
COMMENTS WITH THE ASSOCIATION
THANK YOU.
AND MR BEFORE YOU CALL FOR
OPPOSITION IF I COULD JUST
BRIEFLY BUCK YOU KNOW WORK WE'LL
WE'LL WORK IT OUT WE'RE GONNA
WILLING THE THE THE THE YOUR
COMMITTEE STAFF.
WHO IS PART OF THIS THING FOR
THOSE TEN MONTHS -- WHEN HE
WORKED FOR MY COMMITTEES
DEFINITE JUST YOU KNOW WE STILL
YOU KNOW HOW THAT WORKS A FEW WE
STILL ALL PART OF THE STATE YOU
GOT IT WE'RE ALL PART OF THE
SAME FAMILY YEAR?
BUT WHAT WE'LL FIGURE IT OUT I
MEAN HE'S OUTLINED THREE OPTIONS
AND LOOK IT'S NOT EASY BUT IT WE
GOT WAY DOWN THE ROAD IN
SOMETHING WHERE NOBODY EVER
THOUGHT WE DID WITH WATER
CONSERVATION AND THESE ARE
CHALLENGING AND IF DIFFICULT
THINGS BUT I HAVE TALKED TO
ENERGY SEE.
AND THEY'VE BEEN PRETTY
REASONABLE IN THIS STUFF AND SO
JUST TO YOU KNOW YOU ARE BE I'M
DOING THIS BECAUSE I THINK IT'S
THE RIGHT THING TO DO BECAUSE
IT'S WHAT I SAID I WOULD DO IN
THE BEGINNING AND YOUR HONOR
BOUND TO FOLLOW THROUGH.
RIGHT YES YES HONOR IS
EVERYTHING FOR THE INSTITUTION
BUT I THINK THAT THERE'S A
PATHWAY FORWARD WITH THE
GUIDANCE OF YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF --
WELL SAID.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT NO.
WE HAVE SOME OPPOSITION.
YEAH THAT THAT'S RESERVE THAT.
AND SO YEAH YOU WANT TO COME ON
UP THOSE IN OPPOSITION.
WE JUST YES I HAVE A BRIEF
DISCUSSION.
I'LL BE READY FOR IT.
HI AND WELCOME.
GOOD AFTERNOON OF MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
TRACY CLAN I AM DE CALIFORNIA
DIRECTOR OF WATER.
EFFICIENCY FOR THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
I RESPECTFULLY TAKING THE
POSITION OF OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED.
ENERGY SEE WAS ONE OF THE MOST
ACTIVE SUPPORTERS OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WATER EFFICIENCY
LEGISLATION AND WORKED CLOSELY
WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS -- WHERE THE ISSUE
OF DOUBLE JEOPARDY DID COME UP
DURING THAT DEBATE?
ABOUT WE NEVER DISCUSSED
REMOVING ENFORCEMENT FROM THE
WATER LOSS STATUE THAT HAD
PREVIOUSLY BEEN ADOPTE UNDER --
SB FIVE FIVE FIVE IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN IF THAT HAD BEEN
PROPOSED I WE WOULD NOT HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO CONTINUE OUR
SUPPORT FOR THAT LEGISLATION.
ENERGY SEE IS SYMPATHETIC TO THE
POTENTIAL DOUBLE DOUBLE JEOPARDY
ISSUE AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE A
SOLUTION.
BUT RESPECTFULLY AND VEHEMENTLY
OPPOSE THE APPROACH TAKEN IN --
THE CURRENTLY WRITTEN SB.
ONE THIRTY FOUR WATER LOSS IS
ONE OF THE CLEAREST FORMS OF
WATER WASTE.
IT'S WATER THAT IS A STRETCH
EXTRACTED FROM THE ENVIRONMENT
SOMETIMES PUMP HUNDREDS OF MILES
TREATED TO DRINKING WATER
STANDARDS AND THEN LOST THROUGH
LEAKS AND PIPE BREAKS.
OCCASIONALLY CAUSING EXTENSIVE
AND EXPENSIVE DAMAGE TO PROPERTY
AND INFRASTRUCTURE.
RESPONSIBILITY TO MEET A WATER
LOSS STANDARD IS ALSO COMPLETELY
UNDER THE CONTROL OF THE WATER
UTILITY IT DOES NOT REQUIRE A
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR CUSTOMERS.
IT'S UP TO THEM TO GO OUT AND
AND MEET THAT STANDARD AND AND
FIX THOSE LEAKS -- I THINK IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT MEMBER WHY WATER
LOSS WAS INCLUDED AS PART OF THE
WATER EFFICIENCY OBJECTIVE.
PRIOR TO THE LEGISLATIVE PERIOD --
WE ALL WORKED THERESTAKEHOLDER
PROCESS WITH FIVE STATE AGENCIES
TO DEVELOP THE MAKING WATER
CONSERVATION A CALIFORNIA WAY OF
LIFE FRAMEWORK.
AND AT THAT TIME THIS OBJECTIVE
WAS ENVISIONED TO INCLUDE ALL
TYPES OF WATER DEMANDS -- SO
WATER DEMANDS PLUS WATER LOSS
EQUALS THE WATER THAT UTILITIES
PUTTING IN THE SYSTEM.
WHICH MADE THE FOR COMPLIANCE
PURPOSES A WATER SUPPLIER COULD
SIMPLY REPORT THE WATER THEY'RE
PUTTING INTO THE SYSTEM IT WOULD
REALLY JUST MAKE THE ACCOUNTING
IMPORTING A LOT EASIER.
AS IT BECAME LEGISLATION AND WE
WORK TO THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
SOME OF THOSE DEMANDS WERE
STARTED STARTED TO BE PULLED
FROM THE WATER OBJECTIVE SO
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL INDOOR
WATER USE WS PULLED OUT.
IT MAKES A LOT LESS SENSE FOR
THAT WATER LOSS TO BE IN THERE
NOW SO AGAIN WATER LOSS WAS NOT
INCLUDED TO PROVIDE EXTRA
FLEXIBILITY IT WAS INCLUDED TO
EASE REPORTING.
NOW IT DOES IF YOU WE DO SUPPORT
IF YOU ARE EXCEEDING YOUR WATER
LOSS STANDARD BEING ABLE -- TO
USE THAT TO HELP ME YOUR
OBJECTIVE AND I THINK THAT
THAT'S CAPTURED UNDER THE
ALTERNATIVE NUMBER TWO THAT YOU
SEE IN THE ANALYSIS -- THERE'S
ALSO -- ANOTHER OPTION THEIR
ALTERNATIVE THREE BOTH OF THOSE
REMOVED DOUBLE JEOPARDY WITHOUT
REMOVING THE ENFORCEMENT FROM
THE WATER LOST OUT YOU.
WE MET WITH SENATOR HERTZBERG
THIS MORNING AND HE HAS AGREED
TO WORK WITH US TO HOPEFULLY
SETTLE ON AN ALTERNATIVE
APPROACH THAT WOULD REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION.
WE APPRECIATE THE SENATORS
COMMITMENT TO WORK WITH US --
AND UNFORTUNATELY FOR THE
CURRENT VERSION OF THE BILL WE
REMAIN IN OPPOSITION AND LESS IT
IS AMENDED TO ADDRESS DOUBLE
JEOPARDY WITHOUT REMOVING
ENFORCEMENT THE WATER LAW
STATUTE FOR THE WATER LOSS AT
WATER LOSS STANDARDS FOR THE
WATER LAST ISSUED BY THE STATE
BOARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME IN HIS
WITH.
OTHERS IN OPPOSITION.
BRENNAN DAWSON WAS ERICA
CALIFORNIA WE WOULD ALIGN
OURSELVES IN OUR DC OF WE DIDN'T
GET A LETTER AND WE'RE SORRY
ABOUT THAT BUT NOW YOU HAVE IT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY I KNOW THERE'S IN
OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS QUESTIONS I DO A YOUR
QUESTION COMING YOU SIR AND
ALWAYS OF JUST GENERALLY A
COMMENT BECAUSE I'VE BEEN MADE
AWARE OF A COMPANY THAT NOW THAT
IT'S PROVIDING.
LEAGUE THE TEN DETECTION
TECHNOLOGY [inaudible]
MANAGED.
PRETTY AFFORDABLE IN IN TERMS OF
WHAT THEY'RE ABLE TO ACCOMPLISH
THROUGH -- THROUGH -- DETECTION
SYSTEM THAT.
NOTES -- CHANGES OF PRESSURE AND
OPINION WHERE THEY APPLY THEIR
TECHNOLOGY COULD HELP.
MUNICIPALITIES IDENTIFY WHERE
LEAKS ARE KIND OF IN REAL TIME.
AND AS WE GET THIS TECHNOLOGY --
DEVELOPED IT WOULD BE NICE.
TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO EMPLOY IT
AND WHEN I WHEN I A I HELPED --
MANAGE THE WITH THE WATER
DELIVERY SYSTEM IN SAN DIEGO THE
TRUTH THIS -- A LITTLE BIT OF
PRESSURE RELATED.
TO OTHER LOSSES WERE FACING CASA --
FORCES TO PUT A CONSIDERABLE
INVESTMENT INTO UPGRADING OUR
SYSTEM AND WE WENT FROM.
A LEAK EVERY WEEK TO TO LIBERAL
ZERO LEAKS PER YEAR -- BUT I
LITERALLY ENORMOUS GAINS JUST
SIMPLY BECAUSE WE'RE TIRED OF
LOSING LAWSUIT AND AND WHAT AND
BEEN FINE.
AND INSTEAD OF A COMPLAIN THAT
MONEY TO PAY LAWSUITS AND FINDS
WHEN WE JUST FIX OUR
YOU KNOW
WHERE WE'RE AT THE END OF THE
PIPE IN SAN DIEGO SO WE HAVE
LIMITED OPTIONS OF WHERE TO GET
OUR WATER SUPPLY FROM BUT ALSO
IF WE DO GET IT WE CAN'T.
LINK IT NO MATTER WHERE IT COMES
FROM AT THE END OF THE PIPE DOWN
THE S. AS THOUGH I JUST
ENCOURAGE YOU -- TO INA.
WHAT TO WORK ON THIS AND TO ALSO
LOOK AT WHAT OPTIONS THERE ARE
TO PUT INTO?
OF YOU KNOW A MAYBE IT MAYBE WE
GIVE.
CREDIT TO AGENCIES THAT
[inaudible] TO MAKE
[inaudible]
OF STARTED EFFORT TO REDUCE
THESE LEAKS AND IF THEY'RE
PLAYING THESE TECHNOLOGIES
SOMEHOW ADDED TO THE BILL.
YOU KNOW WE WE WE HAVE LESS
EXCUSES TODAY THAN WE DID TEN
YEARS AGO.
A QUESTION -- SO AT SOME POINT
IS GONNA BE A A BALANCE IN TERMS
OF HOW WE ADDRESS THE STATEWIDE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR THE CENTER I'M SO
COMMENTS FROM THE AUTHOR IN
TERMS OF OPTION TWO I KNOW WAS
BROUGHT UP BY OUR DC YEAH IT
WOULD TAKE WE TALKED THIS
MORNING ABOUT OPTION TWO OPTION
THREE I I WHAT I WANT TO TO HAVE
A CHANCE TO TALK TO THE SPONSORS.
OF THE BILL AND KIND OF GO BACK
AND TRY TO GET SOME STE BACK AND
FORTH AND MAYBE BORROW YOUR IF
WATER CONSULTANT AGAIN IF I
COULD. TO HELP US I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT AND WORKING WITH
THE COMMITTEE TO HELP US KIND OF
REACH A RESOLUTION I MEAN LOOK
WE THIS IS HARD AND I I THINK
WHICH IN A WAY SO SAYS CORRECT
TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO CHANGE IS
GONNA BE NEW WAYS TO LINE.
PIPES IS GONNA THE COST OF WAR A
WOMAN WATER SO GREAT -- YOU KNOW
FOR A BUNCH OF REASONS AND WE
JUST GOT TO BE SMARTER ABOUT IT
THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT WERE WAY
DOWN THE ROAD COMPARED TO WHAT
WE USED TO BE.
AND WE GOT A REPAIR THIS AND
THEN WE GET A FOCUS ON WATER
QUALITY FOR THE MILLION PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT DON'T HAVE
CLEAN AND SAFE DRINKING WATER.
BUT THIS NOTION OF OF NOT UNDER
CUTTING SB WHAT IS IT FIVE FIVE
FIVE THE WOKE BILL THE WOKE BILL
WHO.
JUST INTENT NOT TO UNDER CUT
THAT AND SORT OF TRY TO STICK
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF THE
FLEXIBILITY TO DEAL.
YEAH I MEAN IT'S HARD TO SUBMIT
A HARD DEBTS WHY TOOK TEN MONTHS
WITH THESE GUYS AS SMART AS THEY
ARE MAKE IN THIS DEAL HE COULD
DO IT IN TEN WEEKS THEY TOOK TEN
MONTHS.
AT ALL THE MEETINGS AND STUFF
YOU KNOW THE WATER WORLD'S LIKE
IT'S HARD AND AND SO I'M PRETTY
PROUD OF HOW FAR WE CAN DOWN THE
ROAD I THINK A SIMILAR FRIEDMAN
DID A GREAT JOB AS WELL -- YOU
KNOW OUR TEAM WAS IT WAS JUST I
THINK PRETTY PHENOMENAL AND YOU
KNOW IT SHOOTS THE PRICE OF
MOVING DOWN THE ROAD SO WHAT
WOULD LOOK THE BOTTOM LINE IS
WORKING TO TRY TO FIGURE IT OUT.
AND WE WILL.
WE WILL RIGHT.
ARE WE APPRECIATE THAT
COMMITMENT AND AND GOOD POLICY
MAKING IS HARD I DO FOR THE
RECORD I DO THINK THERE'S SOME.
IS THERE SOME CLEVERNESS IN THIS
NOTION OF LOOKING AT WHETHER
YOU'RE EXCEEDING THE WATER USE
SUBJECTIVE SOLELY BECAUSE YOU'RE
SIXTY THE WATER LOSS STANDARD IN
SORT OF A WAY.
TO ED PARSE OUT THE CAUSATION
BEHIND IT -- TO TRY TO GET IT.
STRIKE CONTINUE THE GOOD
ACCOUNTING BUT NOT HAVE SOME
ARBITRARY DOUBLE JEOPARDY SO I
HOPE YOU ALL CONSIDER THAT AS
WELL GOING FORWARD WOULD LOVE
YOU TO WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE AND I'M.
A VERY TO MOVE THE BILL LONG
TODAY WITH THAT COMMITMENT
SENATOR SO.
OKAY -- NO OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS LATER CLOSER.
AS FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK IS
GOING OKAY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL MOTIONS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR
STERN.
HI STERN HI JONES.
JONES I ALLEN BURGESS CABALLERO.
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG HAS BURKE
AYE HUESO.
HUESO AYE JACKSON MONEY.
MONEY HI.
HAS THEM SIX SIX WILL PUT ON
CALL FOR THE MISSING THEM OKAY.
WE'LL LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL
[inaudible]
I
YOU CALLS ON MEMBERS.
ON A ON BILLS THAT WE STILL HAVE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON SO I'LL LET
YOU GUYS GET YOURSELVES SORTED
HERE.
THERE SHE IS SORTED READY TO GO
SO WE'RE GONNA START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER.
ONE I'M SORRY.
MY WHICH IS RIGHT REAL QUICK
OKAY FILE ITEM ONE SB ONE ATKINS
CURRENT VOTERS FOR TO CHAIR
VOTING I PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THERE'S CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HIGH
JACKSON.
JACKSON NINE OR I WILL CLOSE THE
ROLE SEVEN TO THE BILL'S OUT
FILING NUMBER TWO SB. SIXTY NINE
FOUR TWO CHAIR VOTING ON A IN
THIS COME BUREAU.
HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH.
OR THAT IS SIX TWO THE BILL IS
OUT TO CLOSE.
GROWS THE BILL THERE.
THAT'S THAT'S NOT OUR NUMBER --
THREE SB.
ONE THIRTY FOUR SENATOR
HERTZBERG -- SIX ZERO TWO PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS SENATE ALLEN
FORGES JACKSON.
JACKSON HIGH BILLS -- SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN ZERO CLOSE THE ROLE ON
THAT.
YEAH WE JUST WE'RE GONNA JUST
CLOSE THE ROLE OKAY SEVEN ZERO
SEVEN SEVEN THERE THE BILL'S OUT --
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR SB ONE
SIXTY Y. CASKEY FOR TO CHEER
VOTING -- AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL AND IS CABALLERO.
I HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE
JACKSON JACKSON HIGH.
OKAY SEVENTY TWO THE BILLS OUT.
LET'S ROLL THROUGH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR NOW THAT'S FILE ITEM
FIVE IN IS THAT THIS BE ONE
NINETY AND FILE ITEM THIRTEEN
THAT'S SB SEVEN NINETEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CENTERS ALLEN.
FORGES CABALLERO CAREER AYE
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG I'D JACKSON.
JACKSON HI OKAY THAT IS. SEVEN
ZERO WE'LL CLOSE THE ROLE ON
THAT THE BILL IS OUT -- NUMBER
SIX SB TWO TWO SIX MOTIONS DO
PASS.
SIR -- DO PUT TO PASS A NO NOT
AS MINISTER DO PASSED THE
COMMITTEE ON RULES.
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS WILL BE
TAKEN IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE --
SO SIX YEAR CHAIR OF THE DENTURE
AT HASN'T VOTED YET SO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
SENATORS TURN BY TURN HI ALAN
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI.
SO OKAY IT IS YOUR THE MEASURES
OUT.
MOVING ON A FILE IN A NUMBER
SEVEN SB -- THREE OH SEVEN FIVE
ZERO CHAIR VOTING II CENTERS
JONES [inaudible]
BURGESS [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
HUESO.
OKAY I'M IN NO ONE THAT.
OKAY JONES NO.
AT FIVE ONE THAT MEASURE IS OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT SB THREE THIRTEEN HUESO DO
PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
AND THERE'S JONES.
ALAN FORGES.
CABALLERO.
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
I'D JACKSON JACKSON HI.
SIX TO LEAVE THE MEASURE ON CALL.
HE WOULD SENATOR BORDERS IF YOU
CAN GET BACK [inaudible]
NUMBER.
NINE OKAY SB THREE NINETY FIVE
ARCHULETA -- TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS FIVE ZERO
CHAIR VOTING I SAYS JONES.
JONES I OR JUST HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG AYE JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE THOSE EIGHT ZERO
EIGHT ZERO THE THE MEASURES OUT --
WHO WE MISSING BURGESS ALL RIGHT
WHAT WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL
FOR GORGEOUS?
FILE ITEM [inaudible]
ELEVEN SB.
FIVE I'M SORRY TEN STERN FOUR
DAYS BEFORE SIXTY THREE DO PASS.
TO PASS TO EQ.
VOTE IS THREE ZERO CHAIR VOTING
I YOU GUYS GOT IT.
WHEN SENATE ALLEN FORTUS
CABALLERO CAREER AYE HERTZBERG?
LET IT.
DIE THIS IS VERY AYE HUESO
JACKSON.
JACKSON AYE.
OKAY SIX ZERO SIX ZERO WE THAT
ON CALL -- A LOT OF FILING
ELEVEN SB -- FIVE FIVE NINE TADO --
MOTIONS D PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
COVER SIX YOUR CHAIR NOT VOTING.
SENATOR STERN.
ALAN JACKSON. SIX ZERO SIX
YOU'RE THE MEASURES THAT WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLE ON THAT.
JACKSON NINE THAT IS.
SEVEN ZERO THAT MEASURES OUT.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB FIVE
SEVEN SIX NUMBER DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR ZERO CHAIR
VOTING I CENTERS JONES.
JONES NO ALLEN FORGES HERTZBERG.
AS FOR I'D JACKSON.
JACKSON -- NINE SIX TO ONE SIX
TO ONE WILL LEAVE THAT ON CALL
FOR THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
VIOLENCE FOURTEEN GLAZER DO
PASSED THE COMMITTEE ON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION.
VOTERS THREE ZERO SAN IS JONES
JONES NO ALLEN FORGES CARILLO.
CAREER AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
AYE HUESO.
HOW MANY [inaudible]
ZERO FIVE YEAH [inaudible]
THAT'S ENOUGH.
HUESO WAS IN HERE ALLEN BURGESS
I'M TELLING YOU WANT TO WAIT FOR
GORGEOUS IS PRESENT IN THE BILL.
I AM DOWN YEAH.
OKAY SO I NO I THINK THE
SOLUTIONS FOR ON IT YEAH IF YOU
GAVE AREAS.
WELL DONE STILL THERE.
I KNOW I KNOW ALL RIGHT WE WILL
WE'RE GONNA GO SUPER FAST HERE.
YOU GET YOURSELF READY WE'RE
GONNA ROLL THROUGH THE CALL SO
YOU CAN YOU CAN GET ALL YOUR
EYES NAY SUBSTANTIAL.
YOUR TO CLOSE THEM.
A BECAUSE ON THE CONSENT YEAH.
AND ONE TO FIVE GREAT ARE
[inaudible]
MY BED.
I WAS JUST THINKING OF ALLEN.
I THINK CLOSER ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CLOSER ON THE REST I
CALLED BECAUSE ROLL ON
I DIDN'T
MEAN FOR SO LONG WE CAN.
AND ALL RIGHT WE'LL LEAVE IS UP
TO THE PARLIAMENTARIANS JUDGE
LATER BUT INTENT WAS NOT TO
ACTUALLY OF CLOSE THE RULES ON
THE PRO THE CONSENT CALENDAR SO
WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIVE SB.
ONE NINETY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN FORGES.
OR JUST I BELIEVE THAT ON CALL.
808- IT ONE NINETY AND SEVEN
NINETEEN OF THE TWO ITEMS ON
CONSENT.
OKAY -- AND NOW WE'RE GONNA JUMP
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHT HUESO IS SB THREE THIRTEEN
KERN VOTE IS SIX ZERO MOTION IS
TO PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
SENATE ALLEN BURGESS.
A SO WE'LL LEAVE THAT ON CALL.
OF FOR AS ABSENT MEMBERS AND
THEN WHAT A NINE SB THREE NINETY
FIVE DO PASS AS AMENDED EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
OF WAGES.
OR JUST OUTLINED ZERO WILL CLOSE
THE ROLE THEIR NUMBERS -- THAT
BILLS OUT.
NUMBER TEN IS BEFORE FOR SIXTY
THREE CURRENT PHONE IS SIX ZERO
TWO PASSED ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
PLEASE CLASS MEMBERS ALAN FORGES
[inaudible]
HUESO.
HEY HAS SIX AND ARE I WILL LEAVE
THAT ON CALL -- WHAT WE GOT LEFT?
HE THEN WE HAVE. FOURTEEN SEVEN
OKAY SORRY.
YOUR YEARS ON ELEVEN NUMBER
TWELVE WELL OKAY SB FIVE SEVEN
SIX NUMBER IS SIX TO ONE TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SENATE ALLEN FORGES. ZERO SIX
ONE SIX ONE SO WE WILL BE.
IN THE END OF I WILL PUT THAT ON
CALL AND THEN.
A FOURTEEN SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
GLAZER FIVE TO ONE TO PASS TO
GET GEO.
YES SIR SO WE'RE ON FOURTEEN
IT'S SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN IT'S A
THE CALL THE TEST LE ALLE ME
TEST EXPANSION AREA YES SIR.
HELLO AND IS ALLEN ORANGES.
ARE JUST NOW HUESO.
OKAY SO THE BILL IS OUT -- WE
WILL.
YOU KNOW A FELONY ONE LEGAL
OWNER.
BET ON ALL. FOURTEEN IS STILL
LONG CALL THE CURRENT LOTUS
.
FIVE TWO TWO WE'RE A CALL RECESS
SENATOR ALLEN WE ARE GOING TO
LIFT THE CALLS FOR A BUNCH OF
WONDERFUL MEASURES HERE.
ALL OF YOU IN TV LAND WE ARE
RECONVENING SENATE NATURAL
RESOURCES AND WATER.
THE FIRST ITEM UP IS THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
FILE ITEM FIVE AND THIRTEEN ONE
NINETEEN SEVEN NINETEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL SENATE ALLEN.
ALLEN I WAS ROUTE NINE OKAY
CLOSER ON THAT THAT IS OUT --
NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX SB.
I'M SORRY.
EIGHT SORRY SB THREE THIRTEEN
HUESO DO PASSED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON JUDICIARY -- THAT IS SB THREE
THIRTEEN PLEASE CALL ABSENT
MEMBERS SENATOR ALLEN.
ELLEN HI.
AT THE BILL'S OUT CLOSE ROLE IS
BE -- VIOLIN TEN AS BEFORE SIXTY
THREE STERN TO PASS TO COMMITTEE
ON THE QUEUE [inaudible]
SENATOR ALLEN.
BUT ALLEN AYE.
HOUSE AND IN THE BILL'S OUT
RELUCTANTLY -- FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE SB FIVE SEVENTY SIX
NUMBER DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS OF THE S. AND
SENATOR ALLEN.
ALLEN HINES OF SEVEN IT'S OUT
WITH CLOSE ROLE THERE AND THEN.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST A FUN
FOURTEEN SB SEVEN SIXTY SEVEN
GLAZER DO PASSED. TO THE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION CURRENT VOTE IS.
FIVE TWO TWO SENATOR RUNNING ON
SENATOR ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE THE HOUSE OKAY.
BILLS AT SIXTY TWO AND WITH THAT
WE ARE ADJOURNED [inaudible]
OKAY